Mova Max, hier wo die Nerds sprechen, die auch Freundinnen haben.
Vor allen Dingen war Lost ja auch totaler Quatsch. Also das ist eine Realität.
Wieso?
Also bei Lost waren eigentlich ähnliche Dinge genauso wie im Apple-Universum unterwegs. Und immer wenn alle mit Spannung auf den bestimmten Moment hingefiebert haben, puff war auf einmal alles ganz anders, als man gedacht hat.
Wir dürfen übrigens explizit nur Saffo-Work-Schokolade essen.
Genau, das ist erlaubt.
Da ist so viel gekommen.
Die mochte Holli nicht, oder was?
Wollen wir erzählen, was kommt? So, wollen wir mal ein bisschen hier eine Glaskugel machen?
Ja, aber sie haben uns ja auch eigentlich kaputt gemacht, ne? Da sagen wir einfach von vornherein, was da anounced wird.
Hat doch bestimmt bei den Fanboys gehört mit dem.
Bleiben Sie dran! Schalten Sie sie nicht weg.
Gleich nach der Kinderwärmung.
Gleich gibt's wirklich WWDC. Ich hab, ich hab, weißt du, dass es so viel Neues geben wird?
So, worauf haben wir jetzt Lust?
Gleich zum Anfang, heute gleich mal.
Der richtig langweilige Teil.
Versioniert, Auto gesaved, State gesaved. The whole enchilada.
Sie können natürlich gerne mein neues MacBook Air vorstellen, da hab ich jetzt überhaupt kein Problem mit.
Ach so, Notifications wären besser mit iOS 5. Das ist glaube ich schon mal gesetzt. Ha!
Genau.
Ich glaube auch. Diese Notifications, die sind auf der Bühne.
Also wenn sie kommen, dann sind sie auf der Bühne. Weil dann sind sie irgendwie smart und nett und mit Bildchen und ein paar neue Gesten, womit man sie easy peasy zur Seite schieben kann. Die ziehst den Screens nach unten und hält sie so.
Ach, das ist doch geil.
Das ist Zeit auch generell über diesen Homescreen.
Ja, stimmt.
So ist das auf jeden Fall fertig.
Also ich fand ja mal E-Mail-Verschlüsselung ganz geil, dass wir endlich mal S-Mime einbauen, dieses Scheißteil. Ich verstehe nicht, warum, aber ich finde, ich...
Wie Fullscreen-Apps, die man dann auch so irgendwie wie offline und später so durchswipen kann, so irgendwie wie bei WebOSD-Karten und so.
Naja, genau, da gibt es auch dieses Gerücht, dass Twitter irgendwie da drin landet.
Dass das dann in iOS integriert wird.
Montag mit einer Beta-Version von iOS 5. Extensions for Mobile Safari. Extensions for Mobile Safari.
So I get to talk about iCloud.
We've been working on this for some time now.
Und dann hat man alles was man auf dem iPad und Mac hat, hat man automatisch auch auf dem iPhone. Also Dokumente wird auf jeden Fall kommen. Kann ich euch sogar haargenau sagen, warum das kommen wird, worauf meine Prognose basiert. Und zwar gibt es jetzt iWork fürs iPhone.
Und mit iCloud müsste es an jedem Programm möglich sein, alles Mögliche über diese Cloud zu sünden.
iCloud wird mobile ersetzen.
Ja, vielleicht wird es auch eine Erfolgsgeschichte, weil es kostenlos werden.
Wie wird der iCloud-Musikdienst aussehen? Wird es einen geben? Und dann, dass nicht wirklich dein mp3 hochgespielt wird, sondern es nachgeguckt wird, was haben wir denn da? Und das, wenn die Bitrate bei dir auf deiner lokalen Platte schlechter ist, als das, was die oben in der Wolke haben, dass sie dann sagen, okay, wir nehmen hier das mit der höheren Bitrate. Dann sag ich jetzt mal eine Bold Prediction. Und zwar, ich glaube, dass von Apple noch mal eine Uhr kommt. Eine Armbanduhr.
Ich würde sagen, wir stellen den Podcast auch ein.
Herzlich willkommen bei Bum Zag Return.
Ja, das war ja mal wieder eine Meisterleistung hier von unserem Freund David.
Applaus, Applaus, Applaus!
Ich hab doch mit der Uhr nur gesagt, dass wir irgendwann mal kommen.
Das hat dich den Sieg gekostet, mein Freund. Doch, hier der Lukas hat hier ne schöne...
Warte mal, jetzt, jetzt, jetzt, da gehen wir gleich mal schön.
Was?
Das arbeiten wir hier mal ab. Da stehen ja auch ein paar Sachen bei dir, die so nicht stehen.
Ja, also wir haben auf jeden Fall, also erst mal Hallo, hier ist MobileMix.
MobileMix.
Das war meine Club-Marte. Und ja, wir sind komplett, würde ich mal sagen.
Dennis? Wo ist Dennis?
Wo ist eigentlich Dennis?
Die kommen gleich.
Okay, Dennis ist noch nicht da. Aber, ja, was soll ich sagen? Ich würde sagen, wir leben hier von Feedback mehr als wir es uns jemals hätten vorstellen können.
Das Intro dauert mittlerweile länger als die Sendung.
Ja, David übernimmt das dann einfach. Der recycelt einfach aus den alten Sendungen so viel Material, dass wir gar nichts Neues mehr dazusenden sollen.
Und wenn wir nichts bringen, dann spielt er mal die Keynote ein oder irgendwie sowas?
Wir wiederholen uns ja sowieso, laufend. Von daher, und wir reden auch immer dasselbe.
Und nie über Merck.
Jetzt verrat nicht, dass hier die Hälfte der Sendung von Band kommt.
Von Platte meinste, wa?
Und leg die Nokia-Tapes weg.
Und dass Dennis in Wirklichkeit seit zwei Jahren tot ist.
Tja, ja, so ist das.
So ist das.
Ja, derweil... derweil... klangen sich hier schon wieder alle über die Sound-Settings.
Endlich, komm ist Dennis wieder da. Letztes Mal gab es keine Audio-Probleme, da ging es straight los.
Ja, ich hab mittlerweile wieder mal ein paar Experimente aufgenommen.
Ich werd morgen das Setup hier nicht bedienen können.
Naja, das ist wirklich so eine Sache mit diesen komplizierten Setups. Aber ihr wisst ja, wie es ist. Es muss weitergehen. Und wenn es nicht weitergeht, dann geht es halt nicht weiter.
Erzähl mal weiter, dass nichts passiert in den letzten zwei Wochen, worüber wir reden müssten. Wir müssen irgendwie Zeit tot schlagen.
Das stimmt.
Hast du gerade dein Bitcoin zugemacht?
Ich habe es in den Hintergrund geklickt, mein Freund.
So, da waren ganz schön viele Zeilen, du. Kriegst du schon Überweisungen, ja?
Naja, so im Mikrobenbereich, ja.
Alle geizig.
Haben alle nix?
Nee, alle geizig.
Gab es jetzt nicht irgendwie so einen Bitcoin-schwarzen Freitag, wie Spiegel Online geschrieben hat, wo irgendwie der Kurs nicht mal habiert hat?
Hat es ja auch schon alle wieder.
Also sowas nennt man dann Gewinnmitnahmen oder Kurskorrektur, glaube ich, wenn man über die richtigen Börsen berichtet.
Ich besitze 0,16 Bitcoins.
Ich noch ja auch nicht.
Wollen wir jetzt wirklich gleich über Bitcoin reden? Ich finde, wir sollten jetzt einfach mal gleich voll einsteigen. Windows 8. Dennis, du kannst jetzt auch deinen Senf fleißig dazugeben, denn du hast ja gefehlt letztes Mal, als wir uns hier allerlei Prognosen aus dem Leib gesugen haben. Achso, ich wollte hier noch die Seite von Lukas erwähnen. Lukas F hat sich nämlich auch hier richtig die Kante gegeben und mal unsere ganzen Predictions zusammengegeben. Wobei ich sagen muss, wir haben uns ja wirklich nur zu einem echt kleinen Teil wirklich so geäußert, im Wesentlichen eigentlich über iCloud. Mir ist auch ehrlich gesagt jetzt eine Woche später immer noch so einiges nicht so richtig klar, aber das können wir ja hier gleich mal kollektiv klären. Aber so richtig schlecht haben wir nicht gelegen.
Wir haben schon schlechtere Voraussagen.
Wir haben schon schlechtere Voraussagen gemacht, das ist wahr, das ist wahr.
Das macht die Übung.
Ich weiß ja nicht ganz genau, also ich kann die Statistik, die hier der Lukas so herangezogen hat, nicht so ohne weiteres nachvollziehen, aber ich habe den höchsten Balken, und daher muss es stimmen.
Nee, da können wir ja nochmal schön drüber.
Ich habe dich auf den letzten Metern abgehängt.
Nur weil hier so Punkte drin sind wie ein neuer Homescreen. Es gibt keinen neuen Homescreen.
Das war die Armanduhr.
Nein, du hast hier einen neuen Homescreen prediktet, der steht in der Liste drin. Die Liste lügt nicht. Anzeigen von Kalenderevents, Tasks etc. gibt es nicht. Kein Homescreen, der das macht.
Doch, in den Notifications ist das drin.
Nee, der zeigt dir nur, so wie bisher, wenn er dich an einen Termin erinnert. Nur das zeigt er an.
Naja, wir können das ja mal alles mal so durchgehen. Und du kannst ja dann seine Statistik nochmal korrigieren. Und ich werde dann einfach mal im Zweifelsfall einfach das Gegenteil behaupten von dem, was ich vorher gesagt habe. So redet man sich raus.
So machst du das!
Du warst interessiert mich mein Geschwätz von gestern.
Genau.
Und glaube ich, kein Statistik, die du nicht selber gefälscht hast.
Man muss ja auch zukunftsorientiert arbeiten.
Vorwärts immer, rückwärts immer.
Gut, dass wir diese Sendung nie aufnehmen. Sonst könnte man das noch mal nachprüfen.
Entweder Ochs noch Esel auf! Na gut, kommen wir hier mal so ein bisschen in die Spur. Dennis, was hast du eigentlich so gemacht in der Zwischenzeit?
Ich?
Ja.
Ich dachte, wir wollten jetzt über die Predictions reden. Wenn jetzt Dennis weiß, was er so gemacht hat.
Der ist ja nicht so prediktet, deswegen kann er ja vielleicht mal... Hast du denn irgendwas prediktet? Hast du so in deinem Kämmerlein gesessen und dir Notizen gemacht? So, irgendwas vorzuweisen? Irgendein digital unterschriebenes Dokument? Mit Zeitstempel, mit dem du belegen könntest, dass du so richtig gelegen hast?
Nee, aber was ich gedacht ist, weil kurz vor der WWDC gab es ja hier diese Ankündigung, dass sie diesen Notification-Typen eingekauft haben, ne?
Einen weiteren, ja.
Dass sie ihn offentlich auspeitschen auf der Bühne?
Also der, der das für das Jailbreak da irgendwie macht. Und dann dachte ich mir, wenn sie den jetzt einkaufen, dann haben sie ja wahrscheinlich irgendwie bei diesem iOS noch nichts mit den Notificationen.
Ja, aber sie haben ja sicher schon vorher den Typen von WebOS geholt.
Aber das kam auch nur so knapp raus. Der war schon länger dabei.
Ich glaube, dass sie es um zwei Füße auch selber hinbekommen hätten.
Aber warum holen sie sich den dann noch rein? Gerade wenn er so ein Jailbreak-Typ hier ist, das ist irgendwie, entweder sind sie noch nicht so weit oder... Ja, deswegen hat es mich gewonnen.
Und dann ist ja auch noch alles von Android geklaut, habe ich gelesen.
Ja, ich habe das nicht nur gelesen, ich habe das auch gehört.
Ich hab's gesehen!
Du hast auch schon mit Android gearbeitet. Ist das neue Notification-Feature genauso?
Na, es sieht schon verdammt ähnlich. Also es sind Detailunterschiede.
Welche?
Na, es ist zum Beispiel, es ist bei Android, gibt es ein Alle Notifications löschen-Button. Bei iOS gibt es Pro App, was eine Notification anzeigt. Mit einem Notifications löschen-Button. Aber ansonsten ist es schon verdammt nah dran.
Na, damit ist es natürlich was ganz anderes.
Und selbst wenn, da gibt es ja wieder so einen Patent-Streit, dann eidigen sich nach ein paar Monaten wieder Ruhe.
Genau, und Microsoft nimmt die Kohle ein.
Gucken wir mal. Stimmt. Ja, aber sie fangen sich auch die gleichen Probleme ein, die Android damit hat. Das ist ein bisschen meine Befürchtung.
Welche denn?
Ich finde das Android-Notifications-System nämlich gar nicht gut.
Ich habe einen Vorschlag.
Aber sagen wir so, es ist auf jeden Fall jetzt besser als vorher, oder? Also ich war nämlich auch am Zocken. Ich bin jetzt immer noch so ein bisschen am Geodefense-Zocken und so. Und wenn du da mittendrin irgendwie die Nachricht kriegst und dein App klickt irgendwie weg oder weißt schon, ist das schon ein bisschen blöd.
Also ich hatte vom iPad Boxcar runtergeschmissen, wenn mich diese ständigen Notifications so genervt haben. Und gerade wenn man irgendwie mal einen Tweet mit vielen Replies abgesetzt hat und dann spielen wollte, dann hat es echt genervt.
Was ich ja noch für einen schicken Sport gemacht habe, muss ich gerade mal erwähnen. Seitdem bei Game Center die Full-Names da angezeigt werden, dachte ich mir, ich haue mal meine ganzen 500 Follower wieder raus. Also hier die Game Center Friends. Da war ich also morgen noch nicht so richtig müde anscheinend. Also ich gehe mal morgens ins Bett gerade. Dann habe ich zwei Stunden gebraucht oder länger, weiß ich gar nicht, um alle 501 wieder rauszulöschen. Weil ich habe nichts gefunden, wo man die alle mal löschen kann. Euch habe ich natürlich drinnen gelassen.
Zwei Stunden Game Center Friends löschen.
Das war mein Rekord.
Aber ich habe keine Cheat-Ments bekommen.
Warum hast du jetzt alle gelöscht?
Ich wollte immer loswerden. Außerdem bin ich jetzt wieder der Erste.
Es gibt eine Cheat-Ments dafür, wenn man Game Center Freunde löscht.
Was da auch für Leute sind, da sind Leute, die haben irgendwie, keine Ahnung, 200-300 Games oder so.
Ich hab da auch so eine Statistik gesehen, kürzlich, wo nach letztes Jahr der Anteil von den top beliebtesten Grossing-Apps noch so Hälfte, Hälfte Productivity und die andere Hälfte Games war. Mittlerweile ist es so irgendwie, da verschwinden kleine Teilen noch so Productivity-Apps und der Rest irgendwie alles Games.
Ja, also Apple sollte sich mal das überlegen, ob sie, also auch auf dem Mac irgendwie, dass sie das schon mal ein bisschen fördern könnten.
Dass sie was fördern könnten?
Games!
Machen sie ja überhaupt nicht.
Na ist ja nicht so, dass sie jetzt keinen Fortschritt erzielt hätten.
Ja, aber es ist noch gering.
Was fehlt denn hier?
Duke Nukem Forever. Nee, aber da geht schon noch ein bisschen was. Also auch so grafikkartentreibermäßig hier. Also da gab es ja letztes Jahr oder war schon dieses Jahr, weiß nicht, aber das hat schon Fortschritte gemacht letztens. Aber ich denke mal, da ist noch Nachholbedarf im Gegensatz zum PC-Markt. Also auch mehr so aktiv mit den großen Spielefirmen zusammenarbeiten und das insgesamt so ein bisschen mehr pushen und so, die ein bisschen fördern. Also ich denke mal, es würde Apple ganz gut tun auch am Ende.
Aber es ist schön, wenn wir jetzt von den Notifications spontan auch gleich wieder zur Apple- und Spielepolitik gekommen sind. Das wird nichts hier mit dem schönen Abarbeiten der Predictions. Ich sag's gleich.
Naja, vielleicht müssen wir uns auch gar nicht so sehr an den Predictions abarbeiten, weil das hat ja das Intro schon ganz gut zusammengefasst. Kurz gesagt, wir haben so einiges erraten. Beziehungsweise ich dachte einfach mal, wir machen mal so voll Monty und gehen jetzt einfach mal die komplette Liste durch. Wir müssen nicht alles erwähnen, aber vielleicht so das, was uns sozusagen an der Stelle erwähnenswert erscheint, weil das ist ja jetzt eigentlich das erste Mal, dass sie jetzt komplett auf den Tisch legen, was alles wirklich in Line sein wird, abgesehen davon, was halt so in den letzten Monaten schon sich so vor sich hingelegt ist.
Da kann ich noch was anmachen, bevor wir da einspringen. Weil ich hab ja immer gesagt, dass ich es nicht geschafft hab. Also, dass die Person, die ich kenne, meine ich. Dass sie es nicht geschafft hat, den Lion auf irgendwie hier das aktuelle MacBook Pro, nämlich genau so eins, wie ich habe, zu installieren. Und das lag da dran, weil das geht auf dem aktuellen MacBook Pro nicht. In manchen Fällen, und zwar der Lion kommt, da ist der WLAN-Treiber, früher auch genannt Airport, den nennt man jetzt wohl auch noch, Wi-Fi und so. Aber der Treiber jedenfalls, der ist irgendwie kaputt. Und wenn man den Lion bootet oder auch schon den Installer, dann bleibt er genau beim Laden von diesem IO-802-11-Family-Caxt, da bleibt er irgendwie hängen. Und wenn man den rausschmeißt, dann geht's. Also zunut einen anderen Rechner nehmen, sich einmal das Lion installieren, dann diesen scheiß Treiber irgendwie einfach wegloppen, und dann funktioniert es auch.
Aber jetzt ist doch eh gerade eine neue Lion-Version rausgekommen, zur WWDC, die wird da wohl funktionieren, oder?
Ne, genau das gleiche.
Ach echt?
Epischer Fehlschlag.
Und der Witz ist, es ist noch nicht bei allen Leuten, sondern nur bei manchen. Aber schon ziemlich viel, ich würd mal sagen, also eine deutliche Summe. Also es ist ein bekanntes Problem, sie haben ja auch relativ schnell rausgefunden, was es ist. Und ja, ist gar nicht so schlecht, das Lion.
Ja, was haltet ihr denn jetzt von dieser Idee, dass wir hier mal einfach mal durchgehen?
Ja, wenn es nicht zu lange dauert.
Also so zwei, drei Stunden würde ich auch mitgehen.
Naja, also ich meine, wir haben jetzt hier so die einzelnen Gruppen, das hat den Vorteil, dass wir dann auch schön beieinander sind.
Ist es relevant, ob wir eine Meinung haben dazu oder nicht?
Nein, das ist nicht relevant. Jetzt wo wir sowieso hier gerade zusammensitzen. Manches haben wir ja auch schon besprochen und müssen wir jetzt nicht unbedingt nochmal in voller Tiefe machen, aber es gibt hier zum Beispiel einen Bereich Accessibility, da gibt es ja ein absolutes Lieblingsfeature. Ihr seht es auch gerade, wenn ihr hier mal diesen Mauszeiger, diesen Vergrößerten euch hier anschaut. Ja, wir haben es nach 10 Jahren Mac OS X Entwicklung geschafft, den Cursor so zu skalieren, dass er nicht pixelig ist. Krass. Ist nicht geil?
Das ist schon eine Leistung. Das will ich sehen. Das haben wir auch irgendwann schon mal in irgendeiner Sendung richtig mal gehabt. Und jetzt kommt die Vision in die Realität. Wir können uns ja auch von jeder Gruppe einfach die schönsten Features nur schnell machen.
Wir waren so, als wenn wir unserem Test, dass wir ihn zwar größer machen konnten, aber er wurde noch billig hochskaliert. Kann das sein? Wir hatten das schon mal getestet hier, wenn ich mich richtig erinnere.
Ja, stimmt. Der war nämlich... Du hast jetzt hier grad Lion. Der ist nur ein bisschen besser als der. Der ist aber immer noch nicht...
Also, High Resolution ist das noch lange nicht.
Ist noch nicht Full HD.
Vielleicht ist das 32x32 Pixel oder sowas, aber...
Tim braucht den Full HD-Cursor.
Ja, irgendwas müssen sie sich auch noch für Mac OS X 8 vorbehalten, ne?
Also, ich finde ja, in diesem Accessibility-Bereich sind ja immer wieder so ein paar lustige Sachen, die man so verwenden kann, aber die haben eben so nicht auffallen, weil man eben nicht unbedingt jetzt drüber nachdenkt, wenn man nicht unbedingt besonders eingeschränkt ist. Aber gerade hier so diese Zooming-Features, die gehörten ja da auch immer schon dazu. Jetzt gibt es irgendwie ein Picture-in-Picture-Zoom. Picture-in-Picture-Zoom? Naja, du kannst wohl irgendwie einen Teil des Bildschirms nur vergrößern, damit du den Ausschnitt siehst, aber der Rest zoomt dann nicht automatisch mit. Das find ich schon mal ganz cool.
Fensterzoom sozusagen.
Ich find ja auch dieses ganze Voice-Over, das ist eigentlich eine super wichtige Geschichte. Nicht nur wegen der eigentlichen Zielgruppe. Wir hatten das ja auch schon ausführlich, auch mit dem iPhone und so weiter. Blinde und wer auch immer in irgendeiner Form nicht über alle Dinge und Möglichkeiten verfügt, der hat dann natürlich auch was davon. Aber was mich besonders gefreut hat über dieses Voice-Over im Besonderen ist, dass sie eben sicherstellen müssen, dass einfach das ganze GUI und die ganze Art und Weise, wie so eine Applikation sich so in den User hineinrendert, einfach in geordneten maschinenlesbaren Wegen gehen muss. Damit eben so ein Subsystem automatisch dir jedes Detail vorlesen kann etc. Und das erhöht einfach die Großqualität.
Hier, Yearless Birthdays, Adressbuch. Großartig. Darauf hab ich gewartet. Darauf hat die Welt gewartet, auf jeden Fall.
Ja, da fragt man sich wirklich, warum das so lange dauert. Das hat doch jeden schon mal genervt. Oder warum muss man immer das Geburtsjahr wissen, um jemanden zu einem Geburtstag zu sehen?
Also ich hab das ironisch gemeint, aber okay.
Aber sag mal, Jungs, hier iPhone, Version 4, da kann man ja Geburtstage eingeben. Es gibt ja den Geburtstagskalender, richtig? Und wenn du den Kalender auch rufst, ist ja überall ein schöner Punkt, wo Leute Geburtstag haben. Und dann klickst du drauf und da steht nicht dabei, welches Jahr. Dass du mal weißt, wie alt jetzt werden. Und du kannst auch nicht einsteigen, okay, ich hab hier den Geburtstagskalender und mach mal bitte an dem Tag, wo Leute Geburtstag haben, so eine kleine Notification, irgendwie mittags um 12, einfach für alle so grundsätzlich. Geht auch alles irgendwie nicht. Haben die bei Apple keinen Geburtstag oder was?
Ne, gratulieren sich einfach gegenseitig nicht.
Steve Jobs ist nicht mehr drauf hingewiesen.
Wahrscheinlich haben die das wegautomatisiert. Es gibt wahrscheinlich so einen Firmserver und der macht das immer für alle.
Ein Open-Delectron.
Ich würde sagen, da geht noch ein bisschen was.
Naja, aber jetzt kannst du sie zumindest auch gleich ohne Jahr eingeben und dann musst du dich nicht ärgern.
Das ist schonmal ein Anfang.
Naja, auf jeden Fall kann man jetzt auch Twitter-Accounts und Facebook-Accounts eintragen. Das finde ich ja auch schon mal einen Schritt nach vorne.
Das hab ich nicht gefunden.
Gibt es dieses iMessage eigentlich auch auf dem Lion denn?
Ne, bisher nicht.
Da müssen wir nochmal separat drüber reden, dieser ganze Chat-Kram. Ich weiß nicht, wie viele Telefonie und Chat-Protokolle Apple noch erfinden will, die zueinander inkompatibel sind. Ich dreh total am Rad. Facetime hier, iChat da.
Na gut, iChat ist irgendwie hier Mac.com-Accounts gewesen und so weiter. Und iMessage ist ja telefonnummern-based.
Nicht nur. Und Facetime ist...
Ja, aber Facetime ist auch irgendwie telefonnummern-based und basiert sicherlich auch irgendwie auf derselben Technologie, aber ist auch nicht miteinander verbunden. Also, ich meine...
Die sollen mal klacken, die googeln ganz schön rum.
Ja, das ist... Na gut, also wir verlassen das Adressbuch.
Ja, und gehen straight into AirDrop.
Ja, was ist hier...
Haben wir das jemals schon mal in echt jetzt ausprobiert eigentlich?
Hat hier irgendjemand klein?
Nee, ich auch nicht.
Ich könnte, ich könnte.
Mach doch mal was.
Ach, jetzt nur wegen diesem AirDrop.
Ich muss kurz den Rechner von meinem Kumpel hier aus der Tasche holen.
Achso, du hast noch den Zweitrechner für...
Für alle Fälle.
Für das Not-OS. Also AirDrop ist das Feature, was eben dieses Problem lösen soll. Das ist auch eine der Sachen, die wir hier schon mal heftigst beklagt haben. Also ich hab das zumindest heftigst beklagt. Dass es einfach immer noch so Schweine schwer ist, mal eben eine Datei von einem Rechner auf den anderen zu kriegen, wenn man so gemeinsam in einem Raum sitzt.
Ich hab das Gefühl, das Klagen wird nicht direkt aufhören.
Weil sie haben es so gemacht, dass man nicht mal mehr im gleichen Netz sein muss.
Ja, das ist nämlich auch das, was ich mich gefragt habe. Es ist dieses No-Network-Gefreier, dass wenn ich das richtig sehe, machen sie da ein Computernetzwerk auf, sozusagen. Und ich vermute mal, ich kann schwören, dadurch, dass dein normale WLAN-Connection, damit du eigentlich nicht verlieren solltest, sagen wir mal, zwei Menschen sitzen in einem Raum. Und jeder ist in einem anderen WLAN.
Meinst du, dann geht's noch?
Geht's noch?
Ich weiß es nicht. Aber ich meine, ähm, Doesn't require, was steht denn hier nochmal ganz genau? Peer-to-peer Wi-Fi, Doesn't require, okay, dann geht's wahrscheinlich nicht. Aber wenn ich das richtig sehe, ist, du brauchst keinen WLAN, sondern sie nutzen eben auch mehr oder weniger automatisch dieses Computer-zu-Computer-Network. Das heißt, sie machen halt einfach so ein Peer-to-Peer Wi-Fi-Netz auf.
Aber erst in dem Moment, wo du auf AirDrop klickst, oder?
Genau, in dem Moment, wo du auf AirDrop klickst, aber das machen sie dann quasi automatisch. Du musstest dich selber einrichten und benennen oder sonst irgendwas. Das wird wahrscheinlich ein Hidden-AirDrop-Netzwerk sein. Ich hab eine Idee.
Diese WLAN-Karten, die haben jetzt noch mehrere Antennen, können die das auch so aufblicken?
Naja, du meinst, ob sie gleichzeitig in einem WLAN und da drin noch sein. Das war eben auch das, worüber ich nachgedacht hab. Ich weiß bloß nicht, inwieweit das auch für alte Rechner dann auch noch so ohne Weiteres geht. Also das ist auf jeden Fall ein Fragezeichen und da frage ich mich ernsthaft, wie sie es gemacht haben.
Also der Chat behauptet, dass da ganz schnell zwischen assoziierten WLAN und Beacon Discovery umgeschaltet wird.
Wollen sie multiplexen? Das glaube ich ja nicht.
Wir können ja gleich mal gucken, wann man überhaupt den anderen sieht, ob man da wirklich dieses AirDrop-Fenster dafür aufmachen muss oder ob man da... Achso, ich muss erstmal Wi-Fi aktivieren. Siehst, jetzt muss ich es doch wieder anmachen. Der Tim hat nämlich gesagt, ich muss das Wi-Fi hier ausmachen.
Also ich hoffe schwer für die Herren Apple, dass sie die vollmundigen Versprechungen, die sie da auf diese Seite schreiben und auch in den Ankündigungen verlautbaren haben lassen, dass sie dann auch eintreten, dass das wirklich einfach gut funktioniert und nicht wieder irgendwie so ein...
Die Herren Apple.
Ja, die Herren Apple, so ein Filesharing-Desaster wird.
Ich frag mich ja, warum das das iPhone und iOS nicht macht.
Was?
Warum ist das nicht im iPhone und iOS drinne? Oder wird das für Wi-Fi-Sync genutzt?
Warum ist das nicht in der iCloud?
Nein, nicht in der iCloud, sondern so, dass ich irgendwo unterwegs bin, gerade jetzt keinen WLAN oder kein schnelles Netz habe und mal kurz von meinem...
Du sollst einfach Hocker kaufen.
Und mir mal kurz auf dem iPad Fotos angucken will, die ich auf dem iPhone gemacht hab, ist ja jetzt wirklich keine Seltenheit, oder? Das ist doch ein sehr häufig auftretender Anwendungsfall.
Tja, also ich bin auch ehrlich gesagt noch so ein bisschen skeptisch mit diesem AirDrop.
Da haben sie sich was Schönes zusammengebaut.
Naja, also gucken wir mal.
Gucken wir mal. Willst du mal weiter scrollen, Timmer?
Ja, scroll auch mal weiter hier.
Wenn du dich hier schon nicht am Gespräch beteiligst.
Genau, wenn du dich wieder da im Kult...
Äppelskript, können wir das bitte überspringen?
Ja, bitte.
Weil bei Äppelskript glaub ich gar nichts. Was die mir da alle schon seit Jahren versprechen, was man damit angeblich kürz machen kann, ist alles gelogen.
Kleines Detail zwischendurch, was ich irgendwo gelesen habe, dass iTunes diese 10.5 Beta, das die 64-Bit sei.
Ja, das hab ich auch gesehen. Da gab es so Screenshots und danach sieht es wohl tatsächlich aus. Das kann dann nur bedeuten, dass iTunes nicht mehr Carbon ist.
Oder dass die Carbon 64-Bit gemacht hat, weil...
Also durch wie viele Reifen, die schon gesprungen sind, habe ich die Carbon-Ups noch weiter zu supporten.
Ich hab da diese Diskussion gesehen, sogar der Rollbalken funktioniert noch so scheiße wie vorher. Also sie hätten wirklich was 1 zu 1 nachprogrammieren müssen.
Das Terminal geht wieder auf mit dem alten Inhalt nach dem Booten.
Das ist echt krass.
Resume, da kommen wir gleich zu.
Aber es ist nur, es ist grau. Aber es ist noch da. Wie geht man dieses Air-Drop, wenn wir schon mal noch mal dabei sind?
Du gehst in Finder und wählst da links Air-Drop aus. Das ist so in den Favoriten drin. Gibt's bestimmt auch bei Gear zu.
Ich sehe hier keinen Air-Drop.
Go Air-Drop gibt's auch nicht. Denn es hat keinen Air-Drop.
Ich weiß noch warum. Ich muss das 802L Family Cacks entfernen, weil ich hab kein WLAN da drin. Ich hab keinen WLAN.
Okay, man braucht WLAN? Na toll.
Obwohl wir beide am Kabel hängen.
Er hat mir auch explizit gesagt, dass er Wi-Fi einschalten muss.
Oh shit.
We're doomed. Wie, was, wie, was, wie, was, was?
Nehmt dich über Kabel.
Ohne WLAN geht's definitiv gar nicht.
Man kann Air-Drop nicht über Kabel machen?
Das heißt ja auch Air-Drop und nicht Wire-Drop.
Genau.
Du Drops.
Es ist keine drei Minuten her, dass ich gesagt habe, und ich glaub, das W-Klagen wird nicht aufhören.
Ernsthaft, das ist doch vollkommen bekloppt?
Voll überdroppt.
Also ich mein, weißt du hier so Bump und Hocker und wie so alle heißen so die Apps, die benutzen ja auch echt alles, um irgendwie so die Übertragung hinzukriegen. Denen ist das ja total egal. Und dann kommen die an und machen das nur über Wifi?
Das ist genau so bekloppt wie auch Facetime, nicht über alles Mögliche.
Air-Drop-Tonne.
Das kommt dann wahrscheinlich im nächsten Release. Begeisterungsströme, irgendwie Leute werden ohnmächtig. Zeitungen, Blogs berichten darüber in aller Ausführlichkeit und nehmen das einfach als die Begründung, warum Apple einfach da ist.
Ja, aber Internet über Kabel wäre schon geil, oder?
Schon ein bisschen advanced, oder?
Das ist ja nicht Wide Area Network, das ist ja Local Area Network.
Ja, aber wir brauchen auch nichts anderes. Also ich meine, diese Kabel-Scheiß, bloß weil du hier keinen funktionierenden Router hast, heißt das ja noch, bei anderen Leuten funktioniert das relativ gut.
Also ich bin enttäuscht.
Ja, ich auch. Also wenn das stimmt, dann bin ich auch enttäuscht. Entschuldigung, ich klicke hier gerade auf meinen Mischbetrieb.
Ja, da haben wir jetzt oben als Thema stehen Autosave.
Ja, das ist ein cooles Feature, aber ich meine, das ist wirklich auch schon viel debattiert worden, oder?
Ja, war dringend fertig, brauchen wir nicht weiter drüber zu reden. Außer über dieses kleine hässliche Menü da oben in der Titelleiste. Das finde ich ja bestenfalls so mittelgut gelöst.
Ja, aber was denkt ihr denn darüber? Also ich finde das ja eine wirklich, wirklich gute Idee. Und das ist etwas, wo ich schon bestimmt hier schon vor einem Jahr, wenn ich sogar schon vor zwei Jahren nachgeschrien habe, dass einfach Save muss weg.
Das ist vor allen Dingen, was das andere Essen einfach nicht haben.
Sie sind so endlich, dass das Kettensymbol in der Menüleiste losgeworden. Keine Ahnung. Bei Apple Works gab es das bestimmt mal.
Das Kettensymbol zum Saving?
Das gab es nicht mal bei Clarisse Works.
Ach, bestimmt gab es bei Clarisse Works ein Dissymbol.
Nee. Ich wette.
Eine Mate.
Die halte ich. Ich versuche mich jetzt mal zu erinnern, gibt es überhaupt irgendeine Software auf dem Mac, die nicht von Microsoft oder anderen Bekloppen geschrieben wurde, die sowas hat? Also ich meine, ein Save-Icon, also überhaupt im Toolbar ein Icon umzusichern, kann ich mich nicht...
Das muss es hier doch irgendwo jedem...
Gotteslästerung.
Ich wüsste gar nicht, wie das aussehen sollte, also das ist bestimmt keine Diskette. Aber Windows 8, das ist immer noch eine Diskette, oder?
Keine Ahnung, das haben sie irgendwann removed, aber ich habe heute irgendwo ein Diskettensymbol gesehen, und...
Windows 8?
Ist gerade aktuell.
Ja, aber Windows 8 kommt doch jetzt.
Ja, das ist ja schon ein großer Anliegen.
Es wird doch endlich mal alles ändern.
Wir sind doch hier gerade bei Autosafe.
Ja, genau, und Autosafe ist einfach total sinnvoll, dass Programme sich selber darum kümmern, bzw. noch besser, dass sie das dem Betriebssystem mehr oder weniger automatisch überlassen oder zumindest so einen Hook haben, dass das Betriebssystem das so zur Kenntnis nimmt, dass das Betriebssystem auch genau weiß, dass war jetzt ein Safe-Vorgang und dann eben auch die ganze Dokumenten-Historie damit macht. Was ihr ja, gut, das fällt dann wahrscheinlich hier eher unter Versions, aber sie haben ja auch dieses Time Machine Interface, mit dem ich immer schon so ein bisschen mal Probleme hatte, jetzt dafür auch noch aufgerufen, dass du da in deinem Dokument hin und hergehen kannst. Das ist schon, das ist wirklich schon eine gute Idee. Und das hängt ja auch alles zusammen mit diesem ganzen, du kannst jederzeit beendet werden und du kannst jederzeit resumen. Und wir können hier mal booten und das Programm kommt danach hoch und macht mit demselben unbe-anthaltet Dokument, wo du schon was reingeschrieben hast, einfach wieder genau da weiter, wo es aufgehört hat. Ja, das heißt du kannst jetzt einfach häufiger rebooten.
Endlich! Wir können wieder keine Panics einbauen.
Man kann jetzt einfach häufiger rebooten, ohne dass man jetzt großen Schaden davon hat.
Also wie gesagt, ich finde halt vor allen Dingen, es gibt kein anderes OS, was auch so annähernd so eine Feature bietet, oder? Ich meine, das ist jetzt schon mal so ein Alleinstellungsmerkmal vorerst, oder? Täusche ich mich.
Ja, und das höchstens 10 Jahre zu spät.
Welches?
Na ja, ich meine, haben wollen tut man das, seitdem man HyperCard das erstmal gesehen hat, oder?
Jaja, also ich meine Persistent Desktop. Das ist eigentlich genau die Vision, die sie da jetzt einführen. Und ja, das ist wirklich back to the Mac. Da hat iOS auf jeden Fall das schon mal gemacht. Und vor allem, es trägt dazu bei, dass man eben seine Arbeit eben wirklich mehr als Document sieht und nicht so sehr als File.
No.
Das habe ich zum Beispiel Microsoft auch immer sehr übel genommen, dass sie...
Wie du hast es benutzt?
So hält nichts falsch.
Das kann ganz, ganz böse nach hinten losgehen.
Voll erwischt.
Sagen wir mal, ich hatte feinen Kontakt.
Schrotflintig.
Du warst schon mal an der Front.
Nee, du kennst das sicherlich. Wenn deutsche Versionen kamen von Microsoft... Wie heißt das File-Menü auf Deutsch?
Datei.
Weißt du, bis heute bei denen?
Nein.
Keine Ahnung. Ablager hieß es immer. Offenbar gab es keine Dateien.
Es ist nämlich nicht The File, sondern To File. Es geht ums Ablegen. Es geht nicht um Dateien. Aber bei Microsoft und bei manchen anderen, aber Microsoft war es immer besonders notorisch, hieß dann halt das Menü in der deutschen Übersetzung Datei. Heißt aber nicht Datei.
Heißt Ablage.
Das sind so Momente, wo ich schon immer so ein bisschen zusammengezuckt bin. Wo ich auch gemerkt habe, die haben das eigentlich gar nicht verstanden mit diesen document-oriented Applikationen.
Sie wissen nicht, was sie da geklaut haben. Das ist mir auch immer aufgefallen.
Ja, Docs.
Also ich rede auch von den Applikationen auf dem Mac.
Ja, natürlich liegt das an den Übersetzern. Aber das ist halt auch...
Nee, sie haben es konsequent falsch übersetzt.
Das ist auch eine falsche Denkweise an der Stelle. Es geht halt ums Ablegen in dem Menü. Das sind halt die Dinge, die du tust, die mit Ablage zu tun haben. Rein, raus, hin und her, Zettel nehmen, desktop-Metapher usw.
Aber dieser zum Glück gibt es tot.
Und es geht nicht um Dateisysteme in dem Sinne.
Aber bei Word gibt es immer noch ein Diskettensymbol. Ich hab bei Claris tatsächlich, sie hatten für alles hässliche Symbole, aber für Safe-Nauswendung nicht.
Wir werden auch in 10 Jahren noch einen Festplatten-Icon sehen, auf dem wir alle eine SSD haben.
Nee, das werden wir nicht mehr.
Na ja, mal gucken, wie lange wir noch Fals sehen.
Ja, eben.
Weil die so weitermachen, nicht mehr lange.
Ja, aber das ist an sich gut. Man muss halt schauen, was da in der Zwischenzeit noch alles unter die Räder kommt. Es ist klar, dass jetzt Dateisysteme und Dateien jetzt nicht so schnell verschwinden werden. Also sie können jetzt nicht die nächste Katze ausgraben und dann gibt es kein Dateisystem mehr, sondern nur noch so ein opaken Document Store.
Aber auf der iCloud verwaltest du keinen Dateisystem.
Auf der iCloud verwaltest du keinen Dateisystem.
Ja, und auf dem iPhone ja auch nicht. Und darunter haben die auch das gleiche File System wie auf dem...
Das File System, das ist so eine Abstraktion wie Assembler-Code. Die Files sind eigentlich für das Speichern von Daten wie Assembler für das Schreiben von Programmen. Das generierst du zwar irgendwie, aber eigentlich siehst du das nicht und du denkst nicht in dieser Logik. Klar, wir jetzt so als halbwegs erfahrene Computer-Benutzer, die das ganze Elend seit 20-30 Jahren mitverfolgen, haben alles gesehen. Und für uns war auch irgendwann mal ein Dateisystem ein Fortschritt. Gab es ja auch mal nicht. Aber es ist halt nicht das, wie Menschen denken. Ich merke das immer wieder, wenn ich irgendwelchen Freunden, die jetzt nicht solche Computer-Wizards sind, die dann irgendwie fassungslos vor ihren Büchsen sitzen und sich fragen, was geht da ab.
Aber das liegt auch daran, dass dieses Fallsystem total zugemüllt ist. Also ich meine, du hast drei Libraries und weißt ja auch nie, wo irgendwas hinfällt. Wenn du jetzt irgendwie auf die Festplatte klickst und siehst halt irgendwie vier Orne und das ist so, dann ist ja auch nochmal eine andere Liga. Aber dadurch schon alleine, dass du drei Libraries hast und auch nie genau weißt, wo welches Fall jetzt überhaupt liegt oder wo es hin muss. Farbprofile.
Darum haben sie in Lion auch das Festplatten-Symbol rausgeschmissen, glaube ich.
Das ist doch ans Schnöleport auch schon weg.
Hier in der Seitenleiste ist das da noch? Aus dieser Favoritenleiste links.
Auf dem Desktop war es früher halt ja auch drauf. Und seit Schnöleport haben sie es ja auch da nicht mehr eingeblendet.
Kannst du einstellen?
Ja, aber die Fall war es früher an.
Ja, aber hier in dieser Seitenleiste, in dieser linken, da ist es bei Schnöleport noch drinnen. Die Festplatte und bei Lion nicht mehr. Also die zweite Festplatte, die ich habe, die ist da, aber die...
Zum Feiner kommen wir ja gleich noch. Jetzt sind wir noch bei Automator übrigens.
Toll! Ach komm, komm jetzt, so ein bisschen was überschrieben.
Ja, Automator ist so der nächste Versuch. Ja, bemerkenswert finde ich nur, dass sie da eben auch gleich Autosave Versions und so weiter überall einbauen. Aber es ist immer dasselbe mit Automator. Immer wenn ich probiere, alle zwei Jahre damit mal irgendwas zu automatisieren, stelle ich fest, dass es das eine, was ich gerade gebe, nicht gibt. Oder nicht funktioniert oder nicht versteht.
Oder nicht intuitiv ist vor allen Dingen.
Ich habe mal einen total coolen Workflow, von dem ich nie geahnt hätte, mit Automator hinbekommen. Nämlich Fotos von der Kamera runterladen per USB, die dann drehen, croppen und kleiner rechnen in einen Ordner packen und dann auch irgendwie eine HTML-Datei generieren. War super.
Hab ich auch schon mal gesehen, wo du irgendwie tausende Milliarden Fotos reinschmeißt und der da ein Zeug mitmacht, also so, da kann man schon schickere Sachen machen.
Ich benutze das nur, um Dateien umzubenennen. So, Großbuchstaben auf Kleinbuchstaben und sowas, wo man irgendwie auch unter, auf der Kommandozahle jetzt nicht sehr viel besser dran ist. Tja, der App Store.
Ich bin mal gespannt, also, ob du diesen, wenn du diesen Mac OS Installer aus dem App Store bekommen hast, ob du mit dem dann halt auch mal irgendwie Rechner installieren kannst, die halt, weißt du, eine neue Platte eingebaut und dann kannst du von nichts booten und wie kriegst du da jetzt den...
Ja, das ist mir auch irgendwie ein Rätsel. Also wie, wenn ich das nur in meinem App Store kaufe, wie richte ich einen Rechner auf, auf dem nichts drauf ist?
Hänne-Ei Problem.
Interessante Frage.
Und was machen wir, wenn jetzt dein Rechner abkackt, weil dein File-System kaputt ist und sie kuckelt, kein Problem, schließt es schnell an meinem OS an, wir booten über FireWire und ich repariere dir schnell deine Partition, dann geht das nicht, weil, wenn wir meine Platte irgendwie mit deinem Rechner booten, dann sagt er, nee, ist nicht autorisiert oder wie?
Nee, ich glaube, dem ist das total wurscht.
Also ich glaube, so eine Autorisation Fu werden sie nicht machen, aber so, ich meine, das ist ja schon immer mal so ein Anwendungsfall gewesen, den man so gemacht hat, so ein Image von so einem OS auf eine Platte restoren oder auf eine DVD brennen und dann halt mal irgendwelche Kisten, die nix drauf haben, mal installieren.
Vielleicht haben sie ja einen Burn-DVD-Feature in diesem Installer.
Von Apple direkt.
Ich meine, was ich zum Beispiel mal gemacht hab, meine Time Machine Festplatte, da hab ich eine Partition mit OS-Installer gemacht. Dann konntest du halt von der Platte booten und direkt dein Time Machine auch von der Platte restoren, alles in einem Rutsch und schnell. Musst halt nicht mit optischen Medien rumhantieren. Und hast beides in einem Ding so. Und so eine Geschichten. Mal schauen, wie das dann geht.
Naja, aber auf jeden Fall der Preis ist heiß. 29 Dollar und du darfst endlich auf so vielen Rechnern installieren, wie unter deiner Knute sind. Das finde ich ist eine gute Ansage.
Nach 5, oder?
Ich glaube, das Limit ist sogar auf 10 angehoben jetzt. Und 10 würde ich sagen, naja, das ist vielleicht... Das schaffst du jetzt nicht so. Ja, das ist auf jeden Fall etwas realistischer.
Das ist nicht etwas realistischer, das ist für jeden kompletter Overkill. Außer für dich vielleicht.
Und das ist auf jeden Fall total fair in jeder Hinsicht. Also wenn du mehr als 10 mit einem...
Dann kann man auch das Geld in das Tier nochmal 20 Euro herzulegen.
29, 99?
Also ich nicht, aber okay.
Na du hast halt noch deinen alten Laptop rumliegen und du hast noch einen alten iMac, der steht irgendwo...
Ja das ist doch eh alles nicht line-tauglich.
So sieht's aus.
Das geht ja hier generell um dieses Limit von autorisierten Computern etc. Also gut, das werden wir alles sehen, das wird man nicht ganz genau. Facetime ist jetzt dabei.
Aber Ring Anywhere, das finde ich ein sehr...
Turn Facetime off, man kann es sogar abschalten.
Aber das Ring Anywhere Feature finde ich interessant. Also du kannst es jetzt anklingeln, auch wenn er nicht mal Facetime an hat und auch nicht... Also...
Man kann mich nerven, obwohl ich gerade gar keinen Bock habe, genervt zu werden.
Ja, aber das ist doch jetzt auch schon so bei Facetime. Das ist doch gar nichts neu.
Nee, wenn es aus ist.
Was? Wenn es aus ist, wird es da auch nicht klingeln.
Na, aber wenn...
Aber wie? Aber wenn es jetzt an ist, dann klingelt es auch, wenn das Programm nicht oben ist. Das tut es jetzt dann auch schon. Also what's the difference? Was heißt jetzt Ring Anywhere?
Ring Anywhere heißt, dass du sowohl an deinem Mac als auch an deinem iPhone, als auch an deinem zweiten Mac deine Facetime-Calls annehmen kannst, wenn du willst. Das ist überall klingelt, wo du das eingeschaltet hast, dass es klingelt.
Aber war das bisher nicht so?
Doch, das war genau so.
Ach so.
Und hier ist nichts neu. Das steht da nur, weil Facetime halt jetzt dabei ist und kein, gib mir noch einen Dollar Einkauf ist. Das gehört dir ja nicht wirklich zu Snowlappert dazu. Und auch dieser HD-Kram und so weiter. Ich sehe jetzt hier nichts Neues. Vielleicht hier Adressbuch, Integration.
Das ist neu.
Nee, das ist nicht neu. Der Wahnsinn.
Ja, hier unser Lieblingsfeature denke ich mal. Das alleine ist für mich Lion schon wert. Full Disk Encryption. Ja, das ist einfach wirklich toll. Und das haben wir ja hier auch schon mehrfach erhoben. Gibt es da irgendwelche neuen Informationen eigentlich?
Naja, die Pedanten weisen ja noch darauf hin, dass es halt nicht eine Full Disk Encryption, sondern eine Full Partition Encryption ist.
Du nennst mich also ein Pedant, ja, nur weil ich mal wieder mehr Ahnung hab als du. Nee, aber es ist wirklich partitionsweise. Also man muss nicht die ganze Disk entcrypten, sondern man kann sich irgendwie seine Partition aussuchen. Das heißt, man kann sich voll die Movie Partition machen, wo man seine fetten Filme reinlegt und will, die vielleicht gar nicht gekryptet haben, weil kostet ja so ein bisschen Performance dann schon. Wobei wahrscheinlich überhaupt gar nicht, weil die CPUs hier von Intel, die können ja dieses neue AES...
Ja, vor allen Dingen...
Wie ist das?
Ja, aber...
New Instruction oder sowas. Und die haben das halt als Spezialkommand, also müsste ultraflott sein.
Aber vor allen Dingen ist ja so eine Whole Partition Encryption nochmal was ganz anderes als diese Sparse Images und angeblich sowieso generell viel performanter als diese...
Ja, das auf jeden Fall. Du hast halt nicht ein Filesystem, wo ein Filesystem drin ist und dieses File liegt wiederum in deinem normalen Filesystem, alles irgendwie doppelt gemoppelt. Das wird halt direkt draufgeschrieben, aber halt verschlüsselt. Das ist schon mal noch eine Runde flutschiger und wahrscheinlich auch nicht so sehr anfällig, dass da irgendwie was kaputt geht, hoffe ich. Also Filevolt war schon immer ein Problem und damit ein Backup sowieso, du musstest dich erst ausloggen, damit Time Machine ein Backup macht und so weiter und sofort. Denn, dass es irgendwie immer so größer wird und so wachsen muss, das ist auch... Also es schränkt sich zwar ab und zu, aber auch nicht so richtig.
Filevolt war Panyin CS.
Ja, es war einfach... Es war schon cool, ich benutze es und ich würde auch das immer benutzen, wenn es so bleiben würde, weil ich brauch das. Aber das ist schon ganz gut, wenn wir das jetzt mal ein bisschen verbessern.
Ja, und Instant Wipe ist halt auch...
Und vor allem, du kannst es halt einfach so auch für alle Partitionen machen. Also es steht ja auch so extra nochmal erwähnt, der External Drive Support. Das heißt, du kannst dir deinen USB-Stick entkrüpten, wenn du willst. Du kannst dir deinen externen Platten entkrüpten, wenn du willst. Ich nehme mal an, wenn man es sich jetzt genau überlegt, es ist ja so, dass wenn du eine Platte anschließt an Lion oder ich weiß nicht, bei StoleApp oder was auch schon, dann kommt ja gleich dieses Fensterchen. Hier, neue Platte gesehen, willst du da dein Time Machine Backup drauf machen? Dann denke ich mal, du kannst dir auch sagen, hier mach die mal entkrüptet und dann mach das an Time Machine auf die entkrüptete Festplatte. Eigentlich alles voll super.
Und dann lässt sie erstmal ein bisschen warm werden.
Ich wedel damit ein bisschen, damit der den Mund wässrig bekommt.
Ja super. Machen wir hier nächstes Thema.
Warte mal, Time Machine kommt aber hier nochmal, oder?
Bestimmt. Wir müssen mal ein bisschen auf die Tube drücken.
Da haben sie aber wirklich jeden Scheiß direkt hergenommen.
Und dieses XTS AES, was sie bei FileWallTour benutzen, sehe ich gerade, ist auch irgendwie was ganz frisch Neues, glaube ich. Ich weiß jetzt nicht ganz genau, was es ist, aber es ist irgendwie, glaube ich, nochmal eine neue, neue, neue, wie soll man sagen, nicht eine Kryptoart, aber AES in einer neuen Form, die besonders praktisch ist für Disk-Encoding.
Mit noch besserem NSA-Backdoor.
Ja, da irgendwas war da. Ich glaube, irgendwie bei IPSEC haben sie die auch irgendwie gerade.
Also die WGP ja meint XTS AES was standardized an 2007.
Dann ist es total neu. Ist so, wirklich. Weil es sich so durchdings, dauert ja aber eine Weile, bis es durch alle Standards durch ist und die das alle mal annehmen. Also bei AES gibt es ja nun schon ein bisschen länger jetzt als 2007.
Dann ist es total neu. Was heißt das?
Es ist einfach eine Variante von AES, die noch mal sicherer ist im Bezug auf bestimmte Attacken oder was?
Nee, nicht eine Variante, sondern wie das AES eingesetzt wird. Ich glaube, es geht ja darum, dass du musst ja jeden Block verschlüsseln und du kannst ja nicht bei jedem Block den gleichen Key nehmen, weil du kannst ja irgendwelche Attacken fahren und dieses XTS sorgt irgendwie dafür, dass es halt irgendwie ordentlich verteilt wird. Ich hab keine Ahnung, es ist jetzt hier Andreas Buch, er ist jetzt wieder wahrscheinlich voll in seinem Element.
In die Absence of Authentication or Access Control XTS-IS provides more protection than the other approved confidentiality-only modes against unauthorized manipulation of the encrypted data. Okay, auf jeden Fall machen das sowieso irgendwie alle und es ist gut, dass wir es auch machen.
Next Finder!
Finder! Das ist ja auch schon wieder so ein neuer Button da und auch der Versuch, die Leute nicht so sehr lost in directories sein zu lassen. Klickst halt da irgendwie drauf und hast da irgendwie so ein View. Ich weiß aber nicht ganz genau, was er da eigentlich anzeigt. Ich war ja schon noch nie ein Freund dieser Home Directory-Aufteilung, die Apple da verwendet hat. Und diesem Library. Und vor allem das sind auch so System-Sachen und deine eigenen Sachen auf derselben Augenhöhe. Das hat mich schon immer gestört. Also gerade dieser Library, Preferences usw. Das liegt da genauso nackt rum wie Documents. Und du hast überhaupt keine Ahnung, wo du was reintun sollst. Und es wäre natürlich Quatsch, in einen Library-Ordner was zu tun. Aber so ein Ordner der Bibliothek heißt, der lädt ja gerade dazu ein, dass du da wieder eine Bücher reinschmeißt oder so. Ich hatte früher, als das nicht gab, auf Mac OS 9, ich hatte immer einen Ordner, der hieß Bibliothek. Das war für mich der Ordner, wo ich Sachen abgelegt habe, die jetzt nicht so meine Documents sind, im Sinne von womit ich so konkret arbeite, sondern den ganzen Nachschlagekram. Referenzmaterialien, Bücher. Ja, ich finde, es sollte zumindest eine irgendwie geartete Trennung geben. Also es wäre cooler gewesen, sie wären auf irgendeine Idee gekommen, wie das für den Benutzer auch klarer zu trennen ist. Und auch diese ganze Vorgabe, wie die Ordner jetzt heißen. Ich meine, wenn Apple sich mal selber dran gehalten hätte, was schmeißt denn alles iTunes in den Music-Ordner rein? Applikationen, alles, ja. Also Beyond-Music.
In Lion ist Library hier gehitten.
Ist mir doch gar nicht aufgefallen, stimmt.
Ach echt?
Der Chat hat Recht. Zack, Punkt aufgegeben. Nächstes Thema, skip, skip, skip. Eigentlich das coolste Feature bei Finder ist, wenn man das Echo im Web gelesen hat, via Merge Folders. Da haben wir alle in der Zunge geschnallt, hatte ich das Gefühl.
Ja, das wurde mal Zeit. Dass man wirklich mal so zwei Ordner zusammenschmeißen kann und er ist in der Lage da, das einfach zusammenzusortieren.
Das konnte Windows schon seit 74. Weiß ich nicht, aber die können das.
Und Battery Name, das gibt es ja im Finder immer noch nicht. Na, mehrere Files auf einmal umbenennen. Das können sie dann in 10 nach 8 rausbringen.
Hab ich bisher noch nie gebaut.
Ach, ich hab das schon öfters mal gebraucht, ja.
Ich weiß, dass es Leute gibt, da gibt es ja ganze Tools für. Better, finer, renamen, was weiß ich auch.
Oh, und es gibt ein Group S-Folder-Kommando. Auch sehr hübsch. Ich werde übrigens gerade darauf hingewiesen, dass der Library-Ordner natürlich auch auf Deutsch Library Ordner heißt. Das ist natürlich richtig. Trotzdem heißt Library natürlich das. Und das ist auch nochmal besonders bekloppt. Auf der einen Seite übersetzen sie halt alles, aber dann übersetzen sie dann doch Sachen nicht. Was soll denn das? Der Library-Ordner ist nicht mehr zu sehen.
Ja, wir müssen weitermachen.
Ich mach mal weiter.
Wir sind bei F.
Jaja, aber das ist jetzt wirklich ein wichtiges Thema.
Und über einen unsichtbaren Ordner.
Was ist denn noch alles? Es gibt dann noch ein zweites Problem, was auch noch irgendwie total ungelöst ist. Das sind so diese ganzen Programme, die in so Dot-Files was ablegen. Was irgendwie auch nicht okay ist. Und dann gibt es aber noch ein Problem.
Das sind ja aber meistens Shale-Programme oder nicht.
Aber guck mal, wenn Library jetzt abgedinkt ist, was ist denn da noch drin?
Da sind dann diese Caches drin.
Dann hast du in Application Support installieren die Programme dann wiederum auch schon so Sachen, die du manchmal auch mit umziehen willst. Also die schon so Templates und so.
Die ziehen sie doch falsch.
Die ziehst du einfach um in dem hier mit Migrationsassistent.
Also willst du jetzt deine Files weghaben oder nicht? Vorhin warst du noch happy, dass das alles verschwindet und dass irgendwie alles automatisch ist.
Mit dem App Store ist das ja dann eher das Gesamt.
Also ein Library hat eigentlich auch gar keiner was zu suchen, außer er fühlt sich in einer Shell wohl.
So, nächstes Thema.
Das ist richtig, aber ich muss da trotzdem häufiger mal...
Also wer weiß, wie viele Leute sich schon ihr Home zerschossen haben, weil sie ein Library irgendwie rumgepopelt haben.
Ich noch nie.
Was ist denn das mit diesen Drag-Files? When you drag multiple files from one location to another, they flock together.
Mach mal ab für plus ein paar Mal.
Wahrscheinlich, dass wenn du die so durch die Gegend schiebst und diese Ghost-Icons kommen, die sie mit 7,5 eingeführt haben, dass sie nicht mehr an den ganz entfernten Stellen sind, so mit so einem undurchsichtigen Layer über den ganzen Bildschirm, sondern dass sie an einer Stelle neben einer Maus wahrscheinlich zusammenkommen.
Das ist wahrscheinlich wirklich so wie bei Windows dann.
Weiß nicht, wie die das machen.
Ah, man muss ja erst mal, wenn man sie eine Weile trackt...
Die falten sich dann so in einer schönen Liste zusammen.
Also das heißt, wenn ich den hier nehme und mit Shift irgendwie den und den da unten...
Und ich hab genau 42 Dateien erwischt, guck dir das mal an.
Aber hier, guck dir das doch.
Du bist auch nicht mehr offline.
Ok, aber bei ihm wären die drei Files jetzt so weit auseinander liegen, wären dann so zusammengefallen. Ja, ich hoffe, die User können sich das jetzt vorstellen. So, aber warte, wir sind noch bei Finder. Wir können ja nicht nur den Tim quatschen lassen. Man muss ja auch mal andere was sagen. Hier bei Gesture Navigation. Ich hab ja so ein bisschen rumgespielt, Exposé gibt es ja irgendwie nicht mehr so richtig. Und viele andere Sachen irgendwie auch nicht. Also nicht über die F-Tasten und sonstige. Und Spaces zum Beispiel, das Kürzel, dass ich mit Kontroll und den Closer-Tasten in meine Spaces komme, die ich mir so angeordnet habe, gab es irgendwie auch nicht mehr. Sondern man muss es jetzt irgendwie mit drei Finger nach unten ziehen oder zwei Finger nach rechts oder einen irgendwie schräg hoch oder keine Ahnung. Also die ganzen Navigation-Dinger kann man sich alle voll, erstens schwer merken und zweitens mit meiner riesen Hand und mit diesem immer noch mini Mousepad, hab ich Mousepad gesagt? Mit diesem mini Trackpad, also vier Finger und dann noch mit dem Daumen auseinanderziehen, das geht irgendwie alles gar nicht.
Hat der der Typ bei der Keynote auch schon wieder Old Shatterhand gespielt, ne? Habt ihr gesehen? Ich dachte ja echt, der kommt auf die Bühne und jetzt muss er es bringen und dann ist wieder das Gleiche. Wie heißt der? Irgendwie Ferengi, aber ich glaube das...
Ich glaub, der ist einfach heller nervös. Ich glaube, das funktioniert einfach nicht so gut.
Der Typ mit den grauen Haaren, den meint er.
Das Apple Executive, der hat nicht nervös zu sein.
Ja vor allen Dingen, ich glaube, es funktioniert einfach nicht gut genug. Also ich meine, der macht das bestimmt jeden Tag 23 Mal. Und wenn der das nicht hinkriegt...
Ja und ich sehe jetzt schon die Frauen mit ihren längten Fingernägeln, die werden das auch nicht irgendwie. Also die kommen nur mit ihren Fingerspitzen gar nicht ran.
Mac-User-Frauen müssen sich halt die Fingernägel schneiden.
Also die Fingeraufziehgeste finde ich auch nicht. Ich fand die noch nie intuitiv. Ich finde die auf dem iPhone und auf dem iPad finde ich die super, weil da hat man den Finger irgendwie so mehr von oben drauf. Wohingegen auf dem Trackpad, da habe ich so einen Winkel und mit dem kriege ich nur ganz...
Du meinst das Pinschen.
Ja, so dieses Pinsch.
Ja, aber da gibt es jetzt eine Gesture, die ist alle vier Finger drauf und der Daumen und du musst auseinanderziehen.
Dann kannst du das nicht in den Keyboard-Shortcuts nochmal vielleicht ja doch auf den Key legen.
Ja, ich hab doch nicht im Mekde, dass ich mir irgendwelche Keyboard-Shortcuts irgendwie einrichten muss.
Ja, kann man.
Ich bin von diesen, von diesen...
Da musst du halt die Gesten lernen.
Ja, aber ich bin von den Dingern noch nicht so überzeugt, also... Wobei, das ist mit den drei Fingern hier mit dem Safari so, Seite zurück und Seite vor. Da könnte man sich schon dran gewöhnen, so als Dauerklicke.
Aber vier Finger wird's hässlich.
Ich frag mich ja, warum das nicht, äh, warum das nicht nächster Tab vorheriger Tab ist. Das brauch ich viel häufiger als irgendwie...
Kannst du bestimmt auch belegen.
Nee, ich hab keine Möglichkeit dafür gefunden. So, weiter. Fullscreen?
Das stimmt, weil es ist sowieso krank, wie man, man kann nicht zuverlässig von einem Tab zum nächsten Tab wechseln in Safari.
Ist es nicht hier so mit, mit Command-Cursor zur Seite?
Irgendwie, aber das hängt dann immer davon ab, ob du gerade oben noch in der Menüzeile, in der Editierzeile bist oder ob gerade so ein blödes JavaScript-Ding.
Ctrl-Tab und Ctrl-Shift-Tab, das ist echt die bekloppteste.
Womit wechselt ihr denn? Vielleicht benutze ich die falschen Tasten.
Nee, ich mach auch Abfüll-Shift-Stimmung. Geht nicht.
Also wenn du oben in der Adresszeile bist, wie kann man dann den Tab wechseln?
Ja, richtig nicht.
Also ich wechsle mit Abfüll-Alt-Taste, Falt-Taste, Links-Taste, Rechts-Taste, aber ich benutze ja auch Chrom.
Na du kannst mit Shift, mit Ctrl-Tab oder Ctrl-Shift-Tab wechseln.
Ja, und dann hast du auslösend den Rechner neu gestartet, wenn du zu viel Kommandos mit Alt wechseln.
Ach, mit Ctrl-Tab?
Der ist doch total intuitiv. Wie beim PC halt.
Über was?
Nein, bei Windows ist der Ctrl-Tab, das ist doch Programmwechsel.
Das ist nicht Programmwechsel, das ist Tabwechsel. Ctrl-Tab.
Wieder der Shortcut der Sendung. Nicht ganz so gut.
Mein Zimmer. Ja, aber ich will das immer wieder mit der App machen.
Das haben sie so oft geändert, dieses Shuttle. Das war mal Apfel alt, Pfeil links, Pfeil rechts. Das war mal eine Zeit lang Apfel alt, äh, öh.
Es geht ja auch mit Shift-Command und Pfeil links, Pfeil rechts geht es, wenn die Seite selectiert ist, aber es geht nicht, wenn du oben in der Adresseile bist. Oder wenn irgendein blödes Programm, den Keyboard-Focus da mit JavaScript irgendwie gerade dir so wegnimmt, dass dann dieser Key verloren geht in der Seite.
Also ich lehne das irgendwie ab.
Du bist dagegen, meinst du?
Ja, nächster Punkt. Und nutzen Chrome.
So, Fullscreen Apps.
Machst du mal Abfüll Plus da auf der Seite, damit man die schritten kann.
Ich mach mal Abfüll Plus für dich, mein Freund.
So, und mach mal Fullscreen Modus an.
Ich hab hier noch keinen Fullscreen.
Hat er ja schon.
Hier funktioniert auch dieser scheißgrüne Button. Ich bin ja mal gespannt, ob das jetzt funktioniert in Line. Ist das groß genug so?
Ehrlich gesagt ist auch einfach nicht richtig scharf. Kann ja sein. Ich geh mal da an den Regler. Irgendwer war das oder wo?
Ja, das war besser. Hast gewonnen. Bist gut gegen gekommen.
Gut.
Oh, da sieht man aber mal ganz neue Features.
Also, liebe Hörer, man kann den Beamer auch scharf stellen, wenn man vorne an der Linse steht.
Ich kam mir schon die ganze Zeit so ein bisschen blöd vor, ehrlich gesagt. Ja, Vollscreen. Da haben wir uns glaube ich auch schon mal ausführlich zu unterhalten und ich glaube, da ist jetzt relativ wenig Neues dazu gekommen.
Außer schon wieder Gesture Navigation, das ist ja irgendwie systemweit jetzt, wie in allem Scheiß.
Ja, aber welche Gesture ist denn jetzt hier gemeint? Wieviele Finger muss man da einsetzen?
Drei. Ja, das musst du halt auch nochmal merken. Du musst dir die Richtung merken und wie viele Finger. Und musst du irgendwie noch pinchen oder nicht?
Drei Finger links oder rechts.
Drei Finger links, rechts.
Was ich schade finde, weil so die drei Fingergesten, die sind zum Beispiel der Twitter-Klient, auf dem Mac hat die bisher immer genutzt, um in den Listen zu navigieren und so. Und dass da die drei Finger jetzt für geklaut haben, finde ich echt doof.
Aber das funktioniert dann nur bei Fullscreen-Ups.
Nee, das funktioniert immer.
Du kannst mit drei Fingern zwischen Programmen wechseln.
Nee, ich kann mit drei Fingern zwischen verschiedenen Screens wechseln. Und wenn ich keine verschiedenen Screens habe, dann kann ich damit zwischen dem Dashboard und dem Hauptbildschirm wechseln sozusagen.
Und dann kommt noch was dazu. Ich habe nichts gefunden bisher, dass ich mir meine sechs Screens einrichte, wo ich sage, hier Xcode bitte unten immer im vierten und iTunes immer hinten im sechsten und mein Mail immer im dritten Screen, dass es automatisch geht. Das habe ich irgendwie nicht mehr gefunden, sondern du startest immer ohne Screen und musst irgendwie dann in diesen Launch-Dings oder was auch immer reingehen. Du musst oben sagen, ich hätte jetzt gerne einen neuen Screen.
Nee, mach den Screen auf, sobald du ein entsprechendes Projekt aufmachst.
Was ein eigenes Screen haben will.
Entweder ein eigenes Screen oder...
Aber sind die dann auch durchnummeriert, dass ich mit Ctrl-1, 2, 3, 4 zu den passenden komme?
Keine Ahnung, also ich habe Screens früher nie benutzt und ich glaube, ich werde auch jetzt nicht mit warm werden.
Also ich bin da voll mit warm geworden für bestimmte Sachen. So mein riesen iTunes ist ja schon so eine Art Fullscreen-Ding, habe ich halt immer auf meinem sechsten Screen. Dann mache ich Ctrl-6 und dann bin ich da irgendwie oder zumindest mache ich Ctrl-Cursor zur Seite und kann es schnell zwischen dem ersten und dem letzten hin und her schalten und das ist voll super.
Also ich muss sagen, dass ich mir vor... also jetzt mit diesem Fullscreen-Modus, also wo ein Programm wirklich sagen kann, ich bin jetzt Fullscreen und du weißt das auch. Nicht nur mein Fenster ist so groß, dass es den Bildschirm bedeckt, sondern dieser Screen gehört mir, wo dann quasi das Programm automatisch so ein Space aufmacht sozusagen. Das könnte ich mir sehr wohl vorstellen. Also das wäre zum Beispiel jetzt hier auch cool, wenn ich hier irgendwie, was weiß ich, mein Aufnahmeprogramm einfach in so eigenem Screen habe. Ich sagen kann so, wusch, hier ist alles andere und wusch, hier ist nur das.
Aber dann würdest du jetzt zum Beispiel, wenn du da in SubEther Edit angucken willst, würdest du nicht sehen, ob es jetzt gerade aufnimmt. Im Hintergrund kackt gerade die Aufnahme ab.
Das ist aber meine eigene Entscheidung. Ich könnte dafür dann ja auch vielleicht die Media... Das ist dann die nächste Frage, die ich hätte. Kann ich Fullscreen sozusagen auch auf einen Screen machen und auf einem anderen Screen habe ich dann die anderen?
Die Frage kann ich dir beantworten. Und die Antwort ist nein. Der andere Bildschirm wird entweder schwarz oder weiß oder kriegt so ein hässliches Muster. Also das ist mit Lion, spätestens im Fullscreen-Modus, ist dein zweiter Bildschirm einfach quasi tot.
Das ist ein totaler Scheiß. 29 Dollar?
Ich bleib bei Schnurrleport.
Ich finde diesen Fullscreen-Modus, ich hatte mich...
So ein Quatsch. Ich glaube... Das ist doch wirklich Blödsinn. Das ist halt nicht das, was ich immer schon erwartet hätte, dass ich mehrere, das wäre mal ein Grund, mehrere Bildschirme zu kaufen, dass man so ein Programm da hinlegen kann und sagen kann, das ist deiner und die anderen benutzen den in dem Moment auch nicht mehr. Oder? Dann hättest du sozusagen da iTunes laufen, dann wär das dein iTunes-Screen und dann machst du dir da noch irgendwie eine Büchse dran.
Auf einen Bildschirm Xcode, auf einen anderen iPhone-Simulator. Das ist ja durchaus jetzt kein Extremseil, geht einfach nicht. Ein Bildschirm Projekt-Fullscreen, anderes Fenster Dokumentation, andere Bildschirme. Geht nicht. Also, ja, geht. Egal, was man probiert, es geht einfach. So, jeder Anwendungsfall, der sofort... Voll lame.
Also ich denke mal, das könnte so aussehen, als wenn es eventuell eine Verschlimmbesserung ist. Mit diesen Screens und so.
Also ich finde den Fullscreen-Modus nicht gut.
Ja, mit diesem... Da kommt jetzt hier auch gleich noch, ne? Wie heißt das Teil da? Ich kann den Blick nicht mehr durch. Launchpad ist diese Icon-Leiste. Und wie heißt das nochmal gleich?
Mission Control.
Na ja, gut, also keine Ahnung.
Wisst ihr, wo ich einen super eingesetzten Fullscreen-Modus finde? Ich nutze in letzter Zeit so eine App, die heißt Byline. Nee, Byword heißt das. Oder wie heißt das jetzt? Jetzt muss ich den Namen vergessen. Kann man im App-Store kaufen. Also so ein No-Obsc... Also so ein Textprogramm, wo man einfach nur Text rein tippt und im Fullscreen-Modus laufen lässt und man wird nicht von irgendwas genervt. Und wenn man das im Fullscreen laufen lässt und man wechselt dann das Programm, dann verlässt das einfach den Fullscreen-Modus und geht erst wieder rein, sobald man... und geht erst wieder in Fullscreen-Modus, sobald man in das Programm geht. Und das ist eigentlich genauso, wie man es haben möchte. Man kann sich das im Hintergrund, kann man den Text immer noch lesen und nur wenn es im Vordergrund ist, ist es Fullscreen. So was in der Richtung hätten die mal bei Apple einbauen sollen.
Die mal bei Apple.
Wir haben es echt nicht drauf.
Naja, also ich benutze ja keine Screens, von daher sehe ich der Sache noch relativ gelassen entgegen und hoffe, dass das Exposé noch einigermaßen sinnvoll funktioniert, weil ich damit meinen tägliche Windows-Brot...
Ist das überhaupt noch so in der Form?
Na, dieses Mission-Control hast du ja so. Das finde ich ganz gut gelöst.
Also dass die da so die Programmfenster gruppieren gleich in dem Overview und so, das finde ich schon. Ich hoffe, die Desktop-Geste oder der Desktop-Freiräumenblick, der geht dann auch irgendwie noch.
Kannst du auch noch einen Shortcut definieren.
Wie viel kann das Apple Trackpad tracken? Zwölf Finger? Mehr als jedenfalls Finger da sind. So, iCal. Oh Gott, das wird so eine epische Sendung. Ich sehe das jetzt schon.
Das war ja von vornherein klar. Also bei iCal muss ich einfach festhalten, dass mein Lieblingsfeature oder das Must, also das, ich bin einfach dagegen. Es ist einfach, ich kann, ich hab kein Verständnis dafür. Und das macht auch kein einziges Kalenderprogramm, was ich kenne, macht es so. Und ich verstehe es überhaupt nicht. Warum kann ich mir nicht zwei Wochen oder drei Wochen anzeigen lassen? Was sollen diese scheiß Horoskop-Monate, die keinen interessieren, als Navigationseinheit? Ich meine, man plant nicht den nächsten Kalendermonat. Man plant die nächste Woche. Und ich will immer, ich hätte gerne ein View, wo in der Mitte die aktuelle Woche ist und da drunter die nächste Woche.
Oder daneben.
Und da drüber die letzte Woche. Oder vielleicht die letzte Woche auch gar nicht mehr.
So.
Und ich möchte auch, oder ich hätte ein View, wo ich einfach in der Mitte immer den aktuellen Tag habe und links und rechts davon die nächsten drei Tage. Wieso geht das nicht?
Das würde nicht ästhetisch aussehen.
Ein Quatsch.
Was zeigst du mir da jetzt, Max?
Kalender auf iOS 5.
Welches?
Der normale.
Wie was?
Wer hat so eine Wochenansicht, wenn man ihn querschaltet?
Nein.
Aber wir sind doch jetzt hier beim Laien, Kinder.
Wir sind hier bei Kalender.
Hallo, Kalender ist Kalender. iOS und iCloud kommen noch.
Nein.
Doch.
Tja, du musst jetzt deine Kalender leider nur noch über dem iPad und so benutzen.
Auf dem iPad geht's ja auch nicht.
So, scroll mal zu iChat, während du dich da noch austobst und irgendwie Bausteine klotzt.
Interessiert uns ja iChat, der bessere ja WhoMessenger-Support. Ich meine, können wir uns nicht einfach mal überspringen?
Ja, bitte, Tim.
Es geht. Also ich meine, es sieht nicht so aus, wie ich es hier hätte, aber es ist auf jeden Fall schon mal eine Steigerung. Aber beim Mac sehe ich das nicht. Also das iCal bei Lion hat nach wie vor entweder einen Tag oder die aktuelle Woche.
Oder einen Monat oder das Jahr.
Ja, aber ich würde gerne flexibel sagen, können die nächsten drei Tage, die letzten drei Tage oder die letzten zwei Tage, die nächsten vier Tage irgendwie sowas.
Aber dafür kannst du jetzt das ganze Jahr auf einmal gucken.
Also Leute da draußen, wenn ihr wollt, dass Tim euch Featuret und Tim hat…
Warum nicht gleich das ganze Jahrhundert? Ja, ich will die komplette Timeline mit Dinosauriern haben.
Das wär's. Ende der Welt. Das war prefillen schon.
Tim hat 20.000 Follower. Wenn ihr jetzt eine tolle Kalender abmacht und Tim die toll findet und die dann Featuret, dann habt ihr gleich 20.000 potenzielle Käufer.
So interessiert hier irgendjemand iChat.
iChat. Doch, wir haben ja von so abgerannt, was wir jetzt haben. Demnächst kommt iMessage. Wir haben Facetime, wir haben iChat. Was haben wir noch?
Das waren so die drei Systeme.
Ja, nutzt ihr hier noch iChat?
Ja, ich.
Alter, kommt das doch gar nicht.
Was nehmt ihr, Adium oder wie?
Logisch. Adium sieht aber scheiße aus.
Adium nicht, aber ich...
Die Ente.
Das ist einfach für mich...
Die Ente macht Krypto und die Ente kann ordentlich Java, obwohl der kann auch Java, ne?
Also, um mit bestimmten Leuten, mit denen du einfach zusammenarbeitest, über einen längeren Zeitraum von mehreren Tagen und Wochen, irgendwie ein kontinuierliches Gespräch zu führen, geht nur Chat. Geht nur iChat, geht nur Java. Also ich finde da einfach instant... Ich brauche einfach eine ewige Historie und ich brauche...
Die hat Adium.
Ist doch egal, ob ich jetzt iChat oder Adium benutze. Wir reden jetzt hier vom Protokoll und das Protokoll ist Java. Natürlich geht das auch mit Adium. Abgesehen davon, dass Adium immer wieder Issues hat und dann wechsle ich wieder zurück zu iChat. Ich komme ganz gut klar mit iChat. Ich würde nicht sagen, dass da alles golden und rosig ist. Da könnte ich mir auch noch viele Sachen anders vorstellen, aber ich finde, sie haben viele Dinge sehr richtig gemacht und iChat ist definitiv schneller als Adium. Adium kann eine echt lahme Ente sein, im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes. Wenn du da irgendwie mal ein paar Tabs aufhast und so irgendwann fängt er an richtig durchzuatmen und da habe ich einfach keinen Bock auf einen Tab.
Aber Adium muss ich dir zustimmen, das ist nur so halb geil.
So ein Tabwechsel, der dauert dann manchmal einfach Sekunden und das ist einfach nicht akzeptabel, das funktioniert nicht.
Ich finde bei Adium, da haben sie echt ein paar schöne Details. Was ich da zum Beispiel eigentlich sehr geil finde, wenn die Ente gerade flattert, weil man eine Nachricht von irgendjemand bekommen hat, die man so per Grow-Notification gesehen hat, man klickt auf die Ente drauf, dann springt er auch zu dem Tab, in dem diese letzte Notification drin war, sodass man sofort los tippen kann. Skype hat das nicht, wie oft ich da schon der falschen Person was geschrieben habe, weil ich dann einfach nur Skype nach vorne geholt habe und weiter getippt habe und äh, falscher Tab.
Ja, aber es gibt so viele Sachen auch nicht. Ich meine, man hat also zwar seine Tabs, aber er ist dann nicht in Erlage, mir im Tab mal anzuzeigen, ob die Leute available sind oder nicht, sondern dann brauch ich immer noch diese Kontaktliste dazu. Warum schreibt er es nicht direkt dahin, wo ich draufgucke?
Es sind doch grau die Leute, wenn sie nicht da sind.
Die Apple-Apparaten-Sendung heute.
Ja, wenn sie nicht da sind, aber wenn sie da sind, sehe ich nicht, ob sie away sind oder available. Dieser grüne rote Button ist nur in der Kontaktliste und dann kriegt er es nicht zugeordnet. Das könnte auch mehr Liebe gebrauchen. Und vor allem ist mir nicht klar, wohin sie da jetzt wollen. Warum gibt es jetzt in iChat, Audio- und Video-Chat? Und es gibt Screensharing.
Screensharing gibt es ja in iChat und das ist echt cool, weil du kannst mit relativ wenig Setup deine Mutti und Omi und Schwester remote administrieren ohne jetzt Remote Desktop oder sonst was zu installieren. Du kannst einfach auf den Button klicken und es geht los. Durch Nuts, durch Firewalls, durch alles.
Genau.
Was nicht mal mit Remote Desktop selber so gut geht.
Aber jetzt erklär mir mal einer, warum ich nicht von iChat zu Facetime telefoniere.
Oder warum Facetime nicht in iChat drin ist. Oder warum das überhaupt nicht eins ist.
Ja, also warum?
Übrigens geht ja auch Audio- und Video-Chat sowieso viel besser in iChat als in Facetime oder Superlässige.
Also ich meine, fällt euch irgendein Grund ein?
Außer die These von letztem Mal, dass sie da halt so unterschiedliche Dev-Teams am Start haben und selber nicht genau wissen, was sie jetzt am Ende haben wollen.
Total vergoogelt.
Ja, total vergoogelt.
Nee, ich glaube, weil es zwei komplett verschiedene Ausgangsbasen hat. Sie wollten was haben, was über deine Telefon... Das war iPhone-Feature. Fürs iPhone 4 gedacht und das sollte über deine Telefonnummer funktionieren. Das war der Ansatz. Das ist einfach nicht iChat. Natürlich hätte man das irgendwie noch bei iChat reinpappen. Dann haben sie irgendwann mal Facetime-Film weg rausgebracht und vielleicht ist ihnen dann aufgefallen, dass sie eigentlich ganz schlau wäre, das in eine App zu packen.
Aber denen fehlt an vielen Stellen doch echt der Fokus. Also ich meine...
Ja, aber ich meine, das kann doch nicht ihr Ernst sein, dass sie solche völlig sich überschneidenden Dinge... Wem soll man denn das erklären? Ja, ich meine, da wollen sie das alles immer so einfach machen, und dann haben sie zwei verschiedene Videotelefoniesysteme.
Ja, aber die meisten Leute wissen noch...
Ja, die demnächst schon auch selber rausfinden und dann irgendwann das irgendwie zusammenschieben und dann...
Ja, aber es ist ja auch vor allem nahe zu dieser Technologie. Naja, ich meine, das ist H264 hin und her, da ist jetzt kein großer Unterschied.
Ja, aber bloß weil der Codec derselbe ist, heißt das ja noch nicht langlich, da ist da irgendwie ein ganzer Transport-Layer und weiß der Teufel, was da unten drunter... Dass das alles dasselbe ist.
Ja, aber warum machen sie dann überhaupt was anderes? Ich meine, wie viele wollen sie noch erfinden?
Für Facetime brauchten sie halt die Telefonnummer und das haben sie in iChat einfach nicht.
Ja, aber das ist doch nur ein Lookup. Ich meine, das kannst du doch da in iChat genauso einbauen wie in eines Tests haben.
Im Facetime auf dem Mac hast du ja auch nicht deine Telefonnummer.
Das ist deine Apple ID, die du da eingibst.
Genau, das ist die Apple ID.
Warum soll ich nicht meine Apple ID in meinen iChat eingeben, wo ich das sogar tue, wenn ich nämlich im mac.com benutze. Also ich meine, das gibt man da auch ein. Das ist da. Warum kann das, wenn ich es da eingebe, nicht auch Facetime machen?
Kann man über seine Mobile-Me-Adresse oder seine Apple-ID auch iChat machen? Ich weiß nicht.
Also im AIM, viele Leute tun das so. Ich überlege jetzt gerade, kannst du damit nicht auch Java machen?
Nee, Apple-ID ist doch was anderes. Eine Apple-ID ist ja eine beliebige E-Mail-Adresse.
Ja, eine angemeldete bei Apple. Nee, sonst ist es keine Apple-ID.
Ich hab irgendwann mal bei Apple gesagt, hier hast du meine E-Mail-Adresse.
Die Adresse muss nicht Apple sein, aber du musst sie schon dort angeben. Die ist einmalig, deine ID bei Apple ist einmalig.
Ja, natürlich. Aber eine Java-ID, ich kann doch nicht eine beliebige E-Mail-Adresse zu einer Java-ID machen, sondern muss doch da auch ein Java-Server laufen.
Nee, das ist glaube ich nur für me.com-Adressen tatsächlich.
Ja, aber das ist, wie auch immer, wir reden hier wirklich, meine Apple macht gerade nichts anderes als alles Uni-Files und Apple-IDs und Mac.com-Adressen, das ist alles dasselbe. Das ist alles derselbe Brei.
Nee, es ist eben nicht. Genau, da sind wir doch. Du kannst, du kannst über, ich hab zum Beispiel, ich hol mir jetzt irgendwo ein Domain bei Strato und hab da eine E-Mail-Adresse. So, dann kann diese E-Mail-Adresse sehr wohl meine Apple-ID sein. Ich kann darüber aber nicht automatisch Java machen.
Das ist ja auch kein Java.
Hab ich ja jetzt auch gar nicht gesagt. Ich hab nur gesagt, es ist so, dass sie sowieso Dienste anbieten und dass das alles an ihren Apple-IDs dranhängt. Und warum kann...
Weil's nicht geht.
Guck mal, iMessage ist unter Garantie, ich hab da jetzt keinen technischen Eindruck, aber schieß mich tot, wenn das irgendwas anderes als Java ist, mit irgendwie Push hinten dran, dann wär ich schwer überrascht. FaceTime ist am Ende genau dasselbe, sie machen diesen Lookup über Java. Das ist alles irgendwie Java. Also wir reden hier über Instant Messing Technologie.
Und man kriegt eine Information, ob's angekommen ist oder ob's gelesen wurde.
Aber sie ist kein reines Java. Es ist kein reines Java, einfach aus dem Grund nicht. Weil es funktioniert auch mit einer Domain, auf der definitiv kein Java-Server installiert ist.
Dann sollen sie mir einen scheiß Java-Server... Ich meine, sie haben da ja Java-Server laufen.
Wie sollen sie denn Java-Server auf deinem Shared Space, auf deine GMX-Adresse kriegen?
Ich rede nicht von GMX-Adressen, ich rede von der Apple ID.
Ja, und die kann auch eine GMX-Adresse sein.
Das kann auch einfach ein Name sein, das muss nicht...
Ja, das kann schieß mich tot sein, aber es gibt...
Das kann Fubabat sein.
Ich sag doch nur eins. Ich verstehe nicht, warum sie diese Welten so auseinanderhalten. Ich begreife nicht, warum sie es nicht schaffen, iChat, Videotelefonie und Facetime zusammenzubringen. Weil am Ende werden da Verbindungen zwischen Geräten hergestellt und eine Kamera ist eingeschaltet und man redet da rein.
Ja, und ich sagte, das sind zwei unterschiedliche Protokolle, die nicht miteinander compatible sind. Weil das eine basiert auf einer Apple-ID und das andere basiert auf einer Jabber-ID.
Wir könnten noch genauso gut sagen, iChat ist ab heute das, was Facetime ist oder Facetime...
Na dann bräuchte man aber zum Beispiel...
Ja, aber Jabber ist Federation. Das ist überhaupt gar kein Problem. Wenn sie das wollten, könnten sie das tun. Wie? Da gibt es kein technisches Problem mehr. Wie? Dann muss halt da ein Look ab.
Guck mal, im Augenblick funktioniert IChat so, dass man hat einfach Jabber-IDs. Entweder man holt sich eine Jabber-ID bei Apple oder bei Google oder wo auch immer. Und da holt man sich eine Jabber-ID. Und über dieses Protokoll wird kommuniziert. Und wenn ich irgendwo meinen eigenen Jabber-Server aufsetzen will, dann habe ich da meinen eigenen Server mit meiner eigenen ID.
Du brauchst ja über den nicht mit IChat Videotelefonie. Nicht mit deinem eigenen Jabber-Server.
Wieso nicht?
Das läuft alles peer-to-peer. Und am Ende ist das nur...
Ja, das spielt doch überhaupt keine Rolle. Weil, wenn ich jetzt mit jemandem kommunizieren... Aber Facetime macht auch dasselbe. Nein, macht das nicht. Lass mich bitte mal ausreden. Weil, in dem Moment, in dem ich eine Verbindung aufbaue, in dem Moment, in dem ich jetzt hier sitze und zu deiner jabber.ccc.de-Adresse eine Verbindung aufbaue, verbindet der sich zu jabber.ccc.de. Mit Chat, normalem Chat. So, genau. Wenn ich jetzt aber als Apple-ID ne GMX-Adresse hab und sage dir, hey, schick mal ne Jabber-Nachricht an max.gmx.de Ja, geschenkt, darüber rede ich nicht.
Ich sag nur, du könntest die Apple-ID nehmen und nen Jabber-Server bei Apple, der da sowieso läuft, einfach benutzen, fertig. So wie Google das mit Gmail auch macht.
Und wie würdest du dann zu mir ne Verbindung aufbauen, wenn ich ne GMX-Adresse hab? Woher soll dein Jabber-Jabber-Federation?
So ist Jabber gebaut. Du kannst von jedem Jabber-Server zu jedem Jabber-Server ne Verbindung aufbauen. Das ist so.
Und wie findet dein Jabber-Server meinen Jabber-Server?
Über die Domain, die da hinten steht. Dann macht er da einen Lookup und dann verbindet er sich dahin.
Genau. Und die Domain, also er findet sich an gmx.de. Und bei gmx gibt's keinen Jabber-Server.
Na, wenn's da keinen Jabber-Server gibt, dann machen wir keinen Jabber.
Aber es ist ne Apple-ID. Es ist ne gültige Apple-ID. Genau, das will ich doch die ganze Zeit sagen. Es ist ne gültige Apple-ID. Und die Leute können einfach nicht mit mir... Es ist inkompatibel zu Jabber, offensichtlich.
Aber die Kleins machen doch eh nochmal dann was ganz anderes für Videotelefonie und so weiter.
Who the fuck cares about Videotelefonie? Es geht hier um Chat?
Naja, also gerade ging's um Videotelefonie, vor allen Dingen.
Aber es sind zwei fundamental verschiedene Dinge.
Wir reden aneinander vorbei.
Deutlich.
Ja, nochmal ganz zum Anfang. Warum ist iChat Videotelefonie was anderes als FaceTime Videotelefonie? Warum gelingt es Ihnen nicht, das zu unifine? Wieso kann ich nicht mit meinem Programm iChat FaceTime anrufen auf dem iPhone? Warum? Da gibt es für mich keinen wirklichen Grund. Ja, dann machen Sie da ein Kommando und dann trage ich das da ein, wie ich das in das Faceprogramm auch eintrage. Dann macht man eine neue Version und dann ist das da drin. Warum muss das ein separates Programm sein? Warum? Das verstehe ich nicht. Also das will mir ja nicht in den Kopf. Und das können die mir auch nicht erklären. Das können die da alles einbauen und das haben die da auch einzubauen.
So, Schnauze.
Dennis, erzähl doch mal was über Bitcoins. Wir sind bei ihr, Jungs. Aber es würde nicht funktionieren.
Ich sehe da keinen Grund, warum das nicht funktionieren soll.
Kann ich mal kurz auch was sagen, weil ihr habt ja nur beide genug gelabert. Max, stell dir einfach vor, man nimmt den Facetime-Code, klebt den in iChat mit rein, das ganze Protokoll, was im Facetime schon drin ist, schiebt man auch mit rein, dass sozusagen beide Programme einfach in einem drin sind.
Ja, du kannst auch noch iPhoto mit reinklatschen in iChat. Macht genauso wenig Sinn.
Ja, aber wir reden von zwei Programmen. Jungs, im Wesentlichen dasselbe tun.
Nee, sie tun zwei komplette Unterschiede. Das eine ist ein Programm für Videotelefonie. Das andere Programm ist ein Programm, mit dem ich chatten kann in allererster Linie. Das ist die primäre Aufgabe. Dafür benutze ich es am häufigsten, mit der man Screensharing machen kann, mit der man Dateiübertragung machen kann, mit der man unter anderem auch Videotelefonie machen kann. Mit dem anderen Programm kann ich nichts weiter machen als Videotelefonie. Wenn ich in Facetime Kontakt anklicke, dann wird diese Person angerufen. Wenn ich in iChat Kontakt anklicke, dann baue ich zudem eine Chatverbindung auf. Das sind, finde ich, zwei Komplette.
Und wenn du aber bei iChat auf Video-Dings drückst, dann baut er eine Videoverbindung auf. Und in Facetime und in iChat ist beides der Code drin, dass die Kamera angeht.
Ja, bloß weil der Code drin ist, heißt das, das Icon sieht genauso aus.
Das macht einfach überhaupt keinen Sinn.
Also ich finde, ich habe jetzt genug Argumente gebracht, warum das Sinn macht, aber...
Das kannst du aber Leuten nicht erklären. Leute haben dieses Programm, und damit haben sie jetzt mehrere Jahre lang Bildtelefonie gemacht.
Natürlich kannst du nicht sagen, wenn ihr FaceTime machen wollt, startet das Programm FaceTime.
Wenn du mit jemand anderem reden willst, musst du ein anderes Programm benutzen. Das ist doch Quatsch.
Man sagt eigentlich, ich will dich FaceTime, andere nicht, ich will dich aber iChat-Video callen.
Das ist alles dummes Zeug, was sie da machen.
Das ist schon doppelt gemoppelt.
So, was haben wir als nächstes hier? Internet Restore and Utilities. Alphabetisch durchgehen ist auch geil, oder? Das bringt Abwechslung. Build into Lion. Na toll. Was heißt denn das eigentlich alles?
Das ist ein bisschen so wie vorher. Du kannst neu installieren und von deinem Backup wieder irgendwie drauf spielen. Und es gibt jetzt diesen Recovery Mode. Also wenn du Lion installierst und du Bootest hier mit Alt-Taste gedrückt, dann kommt nicht nur deine Lion-Partition als Boot-Option, sondern kommt noch so ein Recovery-Disc. Also ist irgendwie was drin, wo du halt irgendwie, keine Ahnung, Disc-Utility noch machst und noch mal irgendwie wahrscheinlich eine Shell kriegst. Ich war da noch nicht drin bisher.
Und das ist eine eigene Partition, die er dir noch dazu schiebt.
Ja, das ist irgendwie so eine Mini-Partition, wo irgendwie festgenagelt so ein paar Tools drin sind, die man sonst nicht ändern kann.
Ja, das ist auch eine coole Sache eigentlich. Wenn es funktioniert.
Außer wenn die Platte tot ist.
Ja gut, wenn die Platte tot ist, ist die Platte tot, aber wenn halt nur das Fallsystem tot ist, dann hast du gleich die Board-Werkzeuge, die du brauchst und du bist nicht...
Du hast dich mit Virtual-Dingens, mit Virtual-Cacks vollgehaunt, wo einer beim Booten abkackt oder was auch immer die da so machen.
Ich hab ja früher auch schon mal gefordert, dass beim Installieren, dass man Spiele spielen können soll. Früher hat es ja noch lange gedauert mit dem Installieren, dass man währenddessen eine kleine Runde Solitaire spielen kann. Jetzt kann man während des Recovery-Modes Safari brausen und kann dann halt, obwohl nicht Flash-Spiele gehen, dann bestimmt nicht. Aber zumindest HTML5-Spiele kann man dann bei Browse the Web bis Safari im Recovery-Mode machen. Oder zumindest YouTube-Videos, ach nee, doch HTML5-YouTube-Videos kann man gucken.
Das geht gleichzeitig sicher. Nicht, dass man hier nur eins von beiden auswählen kann.
Nein, hier steht Recovery Mode now includes Safari-Browse.
So Jungs, jetzt machen wir ein bisschen mehr Turbo hier.
Noch mehr.
Los, Launchpad-Rakete.
Skip.
Hier ist schon wieder Gesture-Navigation. Da muss man auch schon wieder wissen, was genau der 3, 4 oder 5 Finger-Code dafür ist. Anscheinend ist es ein 3-Finger-Code. Ja, ich weiß noch nicht. Vielleicht gewöhnt man sich ja dran, aber...
Ich glaube, an dieses Links-Rechts gewöhnt man sich das auch schnell.
Also auf jeden Fall besser als Applications-Folder. Weil diese Programme starten, das ist alles so...
Mal ehrlich, wer geht denn in den Applications-Folder rein? Wann machst du denn mal den Applications-Folder?
Laufend.
Das ist der Launchpad. Ja, gut, aber der...
Performt der Launchpad nicht?
Ich hab Alfred jetzt... Nee, Albert?
Nein, aber wenn Leute nach dem Programm suchen, und es ist nicht im Doc, dann müssen sie in diesen Applikations-Ordner. Dann müssen sie gezwungen im Spotlight. Ja, wenn sie wissen, wie es heißt. Aber wenn sie nur dieses Icon suchen, das Bild mit dem Auge und so...
Ich glaube, 90% aller User finden das total toll und finden das praktisch und wussten bisher, was nicht im Doc ist, das ist für die nicht existent.
Ja, aber diese User, die auch nicht so Ahnung haben... Ja, warte, aber die ist schon wieder im Verteidigungsmodus. Mann ey, ist ja schlimm mit euch. Diese User, die hauen sich aber auch in den Application-Ordner so voll. Ich weiß nicht, was passiert, wenn das Ding voll ist. Ich hab's noch nicht gesehen. Aber werden die dann kleiner oder kannst du scrollen?
Nee, es gibt mehrere Seiten, wie beim iPhone.
Move speed wie ein Loungepad, Patreons with the three fingers, da steht's sogar.
Wie viel Seiten hast du auf deinem iPhone? Du hast ja auch eine Menge Programme bestimmt auf deinem iPhone. Ja, und angenommen, da kommt so ein Kitty an und würfelt die alle durcheinander. Okay, es geht nicht so schnell. Aber angenommen, man könnte shuffeln auf deinem iPhone, die Programme so. Wie lange bräucht es, um die einzelnen Dinger wieder zu finden?
Ewig, aber das ist trotzdem ein tolles Feature, weiß ich die meisten Leute, die werden das. Also ich weiß auf dem iPhone, die ersten ein, zwei Seiten, weiß ich blind, wo ich meine Icons zu suchen habe. Das ist nämlich total klasse gemacht. Auf dem Launchpad ist das, glaube ich, auch nicht schlecht. Das ist, wenn du relativ wenige Programme hast, hast du da ein, zwei Seiten. Du arrangierst dir die Programme oder du merkst ja einfach, wo die sind. Und das ist endlich mal wieder so. Das ist so, wie heißt der hier von Ars Technica? Ist das Saracusa, der das immer mit einem Finder, wo man die Fenster früher hingezogen hat unter Mac OS 9 noch. Und dann sind die da ein für alle Mal geblieben und haben sich nie wieder wegbewegt. Und das ist ja mit Mac OS X total flöten gegangen. Und jetzt kommt es mit Launchpad so ein bisschen wieder. Da wo das einmal ist, startest du dieses Launchpad und dann ist immer oben links dein Safari, solange es du nicht explizit verschiebt. Das ist für viele Leute, die mit einer Maus arbeiten, ist das echt eine tolle Sache.
Meine Empfehlung an diese Mac User, installiert euch so als ihr Launchpad oder Alfred ab und...
Also das Best-Side kommt ja ganz später bei S noch und dann wird da auch stehen, dass es verbessert wurde mal wieder.
Also man kann über das Design, kann man jetzt streiten, aber dass es eine Funktion gibt, wo das OS hochkommt und sagt, das sind alle Programme, die du hier finden kannst. Egal, wo sie liegen. Es braucht dich nicht zu interessieren.
Ist es wirklich egal, wo die liegen?
Das weiß ich nicht so ganz genau, aber es ist dir dann egal, wo sie liegen.
Also bei mir ist es zum Beispiel so, dass meine Apps immer in einem Extra-Order sind.
Ja, du sollst auch weiterhin Lautspar nehmen.
Das wird spannend zu sehen sein, ob das auch in deinem Home-Application sein kann. Ich meine, geht mal davon aus, dass das Ding voll iOS-mäßig wird. Ich meine, hier ist ja auch dieses Löschen von Apps auch mit drin.
Und diese Gruppen, also hier diese Groups oder Organizers.
Die Folder ist damit drin und das wird jetzt auch nicht mehr lange dauern, wenn es nicht sogar schon dabei ist. Ich habe so was klingeln gehört, dass im Prinzip Lion jetzt auch schon diesen ganzen Sandbox-Kram mit sich bringt und dass es auch möglich ist, dass du eben alle die Dokumente deines Programms in deinem Programm in deiner Sandbox hast. Dass du da genauso isoliert bist wie bei iOS. Ich bin mir nicht ganz so sicher, ob das jetzt etwas ist, was später irgendwann noch mal enforced wird oder ob das jetzt etwas ist, was man freiwillig wählen kann oder so. Aber in diese Richtung geht es. Dass das alles mehr encapsuliert ist. Darüber habe ich ja auch schon mehrfach geklagt. Dieses Programme hinterlassen, Hirn-Scheiß und dann im Preferences-Ordner und im Library-Application-Support und in Slash-Library, Slash-Tralala, hast du nicht gesehen? Und Caches und Pipapo und dann löscht du dieses Programm. Hast aber unter Umständen noch 3GB an Zeug rumliegen, was du nie findest. Google Earth hinterlässt ja immer Safari.
Dann hast du eine neue Version und installierst die und der Installer von diesem Programm, was dich nicht an die Standards hält, löscht das alte Programm.
Das ist Mac App Store.
Und dann sind deine Daten Mac, weil die da mit drin waren.
Es gibt keinen Installer, das ist der App Store.
Aber das ist dann nur auch bei Tools, die über den App Store kommen.
Ja, das ist der Weg, wie die meisten Leute.
Das ist auch der Weg. Ich gehe davon aus, dass wir in zwei Jahren vollkommen normal sein würden, dass es Leute gibt, die einfach komplett nur in der App Store-Welt leben. Gucken wir mal. Zumindest für Normal-User, die wollen auch gar nichts anderes haben. Auch wenn es immer noch was anderes möglich sein würde.
Wir lernen uns dann schon irgendwann dem Mac OS, was man irgendwann jailbreaken werden muss.
Ja, das kann schon sein.
Das hoffe ich nicht. So lange es nur Optionen ist, ist es okay.
Aber wir nähern uns da schon ein Schritt. Irgendwann machen sie die letzte Tür zu und dann stehst du da.
Es ist ja auch eine Security-Frage an der Stelle. Sie machen da echt eine Tür zu. Wir alle wissen, wie groß die Bedrohung ist von Trojanern. Das ist die einzige... Das ist sozusagen ein potentielles Einfallstor.
Ich hab mir diesen Mac-Defender installiert und sehr dämisch. So, was gibt's? Da kann ich noch mal ganz kurz sagen, ich finde, das ist ein bisschen das Antibild zu Google. Google sagt, wir müssen weg von lokal installierten Programmen. Das muss alles in die Wolke, weil das ist sicher und das ist einfach. Das braucht man nichts zu installieren. Man braucht nichts zu löschen. Und Apple probiert jetzt den ganz klassischen alten Programm, genau diese Features der Wolke beizubringen. Nämlich keine Installation mehr, Browsen, total simpel, brauchst dir keine Gedanken mehr, um die Sicherheit zu machen, weil das Betriebssystem kümmert sich darum. So dieses ganze Zeug. Das finde ich schon einen ganz spannenden Ansatz. Natürlich, aber Chrome OS und die ganzen Web-Apps, die sie haben und sowas, da gehen sie halt in die Richtung sehr stark.
Ja, für Apple ist Cloud was anderes als für Google. Und sie haben auch total recht mit diesen Native-Apps. Native-Apps rocken einfach. Der ganze Web-Kram, das ist zwar irgendwie alles ganz nett, aber das kann es mit einer Native-App nicht aufnehmen und wird es auch in den nächsten zwei, drei Jahren nicht aufnehmen können. Egal wie viel Fu und Ba sie dann auch in diese JavaScript-Layer mit reinpumpen und wie fancy das alles wird, das ist irgendwie... ein Programm muss einfach nah dran sein am OS und muss irgendwie alle irgendwie erdenklichen Features aushebeln können, also ausnutzen können.
Also ich finde beide Ansätze spannend. Der Browser wird sicherlich irgendwann mal so weit sein, aber im Augenblick definitiv nicht.
Nächster Punkt hier, Mac App Store. Es gibt In-App-Purchases, hurra! Es gibt Delta-Updates.
Und dann gibt es aber auch, weil wir immer ein bisschen zwischen iOS und Lion hin und her switchen, beim iOS 5 wird es dann auch Delta-Updates geben.
Hab ich so verstanden.
Endlich. Das heißt, wenn dann mal so ein Safari backt, muss man irgendwie nicht acht Wochen warten, bis dann eine neue Version für alle möglichen Devices erstellt haben, sondern dann kommt einfach mal vielleicht auch da in den Updates im App Store, wo halt alle anderen Apps auch kommen, kommt dann irgendwie ein zack neues Safari.
Es gibt in den Einstellungen, gibt es dafür einen Button?
Nein, Safari ist Teil des Systems, und deswegen wird es ein System-Update sein, es wird bloß kleiner sein. Dieses Delta-Update bezieht sich nur auf die Größe der übertragenen Daten.
Ja, aber wie willst du das einzeln machen?
Von Einzel ist nicht die Rede, welches Update auch immer kommt von deinem Programm, am Ende wird nur das auf den Rechner übertragen, was da anders ist. Das können sie halt machen, weil sie hier mit signierten Code und definierten Zuständen arbeiten und wissen, welche Version das ist. Und dann generieren sie wahrscheinlich diese Delta serverseitig quasi für die Versionen, die sie auf dem anderen Rechner antreffen. Das werden sie bestimmt nicht pro Rechner dann neu berechnen und dann durchlaufen lassen, sondern es ist halt einfach dieses Update von Version 3.0 auf Version 3.0.1. Und da wissen sie, was das Delta ist. Du als Entwickler lieferst nur dein 3.0.1 und sie haben ja die 3.0, dann machen sie daraus ein Delta und das pushen sie dann letzten Endes als Update auf den Rechner.
Verstehe, du meinst also, dass wenn im iChat kommt ein Update und Safari kommt ein Update, dass man die sich nicht einzeln aussuchen kann, sondern es kommt ein iOS 5.0, irgendwas Update und da ist halt das neue iChat und wenn man das nicht nimmt, dann kriegt man auch das Folgende, wo dann Safari drin ist, nicht was dann sozusagen 5.0.2 wäre, sondern man muss sie schön in der richtigen Reihenfolge machen, damit man die alle kriegt.
Na wie bisher auch nur kleineren Dateien.
Macht Sinn, weil dann kommen die besser mit ihren Versionen klar und dann wissen sie auch genau, was du hast, wenn du deine Versionsformaten gibst.
Also ich glaube, die machen auf keinen Fall sowas, die wollen das OS immer auf einem Stand haben, dass alle dasselbe haben und ich glaube auch, wenn du dann irgendwie, nehmen wir mal an, du hast irgendein Dienstprogramm, von dem du gar nicht weißt, was es hat und plötzlich steht da im App Store, hier installiere mal die neue Version von Festplatten-Dienstprogramm. Festplatten-Dienstprogramm, weiß ich nicht, brauche ich nicht weg damit. Das machen die übers Betriebssystem.
Das ist ja auch der Linux-Ansatz. Das hat Apple ja noch nie gemacht. Das ist wie BSD. UserLand und Kernel gehören zusammen. Fertig. Weil der Kernel wächst ja auch immer mit dem UserLand zusammen und so weiter. Sie kennen ja viele dieser, was weiß ich, dieses Mail, was jetzt hier bei Lion dabei ist, das könnten sie und das Nolabart überhaupt nicht zum Laufen kriegen, weil es halt alle erdenklichen System-Services gleich mit nutzt, die bei Lion eben dabei sind und deswegen wird es auch kein Backport geben. Das bringt uns zum Mail.
Ich fand die Suchfunktion total geil.
Ja, man kann ja jetzt endlich nach mehreren Sachen suchen, das ist ja mal ganz großartig.
Und auch mit den Vorschlägen und so.
Ja, mal gucken, wie die so sind. Ja, da sind schon ein paar nette Sachen drin. Conversations, hurra, das hat nun auch lange gefehlt, dass man einfach mal das Hin und Her einer E-Mail endlich nachvollziehen kann. Ich habe so ein bisschen Angst vor diesen monochromen Icons. Ich mag ja meine Farb-Icons sehr. Ich weiß nicht, was sie da treibt mit diesen monochromen. Das verstehe ich nicht. Also, es muss eine reine ästhetische Sache sein, weil leichter auseinanderhalten kann ich die nicht mehr. Oder? Also...
Nee, mir fehlt auch ein bisschen Farbe da.
Ja, so Flag, da brauche ich einfach eine rote Fahne. Die will ich irgendwie sofort sehen. Und wenn das irgendwie alles so eine graue Melange von so Mini-Icons ist...
Die Farben blendet vielleicht?
Vor allem gibt es ja jetzt in Lion den Lutschbombon nicht mehr.
Den was?
Den Lutschbombon rechts oben im Fenster. Blase.
Ach, das Ding.
Ja, den liebe ich ja sehr.
Ernsthaft?
Na ja klar, da kann man so schön...
Na, dieses...
Zeig mal.
Dieses Titelleister ausblenden. Nee, nicht Titelleister, sondern...
Na, hier rechts oben. In jedem Fenster, wo es nicht explizit ausgebildet ist. Da kannst du ja schön hier...
Ach so, da ist das Fullscreen-Symbol da, oder?
Ja, da kannst du so draufklicken und kriegst dann hier deine Icon Toolbar-Kontrollation.
Da musst du irgendeinen Modifier klicken.
Du kannst halt mit Alt drauf... Mach ich ja auch gerade. Mit Alt draufklicken, Toolbar ein ausschalten und du kannst mit Command draufklicken und dann durch diese ganzen Varianten hier, die möglich sind, durchgehen.
Ohne irgendwas klicken, ist doch Toolbar ein ausblenden.
Richtig. Du hast recht. Aber wenn du mit Command drückst, dann kriegst du halt alle möglichen Kombinationen aus nur Text, nur Icon und großes Icon und kleines Icon und tralala.
Ich hab dieses Icon da oben in den letzten zehn Jahren vielleicht fünfmal benutzt. Ich vermisse da nichts.
Ja, so geht's wahrscheinlich vielen.
Wir drücken trotzdem eine Solidaritätsträne aus dem Knopfloch für den Lutschbombon.
Und für Tim, der der einzige, der es verlässt. Ich find den Fullscreen-Button an der Stelle vollkommen in Ordnung. Da hat man auf jeden Fall mehr Nutzen draus. Ich sag nur, ich weiß nicht, was das mit diesen monochromen Icons soll. Was soll denn das jetzt heißen? Soll jetzt jedes Programm das auch tun? Ist das jetzt der neue Style? Und alle Icons sehen dann gleich aus? Dann können sie auch meinetwegen gleich überall nur noch Floppy-Dis-Icons machen. Ja, ich meine, kennst du das bei Windows? Hast du auch immer dieses Gefühl, dass eigentlich alle Icons gleich aussehen bei Windows? Alle sind immer so files irgendwie. Ich weiß nicht, vielleicht bin ich da auch ein bisschen zu beballert, aber ich hab extreme Probleme, Icons bei Windows-Programmen auseinanderzuhalten.
Du bist ja an so einem Rechner nur alle ein paar Jahre und dann kennst du den natürlich alle nicht. Auf Mac kennst du deine Icons natürlich.
Ich finde einfach, dass die selten anders aussehen, alle. Das ist so eine Melange aus so einer Pixel-Wolke, wo ich noch nicht mal weiß, wo das eine Icon anfängt und das andere aufhört.
Sollen wir mal aufhören, uns über Windows-Icons aufzuregen?
Ja, aber jetzt ist das ja auch so, wenn da jetzt alles grau wird.
Ja, abwarten, das ist ja nur ein Beta, das kann sich noch alles ändern.
Das wird sich nicht ändern.
Außerdem ist das vielleicht wieder so ein Test-Ballon, so wie sie bei iTunes auch...
Test-Ballon, so wie wir DC, das glaub ich nicht.
Nee, aber so wie bei iTunes, wo sie halt irgendwie eine Version raushauen und plötzlich sind die Ampel-Icons vertikal.
Und seit wann macht Apple irgendwie UIs, die irgendwie benutzbar sind?
Heute ist wirklich so, wir ranten über Apple. Apple, geh nach Hause, ey.
Ja, wir sind noch nicht mal bei Apple as Evil angekommen.
Genau, und wir sind gerade mal bei MW.
Mission Control, können wir mal Mission Control hinwegspielen?
Ja, genau.
Mission Control haben wir jetzt schon drüber geredet, ne?
Ja, Multitouch-Gesten haben wir auch drüber geredet. Networking.
What a low power wake. Captive Network.
Ja, also es ist vielleicht wieder ein Ding mehr reingeballert.
NFS 4 Support. Das ist ja selbst geschrieben eines NFS 4 Support. Was ist denn das hier?
Captive Network, when connecting to a network that requires authentication, Lion presents a window allowing you to log into the network.
Ja, sie detekten an...
Also...
Warte mal, was hat sich hier...
Ist das hier dieses Hotspot-Scheiß oder was?
Was du auch bei iPhone haben kannst auch durchaus sein.
Du kennst... Also Captive Portals halt.
Was meinen sie denn mit connecting to a network?
Wahrscheinlich per WLAN. Also ich vermute, ich weiß nicht, vielleicht hast du denn Huckel eine bessere Idee. Ich vermute mal, beim iPhone ist es ja so...
Aber wo ist denn das jetzt nicht so?
Na wenn du dich mit einem WLAN verbindest...
Na aufm Leinen. Das Snow Lappert ist nicht so.
Wenn es da einen Captive Portal gibt. Also du gehst halt in dein WLAN bei irgendwelchen Leuten, versuchst zu brausen und dann kommt erst mal so ein Captive Portal...
Ach, Hotspot-Scheiß.
Ja, genau.
Glauben wir, glauben wir. Wissen wir ja nicht.
Ja, nee, das würde ja sinnvoll sein, dass sie das einbauen.
Da geht ja dann auch eine extra Seite auf direkt beim Auswählen.
Okay, alles klar, sie haben Hotspot-Support drin, ja hurra.
Fotobus!
Und was ist noch? NFS V4.
Fotobus.
New Effects, ja, skip, skip, skip.
Oh, die waren doch super mit diesen... Das war doch die Twitter-Integration, diese Vögelchen, die da um den Kopf gerät.
Du kannst jetzt hier ein bisschen Fotobus machen, die Fotos stellen wir dann her.
Und jetzt bei Preview haben wir jetzt irgendwie Version Support, improved notes, aber eigentlich Signature kannst du addieren. Das ist auch nicht so spannend. Das ist ja auch nur ein App.
Weiter.
Next.
Smart Magnify.
Ah ja, skip, skip.
Smart Magnify my ass.
No.
Ah, du kannst Copy und Paste auch von den Bildern machen jetzt.
Toll, Copy und Paste mit Bildern. Was werden sie dich als nächstes ausdenken? Ja, super.
Das ist gut. Ich fand schon die Verbesserung von Preview und Snorlappart geil, dass sie so die Columns auseinanderhalten können und so weiter. Das ist schon extrem hilfreich.
Nee, Preview ist auch an sich sowieso eine super App.
Das ist eine gute Sache.
Jeder sollte eins haben.
Umso vieles besser als dieser scheiß Akkubatriere. Das ist wirklich...
Es gibt jetzt einen Privacy-Pref.
Usage, Data Collection, Manage, etc. Schick, schick, weiter Skip. So, QuickTime, was gibt es denn da neu? Eigentlich müssten wir ja langsam mit ihrem QuickTimeX oder wie es heißt, mal irgendwie ein bisschen vorwärtskommen.
QuickTime lets you combine multiple clips into a single movie. Simply drag the clips you want into a movie window. Scales and crops them to match dimensions. Ah ja, guck an. Also man kann jetzt auch editieren sozusagen.
Also was ich cool finde, ist Screen Capturing nur von Regionen vom Screen, weil das hab ich vorher vermisst.
Nur von Windows hätt ich gerne. Weil man direkt das Window anklicken kann.
Such as a specific window. Also geht da jetzt und du kannst halt auch die Clicks zeigen. Das heißt so diese ganzen Screencast Tools sind jetzt...
Das heißt, wenn ich da so irgendwo klicke, dann macht's gleich so ein Kreis, der dann so größer wird oder so.
Wofür hab ich dir neulich noch Screenflow gekauft?
Voll für den Arsch.
Also ich hab diese Screencast-Tools schon ein paar Mal benutzt und fand das eigentlich ganz geil. Und diese Hinzufügungen machen tatsächlich meinen Kaufwunsch nach Dritt-Ups extrem gering. Also ich hab jetzt...
Ja, aber sonst gibt's jetzt nicht viel Neues. AVs können immer noch nicht ordentlich, also...
Ich vermisse, also ich meine, ich sehe da jetzt ein Export Audio Only. Das ist insofern interessant, als dass es ja bisher überhaupt gar keinen Export gibt in dem QuickTime Player.
Wieso?
Du konntest doch nach iTunes schicken und nach Mail und nach iMovie und...
Das ist jetzt nicht so ganz das, was ich meinte.
Auf Movie klicke, dann sich iTunes öffnet, da krieg ich immer ne Krise.
Ja, aber was heißt denn, dass jetzt der QuickTime Player 7 nicht mehr drin ist?
Ich glaube, der war wirklich nicht dabei mehr.
Ja, das wäre dann aber mal der für mich ein ex-extra Grund, dieses Betriebssystem nicht zu installieren.
Also ich hatten hier...
Ich brauch täglich den QuickTime Player 7.
Ja, kannst halt nicht updaten, Tim.
Ja, Pech für dich.
Ja, aber wie soll ich denn sonst das tun, was ich mit QuickTime seit 20 Jahren mache? Ich muss aber meine Spuren exportieren.
Kauft dir Windows.
So, weiter.
Warum solltest du so einen Lion auch haben wollen bisher? Hat der ja nichts Cooles gehabt, oder?
Genau, wir haben nur gerantet bisher.
Stimmt.
Nee, stimmt gar nicht.
Außer Feilwoll war doch alles Scheiße.
Und Versions.
Der Maus-Zeiger hat keine Zacken.
Ja, aber hast du doch gehört, der war doch auch nicht HD.
Ja, der hat Zacken.
Der hat weiche Zacken jetzt.
Kann man sich dann über den App-Store kaufen, das wird extra.
Ja, also wie gesagt, wenn man einen Lion neu startet und da war noch ein Terminal offen, dann zeigt der glatt noch den alten Inhalt an. Also wenn die Bullen kommen, also ich meine, wenn irgendwer deine Kiste kassieren will, du fährst sie schnell runter, dann fahren sie die wieder hoch, steht alles noch da.
Es sei denn, du machst Instant Wipe.
So, ok. Safari. Das ist ja der Safari, der 5.1 heißt. Den gibt's ja schon auch irgendwie. Aber den muss man extra installieren. Ist das richtig, Max? Du hast den jetzt nicht da als 5.1, oder? Ich glaub, ich hab schon. Sag mal, die Bits und so, Jungs. Das sind doch eingetragene Developer. Und es ist auch sehr wohl bekannt, dass es eingetragene Developer sind. Dürfen die da eigentlich vom Lion erzählen? Oder von einer WWDC? Ich meine, sie stehen doch voll unter NDA.
Tja, die Bits und so, Jungs. Das ist jetzt auch eine diverse group of people.
Man kann doch hier mal durch die Liste durchgehen, was bei apple.com steht. Das ist ja nicht verboten.
Aber was ich da schon mal...
Ist immer schön, wie du dir das auch machst im anderen Podcast.
Aber wir reden doch gerade hier von einem Lion, was wir uns angucken. Du, das könnt ich dir auch gar nicht machen. Das ist schon klar.
Also was ja auch sehr schön ist, MarthML Support. Ich finde es ja immer wieder schön, was so in diese Browser auch noch alles so viele Technologien reingeklebt werden. Also wenn man heutzutage einen neuen Browser entwickeln will und keine bestehende Engine benutzen will, dann hat man wirklich richtig viel zu tun. Also MarthML ist jetzt auf jeden Fall eine sinnvolle Erweiterung.
Die haben ja auch alle schon aufgegeben mit ihrer eigenen Engine.
Und Sandboxing.
Und Worf Support.
Ist das jetzt eigentlich endlich mal so, dass hier in Safari jeder Tab sein eigener Prozess so richtig...
In 5.1 wollten sie das wohl irgendwie so machen. Das ist doch dieses Sandboxing, da steht es auch da, dass es ein eigener Support ist. Nee, da steht es noch nicht so richtig irgendwo.
Das ist WebKit 2.0, was das macht. Das ist gar kein Feature von Safari, sondern es ist ein Feature von WebKit.
Ach schon, die hatten das ja gleich native noch in die Render-Engine unten eingebaut, ne?
Genau, Safari benutzt das nur.
Ja, aber benutzt der Safari das da auch schon schon? Der neue, der?
Keine Ahnung.
Ich weiß es nicht sicher, aber ich würde alles andere...
Hier war es ab 5.1, als ihr das da machen würdet. Deswegen wollte ich wissen, ob du da den 5.1 schon zahlst.
Ja, das müssen sie machen, wenn sie diese Sandbox hier wirklich so pro Webseite machen, dann ist das meiner Meinung nach die Voraussetzung, dass sie das auch auf verschiedene Prozesse aufteilen.
Funktioniert das dann auch für Third-Party-Ups?
Bestimmt nicht.
Wenn die WebKit benutzen, ja.
Aber darfst du Box oder...?
Na ja, WebKit 2.0 macht das... Also ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, was das API da jetzt, ob man irgendwas einschalten muss, ausschalten muss, ob man es anschalten oder ausschalten kann. I don't know, aber es ist halt ein Feature von WebKit und kein generelles Feature von Safari. Das zeigt sich jetzt hier halt das erste Mal, weil sie natürlich die ersten sind, die das jetzt richtig rausbringen.
Also das ist ja für einen Endanwender gedacht.
Ja gut, und geswipe und tralala.
Und Instapaper ist es.
CSS3 Auto Hive Nation, das ist Silbentrennung, oder?
Was?
Hive Nation? Wo ist denn das?
Bei CSS3 Auto Hive Nation. Haben sie es mal eingebaut.
Ach so, man kann das sozusagen für seine eigene Webseite einschalten, dass wir hier Hive Nation haben.
Nee, du konntest, man konnte...
Spitze Klammer auf, Auto Hive Nation Klammer zu, denn ist Minus und dann... Nee, die können wahrscheinlich so einen Tag mitten ins Wort reinsetzen.
Es gibt so einen Shy Dash, den gibt es schon seit Ewigkeiten. Das ist sozusagen, wenn du einen Zeilenumbruch machen möchtest, dann mach ihn bitte hier. Also so für Silbentrennung.
So ein Vorschlag.
So ein Vorschlag wurde von allen Browsern im Wesentlichen ignoriert. Man hätte also problemlos einsetzen können, wenn nicht, ich glaube, das war natürlich der Internet Explorer, immer ein Bindestrich dahin gemacht hätte, wo dann dieses Shy-Bindestrich ist. Und ja, und darum...
FrameMaker hat das schon vor zehn Jahren alles richtig gemacht.
Ja, aber das ist... FrameMaker ist auch kein Browser.
Ich meinte ja natürlich nicht Bits und so, ich meinte natürlich die Fanboys.
Ja, los, weiter Scrolling.
New Process Architecture, da steht es ja auch.
Web browsing is now more stable.
Schön finde ich, dass mit diesem Reading List eine gute Idee, dass sie das eingebaut haben. Das ist wirklich sehr klug.
Was wäre von euch, den eingebauten RSS-Reader?
Bisweilen, ja, so als Preview ist er ganz brauchbar.
Steht da irgendwas von RSS-Reader?
Stick your finger in your...
Und er kann Flash-Cookies löschen. Steht da. Remove all website data. Safari removes cookie and flash plugin data.
Interessant, aber das kann jetzt Flash auch.
Flash bietet dafür jetzt eine API, die wird von Chrome unterstützt und jetzt offensichtlich auch von Safari.
Das ist jetzt in dem aktuellen 10.3-Flash-Plugin gibt es halt so die Möglichkeit, auch mal zu verbieten, dass man...
Ach, generell das zu verbieten?
Jaja, und dass du sie auch löschen kannst, einzeln und angucken kannst und so.
Sie bieten auch eine API, mit der ein Browser darauf zugreifen kann, dass wenn du sagst, alle Cookies löschen, dass die dann mitgelöscht werden. Dass du dann nicht extra nochmal wissen musst, dass du Flash drauf hast.
Interessant, aber sie haben ja Flash gar nicht dabei. Dass sie das hier reinschreiben.
Und mehr, dass man die löschen kann. Die alle da rumliegen.
Es ist gut, dass man die löschen kann.
Screen Sharing.
Per User Screen Sharing, das ist gut.
Ich bin schon so müde. Without interrupting someone else who might be using a computer...
Da hast du deine Information, die du von mir haben wolltest.
Und? Hast du das schon mal ausprobiert?
Nö, steht auch da.
Wenn es da steht, geht das immer.
Ich benutze übrigens Screen Sharing, was ja bei Snow Leopard auch dabei ist, als VNC-Ersatz. Man muss es halt nur finden, es ist nämlich im Hauptpfad in System Library Core Services oder wie auch immer das heißt drin. Den findet man auch per Spotlight nicht. Man muss wirklich da reingehen und den von dort aufrufen. Also System Library Core... Core Services und dann Screen Sharing. Der funktioniert und damit kannst du zu jedem VNC-Connect.
Das ist voll super. Ich hab den mal eine Zeit lang benutzt, hab festgestellt, dass wenn er eine Weile läuft, er gar nicht dazu genägt hat, extrem viel Prozessorlast zu saugen. Also dann irgendwie so auf 100% geht und nicht mehr runter will. Und kann er SSH?
Ja, das kann sein. Aber grundsätzlich als so mini VNC, wenn man mal einen braucht, tut er auf jeden Fall.
Auf jeden Fall haben sie jetzt diese ganzen Features eingebaut, die bisher nur in Remote Desktop drin waren, die immer total genervt haben, dass sie hier nicht dabei waren. Also Fullscreen Modus, Observe Only Modus ist total wichtig. Und ja, was ich interessant finde, ist mit dieser Apple ID. Du kannst jetzt an deinem Mac Apple IDs freischalten, mit denen sich dann jemand anders an deinem Rechner einloggen kann, ohne dass du für ihn einen Account machen musst. Das erscheint mir so ein bisschen so wie die Erweiterung des Guest-Accounts, die sie ja schon dabei haben. Dass du jetzt sozusagen sagst, ja hier, ich geb gar kein Passwort mehr ein. Das speichert keinen mehr, sondern du machst halt die Authentication über Apple. Und wenn Apple sagt, ja, hat sich mit seinem richtigen Passwort eingeloggt, dann macht er dir dafür automatischen Home auf.
Da ist natürlich dann die spannende Frage, wann kommt es dann, dass dann auch meine Daten da sind? Tja, das kann ja nicht mehr so extrem weit weg sein.
Mit iCloud, die sind schon da, bevor der Bildschirm bei dir ankommt.
Mit iCloud kann das sehr wohl sein, dass das dann auch tatsächlich so ist, dass du sagen kannst, ok, hier, schalt mich doch mal auf deinem Rechner frei, damit ich hier mit meiner iCloud arbeiten kann. Und dann lockst du dich da einfach ein mit deinem Passwort. Und wenn du dein Passwort änderst, dann ist das da halt auch geändert. Und pfiffig eigentlich. Schön alles über Apple machen, wa?
Du kannst ja auch bei FileVault dann den Crypto Key auch bei Apple ablegen, damit du dann bei FindMyMac, was ja dann wahrscheinlich auch kommen wird, auch mit einem Klick deinen Mac Remote wippen kannst.
Ja, damit die Bullens auch nicht so schwer haben, an deine Daten ranzukommen.
So, hier jetzt haben wir S wie Security. Da gibt es ein Feature, das heißt ASLR, also das Address Spaced Layout Randomization. Das heißt, die legen ihre Libraries und Stuff und Zeug und was weiß ich nicht, ihre QuickTime Frameworks, legen sie irgendwo randommäßig im Memory Spacer, so dass der Attacker nicht weiß, wo er hinspringen will, wenn er die für seinen Code benutzen will. Er benutzt ja nicht nur seinen eigenen Code, sondern muss ja auch einen Einsprungsvektor haben. Und das war bei 64-Bit schon irgendwie drin, glaube ich, auch unter Snow Leopard, aber unter 32-Bit noch nicht. Und hier steht jetzt, dass es auch für 32-Bit kommt, was mich ein bisschen wundert, dass es jetzt doch noch hinterher schieben. Und dann soll es wohl noch ein bisschen besser sein. Mit besser meinen natürlich, dass sie bei Snow Leopard diese Randomisation schon hatten, aber halt eben nicht für alle Frameworks. Und ich glaube eben auch QuickTime war nicht dabei. Das heißt, die Attacker wussten dann relativ schnell, welche irgendwie randommäßig platziert wurden, die sie einfach nicht benutzt haben, sondern die haben sich natürlich weiter in die genommen, die immer an der gleichen Stelle liegen und sind zu denen gesprungen. Also es war sozusagen schwache Leistung von Apple. Voll das Verkackt. Und jetzt haben sie es hoffentlich mal komplett gemacht. Wenn da immer noch ein Framework bei ist, was irgendwie immer noch an einer festen Adresse, die kannst du es eigentlich fast auch schon wieder vergessen.
Unhackbar!
Gibt es irgendwie Wahrscheinlichkeiten, dass es irgendwie an einer bestimmten Stelle liegt oder liegt es wirklich jedes Mal jedes Framework bei jedem Boot an einer anderen Stelle?
Na, wenn die da random liegen, liegen die immer an einer anderen Stelle. Wenn die aber bei Apple halt nicht alle an einer random Stelle machen, sondern eine halt nicht, dann weiß der Hacker halt, diese eine liegt immer da. Das heißt, dieser bestimmte Code liegt immer dort. Da kann ich reinspringen und kann dann in dem Rechner machen, was ich will.
Hätte ja sein können, dass wir nur einen bestimmten Rahmen sozusagen haben, dass so ein Framework sich mal um 10 Megabyte verschieben kann oder sowas.
Dann weiß der Hacker schon nicht mehr, wo der ist?
Na, ich hab mal was von, wie heißt das, das No-Operation-Rutschen gehört. Also, dass du sozusagen, dann musst du einfach entsprechend...
No-Op-Rutschen, das heißt, die machen da so viel Code irgendwie rein, dass dein PC, dein Program-Counter so lange langläuft, bis sie auf Code treffen, der irgendwie valide ist und so. Also, die Hacker lassen sich da schon üble, üble Sachen einfallen und es gibt da die Überhacker, die haben auch dieses ASLR da schon wieder längst ausgetrickst. Aber das sind halt auch wirkliche Überfliege, aber es ist eigentlich egal, die machen einmal so einen Hack, verkaufen ihn als Exploit, irgendwer baut den in seinen Virus ein und dann geht der um die Welt. Also, das ist leichter, wenn einer das kann.
Bei dem Wettrennen Hacker versus Betriebssystemhersteller ist jetzt Apple nicht mehr ganz so weit hinterher wie mit Snow Leopard noch.
Ist ein Stück besser geworden, könnte man so sagen, ja. Aber es ist sowieso, also ich meine, das ist kein Spiel, was man gewinnt, oder voll verlieren kann man es wahrscheinlich schon, aber es ist schon eher so ein Katz-und-Maus-Ding. Also wie bei Tom & Jerry halt. Da gewinnt ja nicht der eine und nicht der andere, sondern die kloppen einfach die ganze Zeit.
Und wir haben auch Spaß.
Genau.
So muss es sein.
So, Spotlight. Angeblich auch wieder schneller, besser weiter, was ich ja gut finde, weil ich persönlich bin ja Spotlight-Benutzer, weil ich hab gar keinen Bock, mir irgendwie hier so eine Loungebar-Tools immer abzudaten und zu machen und zu tun. Und Spotlight ist eigentlich mit einer SSD sowas von scheiße schnell, also da braucht man nichts anderes mehr. Und Spotlight kann rechnen. Ich muss es nochmal betonen, es gibt immer wieder Leute, die irgendwie Bauklötze stauen werden. Ich irgendwie in Spotlight schnell mal irgendwie hier irgendwie die...
Aber dieses Drag und Drop aus Spotlight finde ich gut. Da oben steht Drag und Drop vom Spotlight-Menü, dass man direkt aus Menü oder Datei nehmen kann und rausziehen, wenn man irgendwie mal was verschicken will.
Das fehlt allerdings wirklich. Oder wenn man einfach mal nur, manchmal findet der was und ich will dann den Pfad wissen, da hätte ich auch gerne was, dass ich mit der Maus drüber gehen kann und der mir dann irgendwie den Pfad zeigt. Denkst du mit so einem Tooltip oder so, dass da so was kommt, dass ich's sehe? Ich will es nicht mal kopiert haben teilweise, ich will ihn nur wissen.
Ich mach dann immer Shift, ne, was ist das? Command-Return, ne?
In Spotlight oder in dem Launchbar?
In Spotlight.
Also wenn du was machst, ich will jetzt wissen, wo mein Calculator liegt und ich will nur den Pfad liegen, dann gehst du dahin und du drückst so wie eine Special-Taste und drückst dann Return oder was?
Command-Return. Das ist nicht das, was du meinst, aber es ist...
Er springt schon mal dahin, aber er startet ihn nicht. Normalerweise würde er ihn ja starten, richtig?
Das ist das Show-In-Finder, sozusagen.
Wieder was gelernt, siehste? Ich wieder beruhigt nach Hause gehen.
Ja, aber jetzt ist Quick Look mit drin und ich denke mal, das könnte das auch abdecken. Drückst du jetzt einfach nur noch Space, dann müsstest du diese Informationen vielleicht auch... Oder zeigst du dann nur den...
Nein, bei Space geht's einfach weg, dann änderst du den Inhalt von Spotlight oben, weil du hast ja in Space gedrückt. Ja, ja, ist schon klar.
Nein, in Lion.
Ja, ich wollte es nur mal hier testen. Was passiert? Wie System.
Wie System.
Das schöne Icon hier, schönes Icon für Windows-Migration.
About as Mac ist jetzt ein neuer.
Fenster über ein Finder ziehen.
Fullscreen Chess, das ist natürlich total wichtig.
Vor allem unter System.
Ach, türkisch gab's vorher nicht, ja?
Arabisch, Tschechisch, Türkisch, Ungarisch. Das heißt, das gibt es immer noch nicht in Hebräisch?
Macintosh ist nicht kosher? Ich bin mir auch ein Österreicher Bruder bei dir.
Ich glaube, die haben auch schon hier... Also von rechts nach links schreiben und so haben die doch den Support schon. Den baust du doch nicht ein, wenn du dann kein Hebräisch machst.
Von rechts nach links schreiben machen nicht nur die Israelis.
Ja, aber es sind wahrscheinlich... Wer macht's noch? Es kam ja auch grad erst, oder? Stand da nicht gerade Arabisch?
Jaja, da stand Arabisch.
Ja, aber ich bin mir jetzt nicht ganz sicher. Also wenn ich nicht irgendwas verpasst habe, meines Wissens gab es noch nie ein MechOS, was sozusagen komplett in Hebräisch ist. Was übrigens auch einer der Gründe ist, warum der Mech extrem unpopulär ist in Israel. Aber wir können das mal... Ich starte das mal nach. Vielleicht habe ich...
Ja, und mach mal das andere Fenster und wir gucken mal weiter.
End doch doch mal deine System-Language.
Versuch die doch mal auf den Beweg. Apple ID Authentication for File Sharing. Ach, for File Sharing, ist ja okay.
Wo steht denn diese Information?
Das kommen wir bei Social System Preferences. Dann können wir nämlich mal das nächste Thema...
Haben wir denn hier noch irgendwas Schönes in System? Profiles. Damit kann man hier Systeminstallationen verteilen. Das ist auch sehr interessant. Wenn man an der Uni arbeitet.
Um mal Dennis zu zitieren. Skip, skip, skip.
Wir sollten unsere Sendung Skip, Skip, Skip nennen.
Custom Desktop Color. Jetzt kann man sich eine eigene Farbe für den Schreibtischhintergrund aussuchen.
Unglaublich, oder? Krass, wenn das einer hört.
Ach so, man kann jetzt hier wie auf dem iPhone scrollen, dass ich der Inhalt hochscrollt oder dass ich die Scrollbar hochscrollt, wobei dann der Inhalt nach unten scrollt.
Entweder so wie früher oder so wie neu.
Oder wie so, dass keiner mehr mit deinem Rechner klarkommt.
Ich weiß nicht ganz genau, woran ich mich gewöhnen werde.
Also wenn man nur mit dem Mac macht, kann man es schon... Also wenn man nur Mac benutzt und man hat ein iPhone, dann könnte man es schon umstellen, das macht schon Sinn. Aber wenn man noch irgendwie mit anderen Leuten klarkommen will, auf dieser Welt...
Ich muss mit niemandem klarkommen. Ich hab mir unter Snowlapp, gibt es so ein Programm, mit dem man das Scroll Revert oder sowas heißt das?
Dynamisch umstellen, dann ist ja noch schlimmer.
Ja genau, das ändert sich automatisch alle 20 Sekunden, aber ich weiß nicht, nein, das ist... Und damit hatte ich mir das einmal geändert und hab mich daran gewöhnt. Und man gewöhnt sich sau schnell dran. Und ja, dann hat man das halt so und alles ist gut. Apple Color Emoji-Fond. Endlich kann man Emoji-Symbole auch auf dem Mac sehen. Ich glaube der einzige Grund dafür ist, damit man iTunes-Kritiken noch versteht, wenn man App Store-Kritiken hier so... Ey, das ist voll kacke, kacke, kacke.
Echtes Asiapdate hier. Emoji.
Improved Auto-Correction.
Bessere chinesische Eingabe. Und andere Sprachen, wo ich keine Ahnung, was das ist. Was bitte ist? Kotoeri. Klingt japanisch.
Aber sie können hier plötzlich Auto-Correktoren machen, wie auf dem iPhone, ne?
Ob das eine gute Sache ist. Text-Edit ist auch ganz nett, aber so ja, hm.
Time Machine, darüber müssen wir reden. Was machen wir? Ich hab übrigens einen Vorschlag. Wir machen eine Pause nach diesem Blog.
Wie jetzt? Hast du denn spezielle Musik? Mach erst mal und dann machst du...
Ja, lass das mal weiter mal hin.
Ja, hab ich.
So, okay, Time Machine. Encrypted Backups, na da ist es ja wieder. In der Zeit wird es ja auch mal.
Das hätte ich gern als Klingelton.
Ja, aber nur, wenn du eine Platte anschließt.
Was meinst du?
Also die Hacker werden sich schon was einfallen lassen, dass es auch dann irgendwie am Ende mit dem ZSF auf meinem Freebie-System geht.
Ich will das Encrypted über WLAN haben. Ich will das auf der Time-Capsule haben. Also Local Snapshots, das ist eigentlich das Ding. Also das ist, ich bin zwar immer noch stark im Zweifel, wie sie das konkret implementiert haben, aber...
Ist eine schöne Sache.
Das ist grundsätzlich erstmal richtig, weil du willst halt auch auf Dateien zurückgreifen können, die du dir für eine Stunde gelöscht hast.
Also was ich vermute, dass du nicht... Ohne jetzt der Gap zu haben, ne? Also so nach dem, was ich verstanden habe und so was ich gehört habe, wird da einfach quasi ein virtuelles Volumen angelegt. Und dass das Backup gemacht wird, bin ich mir nicht 100% sicher.
Ja, ja, das hatten wir ja schon mal. Das ist dieses Slash-Time-TM-FS-Time-Machine-File-System. Oder TM, irgendwas FS. Also wenn du mal auf der Comanot-Seile da mal Mount eingibst oder so oder DF, dann müsste das auftauchen. Zwar zumindest in den ersten Versionen von Lion. Und mir ist halt nicht ganz klar, wie das implementiert ist. Also ich hatte da schon mal diverse Mutmaßungen, die sich jetzt weder bestätigt haben, noch dass sie irgendwie, also sie sind weder bestätigt worden, noch wurde irgendwas Gegenteiliges behauptet. Mir ist nicht ganz klar, wie effizient das ist. Im Zweifelsfall ist das halt einfach dasselbe, wie sie das eben auch beim normalen Time Machine machen, einfach mit Hardlings irgendwie, aber eben nochmal verborgen mit so einer hübschen Geschichte.
Also es sorgt meistens dafür, dass die Leute, die keine Ahnung haben, wundern sich, warum ihre Platte irgendwann voll ist.
Die Frage war ja, ob das also bedeutet, dass es Snapshots gibt. Das war sozusagen die Kernfrage. Hat das HFS auf einmal richtige Snapshots? Ich meine, das ist das, was sie hier schreiben, local Snapshots. Aber ich glaube nicht, dass sie das auch meinen. Aber wissen tue ich es nicht. Schön fände ich es. Weil wenn es Snapshots gäbe...
Ja, wir warten auf Syracusa.
Ja, der kommt erst wahrscheinlich im August.
Was meinen sie denn hier mit Combined Timeline? When you connect your Mac to your Time Machine Backup Drive or Time Capsule, Time Machine automatically displays everything you did while you were away with your existing Time Machine Backup.
Na, dass er das mit deinen local Snapshots gleich kombiniert. Das meint er damit.
Ach so, verstehe, sie kombinieren die lokalen Snapshots mit dem auf dem Backup gleich in einem Video.
Combined Timeline.
Ja, ja, ne, ne, ne, okay, alles klar.
Also man kriegt einfach nicht raus, welche Version gerade wo ist.
Ist ja auch egal.
Ja, ja, aber es ist schlicht und ergreifend so, wie man erwartet. Wenn man die Time Machine startet, dann...
Genau, alle Versionen, die du schon mal hattest. So, Junix, jetzt gibt es hier das Fullscreen Terminal-Window.
Ja, aber viel wichtiger die ANSI-Colors.
256 Farben. Ja, aber jetzt kommt auch wieder das, was wir irgendwie mit 10.1 schon mal hatten oder mit 10.0. Und zwar, dass jetzt, wenn du den Terminal hier minimierst, in den Stock rein, dass da drin weiter live geupdated wird. Das gab es nämlich schon mal früher und haben sie irgendwann ausgeschaltet.
Das haben sie ausgeschaltet.
Mit 10.3 oder mit 10.4 haben sie es irgendwie weggemacht. Und jetzt ist es wieder da. Weil wenn ich mit 10.2 oder 10.1, als es noch da war, hat es voll Last gekostet, wenn du so ein Fenster offen hattest. Und da war was gebaut da drin und es hat die ganze Zeit gescrollt. Und da hat es das Ding im Dock, da war dein Rechner irgendwie platt. Also mehr oder weniger.
Ich habe auch immer GL-Term benutzt, weil das hat mit OpenGL damals schon die Terminal-Darstellung gemacht.
Was hast du gerade an uns vorbeigescrollt, hier, du Schummler?
Okay, aber Moment mal, nee, nee, nur mal kurz. The drag-and-drop support for proxy icons to insert a reference to a current directory or file into a session or tab just drags a proxy icon in the terminal window title bar. War doch schon immer so, oder? Ach, jetzt kann man es auch in die Title bar schieben.
Und wo ist da der Unterschied? Fenster ist doch für einfache Title bar treffen.
Sie mussten irgendwie auf 250 Sachen kommen. Wahrscheinlich kann man auch zu einem Tab, den man gerade nicht sieht, das irgendwie rüber schieben oder so, mal gucken. Tatsächlich, man kann es jetzt auch zu einem File schieben, das man gerade nicht sieht. Oh mein Gott.
Das verstehe ich nicht.
Ne, wenn du zwei Tabs offen hast, als bisher...
Er hat doch gleich hin CD oder was?
Der scheint auch gleich ein CD zu haben, ja.
Der macht das automatisch, wenn man es oben in die... Wie heißt das Ding? Window-Leiste irgendwie schmeißt, macht da gleich ein CD an die Stelle. Na ja, endlich, das braucht dich schon immer. Ja doch. Jetzt mal ohne Shit.
Sonst dragst du mal rein, machst Ctrl-A und tippst noch ein CD.
Oder tippst vorher das CD, schiebst dann drüber und weil du vergessen hast, dass du schon ein CD getippt hast, machst du Ctrl-A und machst noch ein CD. Das hab ich ganz oft, dass da CD, CD steht.
Und dann musst du die Cursor-Hochtaste drücken, Ctrl-A, zweimal Fall rechts und zweimal die...
Nein, Function... Function-Delete natürlich.
Ah, Function-Delete. Ihr seid heilig. Aber endlich, endlich.
Ja, Versions haben wir im Prinzip schon drüber gesprochen.
Ja, dann gehen wir gleich weiter zum nächsten.
Xan, das allerwichtigste Feature.
Xan, kennen wir nicht, haben wir nicht. Ja, ob ich mich da noch dran gewöhnen kann, bevor ich in Rente gehe.
Ich glaube, da gewöhnt man sich.
Interact with Photos in Screensaver.
Amazing.
It's incredible.
Interact with iTunes Artwork in Screensaver.
Es gibt einen Screenserver, mit dem man...
Overlay Scrollbars. Ob das gut ist, du weißt ja nie, wo du wirklich bist, weil du musst immer erst mal so ein bisschen scrollen, damit die mal kurz kommen, damit du einen Überblick hast. Und bei manchen Tours sind die aber dauerhaft da, damit du halt die ganze Zeit weißt, wo du bist. Nämlich in Terminal, glaube ich, gehen die nicht so richtig weg, oder? Die sehen zwar schicker aus, aber sie gehen nicht weg, oder? Ich weiß ja nicht. Also wie ist das Line?
Wir sitzen das aus, glaube ich.
Ich glaube, mit dem neuesten Grafik-Triver da raus schmeißt du in meinen Snow Leopard rein und dann gucken wir mal.
Nee, ich glaube, am Ende des Tages, ja, auch wenn wir jetzt hier gesagt haben, Apple kann ja gar nichts an vielen Stellen, Die können schon eine ganze Menge. wird es schon auch schick zu benutzen sein bestimmt.
Naja, also dieses Snow Leopard war auch deswegen so cool, weil der Hecht auch so underground-mäßig dieses ganze geile Zeug haben und noch mal verbessert wurde und auch vorher so mit Grand Central und dem ganzen Schnickschnack.
Das geile Zeug kommt immer aus dem Underground.
Ja, das fehlt ja doch so ein bisschen, der Snow Lion. Ich warte auf den Snow Lion, das wär's. Gibt's keinen?
Es gibt auf jeden Fall eine Kreuzung aus Tigern und Löwen, da gab's noch...
Gibt's Schnee Löwen? Wir sind jetzt hier am Ende mit unserer Lion-Vorstellung. Wenn die Hörer jetzt noch nicht alle eingeschlafen sind, was steht denn noch so auf dem Speiseplan?
Na, wir machen jetzt eine kurze Pause und lüften mal und atmen nochmal kurz durch.
Allerdings, hier sind gefühlte 35 Grad, in Wirklichkeit sind es 24,5.
Und Luft gibt es auch keine mehr.
Und Sauerstoff ist auch schon bei 4,5 Prozent.
Genau, und deswegen spielen wir jetzt für unsere Hörer etwas leise Musik und dann geht es weiter.
Bis gleich, nach der Pause schalten sie wieder ein.
Wenn es wieder heisst.
iOS und iCloud.
Genau.
Wir gehen an die komplette Feature-Liste von iOS 5.
Und dann vor allen Dingen haben wir...
Lion-Feature-Liste noch ein zweites Mal.
Vor allen Dingen haben wir das gemacht, was Phil Schiller am liebsten auf der Keynote gemacht hat. Wir haben jetzt Phil's Wunsch erfüllt und dann jedes Feature einzeln durchgelegt.
Alle 250 Feature. Das wäre aber auch ein großer Spaß geworden. Dann ist hier das Alkohol-Cambol da, wenn man hier rüber geht.
Diese Bilder, wo sich alle Features zeigen. Kannst du dich noch erinnern, was wir früher mal irgendwie ran gesoomt haben, auch noch die kleinsten Wörter da drin zu entdecken, hast du die dir mal irgendwie geschnappt? In der Mitte sind die ganzen Keywords, die in neue Features kommen. Und da stehen auch manchmal noch so voll versteckte kleine Dinge dabei.
Ja, das ist die Sache mit den A-P's.
Genau, da sind doch schon noch manchmal coole Hinweise. Aber jetzt machen wir eine Nachterpause. Spiel mal deine Musik ein.
Wir gucken uns jetzt die Mondfinsternis nämlich auch an.
Oh, das Mondfinsternis. Aber die fängt erst um 22.30 Uhr an, oder?
Das wird eine lange Nacht, Jungs hier.
Ach, haben die hier einen interaktiven...
Ja, Google macht Live-Image-Feed auf der...
Ach schick.
Ich hatte mir das irgendwo notiert, aber ich weiß gerade nicht wo. Ah, hier. Hier hab ich's. Ich hab noch ein Sonderdokument.
Das reichen wir auch nach der Pause ein.
Genau. Muss das erst mal hier...
Aber diese Google... Wie heißen die Doodles, ne? Die wären immer besser. Ich fand ja heute die Gitarre schon ganz geil.
So, wir machen jetzt eine Pause.
Ich hab Musik.
Control Space, TM, Körser rechts.
So, und jetzt?
Bumzack, return.
Das heißt ja nicht umsonst, bumzack, return.
Jaja, hier ist Mobamex.
Oder so, ja.
Wir begrüßen alle unsere Hörer da draußen. Da sind wir wieder.
Sind wir wieder da? Haben alle hier pullert?
Ja, ich mich, Mist.
Das war jetzt etwas mehr Information, als ich wollte.
Er meint, gibt pull.
So, was gab's noch?
Also jetzt noch zwei Stunden iOS, dann noch eine Stunde Bitcoin. Und dann können wir noch ein bisschen über WWDC reden, oder? Also hier so...
Steve!
Über die ganzen...
Steve sah richtig schlimm aus, ey. Also, hat sich auch schlimm angehört.
Habt ihr bei Gruber dieses Foto, das ich jetzt hier habe? Habt ihr dieses Foto gesehen, wo er am Ende so mit seiner Frau da steht? Naja, wo er irgendwie den Kopf auf die Schulter... Der macht echt den Eindruck, als ob er krank ist. Als ob er verdammt krank ist.
Das ist ja nichts Neues.
Meinst du, der ist jetzt so richtig doll krank und stellt sich da trotzdem noch mal auf die Bühne? Hat der drauf, oder? Der stellt sich da drauf und will auf der Bühne sterben.
Also ich hab mir vor ein paar Tagen noch mal diese... seine Reden angehört, als er gerade wieder zurückkam zu Apple, noch bevor er der ICO war. Und wenn du irgendwie so den Stief mit dem aktuellen Stief vergleichst, hast du echt das Gefühl, da sind 20 oder 30 Jahre vergangen. Also dass das irgendwie nur 10 Jahre her ist, das will man echt nicht glauben.
Ja, das ist krass. Also ich mein, wie lange soll das noch so weitergehen, dass der kann nicht noch dünner werden? Ich mein, der hat ja immer noch die gleichen Klamotten an, und der Pulli... Echt? Also ich meine, die Sachen, die schlackerten auch alle, also das war echt nicht schön.
Er hat halt ein Ernährungsproblem, das weiß man ja auch.
Ich würde sagen, das ist mehr als nur ein Ernährungsproblem.
Er ist halt schon ganz schön schwer angeschlagen.
Auf jeden Fall.
Der Ringrichter hat den schon bis zur Hälfte durchgezählt.
We love you Steve and we know it helps.
Ja, vor allen Dingen am Anfang auch so dieses... genau. Was hat er gesagt, als er irgendwie immer das... Das ist auch der Grund, warum iCloud nichts mehr kostet. Der wird weich auf seine alten Tage.
Gut, also iOS 5 ist angekündigt worden. Kommt wann, haben sie gesagt? Herbst, oder was war die Aussage?
Mit dem iPhone 5, ne?
Vermutlich, aber was war die Aussage? War die Aussage September, oder war die Aussage Herbst?
Ich glaube auch, bin mir jetzt aber nicht so sicher, aber ich glaube Herbst.
Ich bin mir auch ziemlich sicher, dass es Herbst war.
Na gut, Herbst ist bestimmt September.
Vermutlich hoch.
Herbst kann Dezember sein.
Nun gibt es also Notifications. Man zieht mit dem Fingerchen von oben in den Bildschirm rein und dann sieht man alles. Tja, da bin ich ja mal gespannt. Sieht auf jeden Fall ganz aufgeräumt aus.
Also wovor ich mich da ja ein bisschen fürchte, ich hoffe, das kriegen sie sauber hin, ist, bei Android ist es so, also wann hat eine Nachricht da wegzugehen? Das ist ja nicht trivial, weil heißt das jetzt, wenn ich das einmal runterziehe, dass die Nachricht damit als gelesen zu markieren ist und weg kann, soll die verschwinden, wenn ich das App das nächste Mal starte, soll die verschwinden, wenn ich die betreffende Mail das erste Mal öffne. Und ich hab das Gefühl, dass es genauso ist, wie auf diesen Screenshots hier, dass da immer eine ziemlich lange Liste mit allem möglichen Zeug drauf ist und höchstens die Hälfte davon interessiert dich und du bist die ganze Zeit nur am Notificationslöschen. Das ist ein bisschen meine Angst.
Ja, weil man das sehr schnell machen kann, das ist ja fast schon wieder okay. Das ist halt die Frage, wie aufwendig das ist.
Na, man muss halt auf diese kleine Closebox hier klicken und dann muss man nochmal explizit bestätigen, ja löschen.
Da man es aber jederzeit ganz schnell holen kann und man nicht in irgendwelche Menüs runter oder reinwandern muss, ist das ja eigentlich noch okay, oder? Ich meine, das ist ja wirklich mit einem Swipe irgendwie runtergezogen, ist es da. Dann irgendwie mit einem auf X geklickt, ist es weg und dann vielleicht nochmal bestätigt, ja, es geht doch schon.
Ich fand's bei Android immer sehr, sehr nervig, diese ganzen Notifications.
Aber wie viele Notifications hast du denn bekommen? Kannst du doch auch einstellen, wie viele es so sind, oder?
Du kannst schon einstellen, wie viele es sind, aber ich vermute mal, dass jetzt, wo die Notifications nicht mehr ganz so aufdringlich sind, dass die App-Entwickler damit umso mehr anfangen und dass man dann immer da eine riesige Latte hat und dass man die ständig aufräumen muss und so. Ich kann mir vorstellen, dass das schon der nächste Ausgang für neues Desaster ist.
Am Ende kannst du halt selber konfigurieren, was du sehen willst und was nicht. Das ist ja auch jetzt schon so.
Ich bin davon noch nicht hundertprozentig überzeugt, dass das wirklich die perfekte Lösung ist. Es ist definitiv um einiges besser, als es vorher war. Also es kann nicht schlechter sein, als es vorher war.
Was ich mich nur frage ist, ich meine, sie haben da jetzt auch dieses Weather-Vidget und dieses Börsen-Vidget da eingebaut. Mit diesem Börsenteil können sie mir gerne irgendwie vom Hals bleiben. Die Frage ist nur, ist das irgendetwas, wo sich auch andere einklinken können? Vermutlich nicht, aber schön wär's.
Na, so ein paar Jailbreaker haben schon geschafft, da reinzukommen, natürlich. Also die Private Arpies dafür scheinen vorhanden zu sein, und auch nicht sonderlich schwer zu finden, weil wie lange ist das jetzt draußen? Und ich vermute mal, dass das kommen wird. Aber auch da wieder, sie werden...
Erstmal das erste Release abwarten.
Sie werden das erste Release abwarten und sie werden Hölle drauf aufpassen, dass sich da nicht jeder reinpappt. Also sie werden sich da auch ein Prinzip ausdenken, schätze ich mal, dass man direkt da auch sagen kann, ey, geh mir weg mit dem Scheiß.
Naja, auf jeden Fall kommt das Ganze dann auch auf den Log-Screen und man kann dann direkt davon, direkt vom Log-Screen, quasi man unloggt dann nicht mehr global das Telefon, sondern man unloggt quasi diese Notifizierung und landet dann eben in dem entsprechenden Ich finde das ja ganz hübsch.
Ich finde es nicht unbedingt intuitiv, aber das hat man auch im Video schön gesehen, dass wenn man hier, man sieht da diese einzelnen Notifications da ist immer das Icon von dem Programm, von dem App da daneben, wo es dazu gehört. Und wenn man dieses Icon drackt, dann wird man direkt in das App reingeschmissen. Also man kann jetzt Slide to Unlock machen, wie bisher gehabt oder man kann halt oben das finde ich ganz knuffig.
Ja, was soll man dazu noch mehr sagen?
Wie ist denn das, haben noch immer alle also wie ist das auf WebOS eigentlich mit den Notifications? Weiß das jemand?
Die erscheinen unten am Bildschirm, zumindest bei den Telefonen. Also dann wird quasi der Bildschirm so ein bisschen virtuell ein bisschen verkleinert. Und sie erscheinen kurzzeitig ungefähr so wie bei IOS hier, so diese komplette Größe und werden schrumpfen dann so ein bisschen, aber du siehst halt immer noch so mehrere Icons. Ich finde nach wie vor bei WebOS die Notifications hübscher gelöst. Die machen einen sehr guten Eindruck.
So, jetzt können wir uns hier noch ein bisschen über iMessage streiten.
Also, das ist...
Es sieht aus wie iChat, ja.
Na, es sieht aus wie das SMS-Programm. Oder es ist das SMS-Programm.
Nee, es hat auch so Punkt, Punkt, Punkt.
Aber es ist ja direkt im SMS drin. Es ist ja kein X-Tribe, sondern es ist da.
Es ist direkt im SMS drin.
Genau, das einzige Unterschied ist, dass unten beim Send-Button, ne Quatsch, bevor man was eintippt, steht dann iMessage da anstatt Text oder SMS.
Genau, also ich hab so ein... Es ist, es ist... Es sieht ein bisschen anders aus.
Es macht aber genau dasselbe wie iChat.
Nee, es macht genau das gleiche wie SMS-Programm.
Jungs, das hatten wir schon.
Ihr seid beide disqualifiziert jetzt.
Nein, es macht nicht genau das gleiche. Du siehst, wenn der andere tippt... Ja, das macht SMS nicht. Du siehst nicht, wenn jemand anderes anfängt, eine SMS zu schlagen.
Oder du kriegst jetzt auch Benachrichtigungen, wenn er es dann gelesen hat. Das ging vorher auch nicht.
Stimmt, das kriegt man auch.
Ja, du hast Fotos mit drin.
Voll toll, ich werde den Huckel so voll taxen.
Ja, aber guck dir das an, es sieht aus wie iChat, es tut dasselbe wie iChat. Aber es ist nicht iChat und ich wette, ich wette, ich wette, das ist Jabber.
Ja, welches Protokoll dahinter steht?
Das ist wie Jabber mit Push dahinter, so wie das die derzeitigen Jabber-Klients auf iOS auch machen.
Was ich bei dem ganzen Zeug ein bisschen merkwürdig finde, ist man kann ja hier dieses iMessage, kann man ja auch auf dem iPad verwenden und auf dem iPod. Und beim iPhone macht man das über seine Telefonnummer. Also da ist man unter seiner Telefonnummer erreichbar für iMessages, aber auf dem iPad ist man nur über seine E-Mail-Adresse erreichbar. Umgekehrt hingegen geht es schon. Also man kann auf dem iPhone kann man sagen, hey, ich bin jetzt auch noch unter der E-Mail-Adresse erreichbar. Was ich daran total doof finde, dass man keine Möglichkeit hat zu sagen, ich möchte gerne Nachrichten, die an meinen Telefon geschickt worden sind, auf meinem iPad lesen. Warum sie das nicht mal... Wenn du mich jetzt über Facetime zum Beispiel erreichen willst, im Augenblick, und dann kannst du mich entweder über meine Telefonnummer erreichen, dann kriegst du mich aber nur auf dem Telefon. Auf meinem Mac kann ich hier Facetime einrichten, wie ich will. Ich kann es nicht mit meiner Telefonnummer verknüpfen. Wohingegen umgekehrt geht es schon. Also ich kann auf dem Mac sagen, hier, erreich mich über meine Apple ID, und ich kann auf dem iPhone auch sagen, erreich mich über meine Apple ID.
Ja, nur auf dem Mac kann ich... Also das ist mir einfach alles zu inkonsequent. Also das ist wieder etwas, das kann ich jetzt nur mit iOS machen. Und nicht mit dem Mac. Jetzt wo sie gerade irgendwie alles versuchen gleich zu machen, und alles sind jetzt Devices, und alles singt auf dieselbe Art und Weise mit der Cloud. Und dann gibt es das jetzt nur auf dem iPad und auf iOS. Ich meine, was so ein Quatsch.
Es gibt dann bald für 99 Cent im Mac App Store die iMessage App bestimmt bald.
Ich fände das auch gar nicht so schlimm, wenn das nur auf diesen mobilen Geräten ist, weil Chatten ist schon was anderes als eine Nachricht, sich gegenseitig zu schicken.
Das ist auch ein mobiles Gerät.
Ja, das ist auch ein mobiles Gerät, aber guck mal, mit welcher Geschwindigkeit ich hier drauf tippe und welche Aufmerksamkeit ich dafür habe. Das ist ja wirklich, das ist nicht iChat, das ist eine SMS. Das ist eine App wie die SMS.
Hast du eine Zeichenlimitierung?
Wo ist denn da der Unterschied? Ich verstehe überhaupt nicht, wo du da einen Unterschied siehst. Ich schicke halt eine kurze Nachricht hin, ich kriege eine kurze Nachricht zurück, das ist Chatten. Leute chatten über SMS, bloß sind das halt die teuersten Bits der Welt.
Also ich, beim Chatten mache ich das so, dass ich schon dialogisch vorgehe. Also wenn ich mit jemandem im Gespräch bin, dass ich dann auch auf eine Antwort warte, zum Beispiel. Du sitzt da vor und wartest, bis die Person eine Antwort geschickt hat?
Das ist doch auch nicht dein Chat-Fenster so lange vor der Grund, bis eine Antwort da ist.
Im einigen Fällen schon.
Komm, wir gehen, ich kann nicht. Ich habe vor zwei Tagen jemanden...
Ja, nicht vor zwei Tagen, aber wenn ich im Gespräch bin, dann bin ich im Gespräch, dann nimmt das meine Aufmerksamkeit ein. Ich finde das ist schon ein Unterschied.
Ja, dann gehst du da irgendwie anders mit um. Für mich ist das alles dasselbe. Ich will SMS eigentlich überhaupt nicht mehr benutzen, weil es ist einfach Quatsch, dafür Geld auszugeben, für diese paar Buchstaben.
Hast du jetzt auch ein Message?
Ja, aber ein Message geht halt nur mit iOS.
Warum? Erstmal.
Ja, gut, erstmal, aber so in dem Zustand, finde ich es halt irgendwie quark.
Kommt vielleicht in einem App-Store für Lion?
Ich hab gerade gesagt...
Man muss doch ein bisschen deutlicher reden, man.
Erstmal zuhören, dein Arsch muss weiters krollen.
Newsstand finde ich ganz spannend vom Aussehen her.
Total spannend.
Oder liegt das zu Hause?
Das sieht aus wie iBooks.
Was?
Das sieht aus wie iBooks, oder?
Nee, iBooks ist ein eigenes App. Newsstand sieht aus wie ein Folder im Springboard.
Vor allem, was ist das? Sind das Programme?
Ah, so.
Sind das Programme? Ja, ne? Das sind Apps.
Na wahrscheinlich sind es im Endeffekt schon Apps.
Das sind Apps, die sich automatisch updaten oder wie?
Apps mit selbst aktualisierendem Content.
Genau, und das auch im Hintergrund, wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe. Genau.
Und halt über ein eigenes User-Interface, das so ein bisschen Springboard ist, so ein bisschen aber auch nicht.
Also das mit dem Background-Download, das war absolut überfällig. Ich finde, das gehört einfach dazu, da immer drauf zu warten. Das ist wirklich Quatsch. Ich vermute mal, die ganzen Apps müssen dafür erst mal angepasst werden.
Sind wir sicher.
Und vermutlich wird es bei Apps bleiben. Ich hatte ja, als sie irgendwie mit Newsstand anfingen, dachte ich ja, sie hätten jetzt hier meine andere Vorhersage oder meinen anderen Wunsch da erfüllt, dass sie jetzt quasi so ein E-Book-Format für Magazines aus der Taufe heben und dass man jetzt eben Magazines in so einem HTML-artigen Full-Layout da reintun kann und sich eben genauso anguckt wie bei E-Books auch und dass Newsstand nur so ein anderer View ist. Aber ja, keine Ahnung, scheint wohl eher was zu tun zu haben mit Apps, die Subscriptions laufen haben und die sagen ich bin ein News-Item und dann tauchen sie halt automatisch da in diesem Dingsbums auf. Ist sicherlich ganz praktisch nur, dass ich irgendwie immer noch nicht auch nur irgendwie Interesse an einer dieser Applikationen hab, weil ich das irgendwie alles Quatsch finde.
Ich hab ja in letzter Zeit, ich hab mal die CT gekauft und so ein paar Artikel gelesen, ein bisschen durchgeblendert. Das fand ich erstaunlich angenehm. Also kann ich mir durchaus vorstellen, dass ich das öfters mach. Auf dem iPad. Also auf dem iPhone, weil sie jetzt nicht unbedingt...
Was kostet das dann?
Weiß ich nicht. Ich muss gucken, was da so eine App kostet. Also es ist halt...
Aber so mit Background-Download würde ich sagen, dann wird das auf einmal dann doch interessant. Da hast du schon recht.
Wenn du da so ein kleines Coverbild mit drin hast und dann...
Ja vor allem so CT, da hast du auch recht. Das ist auch so... Ich will immer nicht mit diesem Schinken Papier rumlaufen. Beziehungsweise wann auch immer ich mir eine CT gekauft habe, liegt die dann im Regal und...
Oder als Klolektüre ist sie ja auch glaube ich sehr beliebt.
Ja aber ich kann ja nicht so viel Zeit auf dem Klo verbringen, wie in dieser CT Informationen drin stehen. Also ich weiß nicht, aber ich renne auch nicht mit meinem iPad aufs Klo und ich habe auch noch nicht ein iPad überall nur fürs Klo. Ich meine das wäre vielleicht eine gute Anwendung, dass man einfach so ein iPad so aufs Klo legt.
Dann kommen die Leute da nicht mehr runter, was die Tiny Wings spielen.
Ich muss mal kurz einen abseilen.
Ich fand auch witzig oder interessant, dass hier der iPhone-Typ dann auch Tiny Wings gleich mal so gefeaturet hat. Dieser Tiny Wings-Typ, der muss auch echt im Geld schwimmen.
Ja, ich glaube, der hat damit ganz gut verdient. Der hat ja auch noch einen Award abgeräumt.
Weiß nicht.
Tiny Wings haben so nicht... Nee, Cut The Rope hat einen Award abgeräumt. Tiny Wings hat ihn nicht bekommen. Ja, Reminders. Sie haben dann endlich mal auch To-Do-Items nachgerüstet. Wurde ja Zeit. Hat mich sowieso gewundert, warum sie sich da so viel Zeit mitlassen. Ich meine, das war schon immer scheiße. Schon bei iCal war das immer alles völlig unbenutzbar. Aber das existierte schon immer. Sie haben es in Mail eingebaut. Das war schon immer... Diese ganze Syncing-Infrastruktur für To-Do-Items war schon immer da, aber sie haben es auf iOS nicht genutzt. Das habe ich nicht verstanden.
Aber die Notes haben sie ja gesynkt. Aber die Notes, das war auch so.
Das ist einfach alles ein einziger Fail. Und ich meine, damit werde ich wahrscheinlich auch nicht arbeiten können. Aber es ist vielleicht ganz gut für Leute, die jetzt nicht unbedingt nochmal so eine Speise-Einkaufsliste abkaufen wollen. Was mir hier fehlt, wie bei allen anderen Programmen auch, und das ist ja dann auch, glaube ich, mein Hauptkritikpunkt an all diesen ganzen iCloud-Kram. Ich habe zwar viel gehört, jetzt wie ich meine eigenen Dokumente auf alle anderen Devices kriege, aber ich habe nichts gehört, wie ich irgendwas davon mit anderen Leuten teilen kann. Und das fehlt mir.
Kann ich mir durchaus vorstellen, dass das auch in der ersten Version gar nicht da ist. Also bei diesem ganzen iCloud-Zeug, ich habe nichts gehört von irgendwelchen Web-APIs, also dass man irgendwie per Rest-API oder so was darauf zugreifen kann, auf das ganze Zeug, weiß ich nicht. Also kann ich mir vorstellen, dass das das Thema ist, kann aber auch sein, dass es einfach ein Security-Feature ist und beim Sharing genau das gleiche. Sie verhindern, dass du versehentlich deine halbe Inbox mit der Welt teilst, indem sie einfach das Pauschal gar nicht ermöglichen.
Es gibt eine Ausnahme, das ist halt iCal. Also, MobileMe Kalender, die Applikation kann Sharing machen, zumindest innerhalb von MobileMe-Usern. Was auch schon mal so eine beklopfte Einschränkung ist, aber immerhin, das geht. Aber auch für solche To-Do-Ups wäre das eigentlich mal so ein Ding und ich verstehe auch nicht, warum das noch keiner gebracht hat. Also der Klassiker ist wirklich Einkaufslisten in der Familie. Du willst einfach notieren, Butter fehlt.
Mach ich mit Simple Note.
Und wer auch immer der nächste ist, der einkaufen geht. Ja, aber Simple Note ist ein Text-File. Da kann man zwar so obskuren List-Modus aktivieren, aber das ist not the same thing.
Das ist weit davon entfernt perfekt zu sein, aber ich hatte ja so ein bisschen darauf gehofft, dass sie so eine Infrastruktur schaffen. Also was ja so fehlt bei diesen ganzen vernetzten Apps ist ja, und das ist jetzt zur einen Hälfte da, die andere Hälfte fehlt aber noch, dieses wenn man eine iPhone-App schreibt, dann hat man im Allgemeinen noch irgendwo einen Web-Service dazu. Und um den muss man sich kümmern, da muss man eine Infrastruktur für schaffen und so was. Und Google probiert mit diesem App Engine Zeug und mit diesen diversen Services, die dir bieten, das ein bisschen zu vereinfachen, kriegen das aber glaube ich auch nur so mittelgut hin. Und dass du quasi...
Jetzt sind wir aber schon voll bei iCloud jetzt, ne?
Ja, kann ich trotzdem. Ich probier's jetzt trotzdem. Dass man sozusagen mit dem Schreiben eines Apps kriegt man in der Wolke noch mal so ein kleines Cocoa-Mini-Framework, wo dann sozusagen solange das App bei dir auf dem Gerät läuft, läuft's da oben auch irgendwie mit und man muss nicht eine komplette Server-Infrastruktur oder VM-Ware oder weißtei toll was aufsetzen, nur um da diesen einfachen Web-Server am Laufen zu halten. Sondern dass Apple diesen Teil mitliefert. Das vermisse ich ja noch so ein bisschen.
Gut, bleiben wir nochmal bei iOS hier. Twitter.
Tja, was haben sie da wohl gezahlt? Also wer hat da wohl wem was gezahlt? Hat da überhaupt jemand was gezahlt?
Also was ist ein lustiges Twitter?
Twitter ist das natürlich Deluxe. Ja, also ich denke da können sie sich nur darüber freuen.
Kennt ihr dieses, ihr kennt auch bestimmt dieses obskure, ich glaube vorn vietnamesisches Video, was irgendwie vor ein paar Monaten aufgetaucht ist, wo jemand ein weißes iPhone gefilmt hatte mit einer iOS 4 Version drauf, die so einen ganz merkwürdigen App-Switcher hatte.
Ja, so Exposé Style.
Genau, so Exposé Style, wo sich alle gefragt haben woher ist das und dann irgendjemand gesagt hat nein, wird es wahrscheinlich eine iOS 4 Beta gewesen sein, die niemals in Produktion gegangen ist, weil es gab keinen entsprechenden Zydiastore-App, was das so konnte und so was und irgendwie sah es aber schon sehr aus, als ob das sich um das echte Gerät handeln würde und nicht irgendein Fake. Und da ist jetzt jemand aufgefallen, dass in den Einstellungen von diesem iOS 4 ist genau an der Stellung, wobei iOS 5 der Twitter- Settings-Button ist, ist bei iOS 4 ein Facebook Settings-Button. an derselben Punkt in der Menüsstruktur. Mit anderen Worten, die hatten schon mal Facebook drinnen und sie hätten auch bei iOS 4 ausliefern können, das mit Facebook. Und haben es dann nicht gemacht, aus welchen Gründen auch immer.
Ja, da ist irgendwie...
Zuckerberg!
Ich hab so den Eindruck, dass dieser Zuckerberg irgendwas Falsches gesagt hat.
Wir wollen auch 13-jährige Kinder abzocken.
Nee, da hat irgendwas gesagt, was Steve überhaupt nicht gefallen hat.
Hey, du hast aber abgenommen!
Ja, ich hab keine Ahnung. Auf jeden Fall, das passt natürlich da ganz gut rein. Also was ist jetzt mit diesem Twitter? Wir müssen mal sagen, was ist das eigentlich? Das ist irgendwie, also sie haben, seht ihr das richtig? Du stellst an einer Stelle in den Settings ein, dein Twitter-Account. Und damit haben, dann können dann alle Programme quasi diese Twitter-Authentication automatisch übernehmen. Ist das das, was sie eingebaut haben? Seht ihr das richtig? Das ist jetzt nicht nur so, dass sie so ein Twitter-Post-to-Twitter-Feature in ein paar Programme eingebaut haben, sondern das ganze Device. Du gibst einmal deinen Account ein und damit kannst du theoretisch jedes Programm auf deinem Mac mit Twitter authentifizieren, wenn du vielleicht noch einmal Ja sagst.
Ohne dass deine Programme alle deinen Account haben.
Weil es ist ja sonst so, dass die jetzt alle in diesen Webview gehen müssen und dann musst du dich dann für das Programm bei Twitter anmelden und so, dieser ganze Fu, was jetzt kommt.
Twitter steigt ja gerade um auf dieses neue Authentifizierungsmodell. Und zwar dieses Zweistufige, dass du einmal, wenn nun, also OOs wollen sie ja sowieso machen, also dieses, dass du in den Webview musst, wo dann sagt, da will jemand auf deine Daten zugreifen, willst du es zulassen. Und damit die Programme auf Direct Messages zugreifen können, ich weiß jetzt nicht, ob lesend oder schreibend oder beides, ich glaube, beides war der Sinn der Sache, musst du dich nochmal zusätzlich authentifizieren. Und nach allem, was ich bisher verstanden habe, ist das so, dass sozusagen die Minimum-Funktion auf deine Timeline zugreifen und Tweets in deinem Namen posten, kann sozusagen jeder. Aber OOs für Direct Messages müssen sie noch separat machen. Ich weiß aber nicht, ob sie dafür nochmal nach einem Passwort fragen müssen, oder ob es reicht, wenn dann irgendwie so ein Dialog aufgeht, wo dann so Twitter fragt, willst du das erlauben und du sagst ja, und alles ist gut. Also ich würde es ja cool finden, wenn man nicht jedes Mal sein scheiß Passwort da eingeben muss. Für jeden Client, der man... Du bist gerade in der U-Bahn, willst irgendwie mal einen neuen Twitter Client ausprobieren? Wie war mal gleich mein Twitter Passwort? Schon wieder ein Tipp.
Das wäre in der Tat interessant, ob ihr die ganzen Third-Party-Twitter Clients dann auch dieser Twitter iOS API benutzen könnt, zum Authentifizieren, ja.
Ich glaub schon, soweit ich das verstanden habe.
Ja, sehr schön ist ja die Sache, haben wir gesagt, Änderung in der Kamera ab. Darauf hab ich ja echt schon dieser Shutter-Button gewartet. Also erstens, dass du halt nicht dich komplett in dein scheiß Telefon einloggen musst, deine Kamera-Applikation aus dem Dashboard da raussuchen musst und starten musst und dann noch mal 30 Sekunden warten musst, bis das Teil dann endlich mal die Kamera geöffnet hat und dann musst du dann auch noch auf dem Bildschirm irgendwo hin tippen, um ein Foto zu machen. Das hab ich noch nie verstanden. Und sie haben jetzt irgendwie beide Probleme auf einmal gelöst, indem sie halt jetzt die Möglichkeit haben, dann von einem gelockten Phone direkt in die Kamera abzugehen. Und dann kannst du da halt auch noch mit der, was ist das? Plus-Taste?
Lauter-Taste.
Genau, kannst du dann irgendwie ein Bild auslösen. Und das macht einfach mal total Sinn.
Was ich im Detail, was ich da ganz hübsch finde, ist, man kann wohl auch in den Fotomodes, also wenn man Pinlock drauf hat, dann kann man auch ein Foto machen, ohne vorher seinen Pin-Code einzugeben.
Genau, dann kannst du nicht die anderen Fotos sehen, sondern nur das, was du gerade gemacht hast.
Genau.
Ja, das ist wirklich klug gelöst.
Das ist voll super.
Daumen hoch.
Ja, zeitwürdig. Alle voll dafür.
Wir sind dafür. Und dann kannst du irgendwie hier auch noch cropping und Zooming.
Achso, und habt ihr auch gehört, die meinen, dass du dann hier das Gesicht z.B. antippst, dass du da seinen Fokus halten sollst, du bewegst die Kamera, dann bleibt der Fokus beim Gesicht.
Ja, sie haben jetzt so diese ganze Face Recognition in Echtzeit, ne?
Core Image ist drin jetzt bestimmt.
Und ich glaube, du kannst auch irgendwie Exposure und Fokus separat setzen. Mit zwei Tabs oder so.
Ich hab keine Ahnung. Also du kannst Pinch to Zoom, das spricht jetzt so ein bisschen gegen mit zwei Tabs oder äh...
Das ist ja nachdem du es gemacht hast.
Nee, nee, Pinch to Zoom.
Vorher die Zoom-Funktion fürs Foto.
Wenn du auf das Gesicht tappst, dann versuchst du halt, dass die Belichtung sozusagen auf das Gesicht zu matchen, also dass das gut belichtet ist. Und dann ist halt, ob du die Kamera bewegst oder nicht, der Hintergrund... Also das Gesicht behält die Priorität bei der Belichtung und beim Fokus.
Einfache Bildbearbeitungsfunktion. Drehen und Crop, das finde ich echt...
Ja, rote Augen.
Rote Zeit.
Das ist alles ganz sinnvoll, dass sie das einbauen.
Erstaunlich, dass es solche Fotos für Apple-Demos gibt.
Ja, furchtbar.
Man muss aber auch sehen, es ist ein authentisches Blitz über blitzes Foto. Obwohl, das Auto-Enhance, das sieht schon echt... Das sieht vorher und nachher scheiße aus.
Ja, würde ich auch sagen. Sieht in beiden total milchig aus. Na ja, okay, du hast hier so diesen Grauschleier raus und die Farben sind etwas besser.
Das sind wenigstens ehrliche Aufnahmen.
Neuer Mut zur Ehrlichkeit bei Apple.
Tabs in Safari. Also auf dem iPad zumindest.
Also das Reader-Feature finde ich ja cool.
Das war auch überfällig, dass sie das eingebaut haben. Und naja, Tabs.
Da ist ja schon noch ein bisschen Platz.
Ja, auch das macht schon Sinn.
Ja, denke auch.
Also vorher dieses da oben auf dieses Fensterding, da poppt dieses Fenster auf, da musstest du das richtige Fenster auswählen.
Aber immerhin konntest du sehen, wohin du gehst. Und jetzt hast du diesen komischen Tabs wieder mit so nicht-sagenden Seitentiteln.
Bei WebOS ist es so, wo du dann diese Karten einfach so durchslidest, fand ich eigentlich auch ganz hübsch.
Also was ich bei... Ich fand ja auch immer... Ich find ja diesen App-Switcher bei WebOS auch prinzipiell toll, was daran aber doof ist. Und das war bisher bei der Lösung von Safari auch. Du brauchst im Endeffekt drei Tabs, und zwei Bildschirmewechsel, um eine Aktion zu machen. Du willst einen Tab wechseln? Du musst in diesen App-Switcher-Modus gehen, musst die Geste dafür machen, musst dann zu deinem App-Switchen oder zu deinem Tab-Switchen zu dem darüber willst, und musst dann nochmal sagen, ja, bestätigen. Und jetzt ist so ein Tab, du bist da.
Ja, aber was ist, wenn du irgendwie neun Tabs hast? Dann hast du wieder so...
Dann hast du neun Tabs, dann musst du jetzt auch notenimmt.
Gibt's da deine Geste zum Durchswitchen?
Keine Ahnung. Ich glaub nicht. Was ich gelesen habe, was Safari jetzt kann, das wird jedem, der ein bisschen mit HTML zu tun hat, Position Fixed. Du kannst ein Element auf einer Seite endlich fest positionieren. Das ist, ich weiß nicht, warum sie da bis jetzt...
Und Overflow haben sie auch hingebaut irgendwie.
Das ist doch CSS 1, oder?
Das ist, ja, das ist ganz, ganz alt, das CSS.
Das ging bisher nicht.
Und Overflow konnten sie auch irgendwie nicht so richtig...
Genau, dass sie jetzt irgendwie das Scrollen innerhalb von Views dann ein bisschen besser hinkriegen, wohl nicht perfekt, aber ein bisschen besser.
Ich bin ein alter Meckara, sagt der Chat. Naja, recht habt ihr.
Deswegen hören sie doch diese Sendung.
Ja.
Wenn's nicht so viel ist.
Kommen wir zu den wirklich überzeugenden Features. Cut the cord, PC free. Ihr händet euch, das war meine erste Kritik am iPad, die ich irgendwie nicht verstanden habe, warum man noch so einen Computer braucht, um dann endlich einen Computer zu kaufen, der kein Computer mehr ist.
Jetzt sind sie so weit.
Ja, sie brauchten noch.
Sie hören diesen Podcast.
Sie brauchten noch diese Cloud. Naja, ich glaub, das wussten sie auch irgendwie schon selber. Und ehrlich gesagt, mir war es ein Rätsel, wie sie überhaupt so viele iPads haben verkaufen können. Also wenn ich mich überhaupt über irgendwas gewundert habe, ist, wie sie diesen Shitload von iPads verkauft haben, obwohl sie voraussetzen, dass die Leute schon einen Computer haben.
Weil sie richten sich da, glaube ich, im Zweifelsfall auch einen Shop ein.
Ja stimmt, ich glaube, es gab auch noch die Option, dass du im Shop sagen kannst, das hier macht mir mal fit gleich. Aber trotzdem muss ja für OS-Updates und sonst was wieder an den Rechner ran.
Ja, Syncing und Musik und also einfach alles, was du tust.
Aber ich sag so, ich komm nach Hause, pack meine Jacke mit meinem iPhone drin, häng das irgendwie in die Garderobe und geh schlafen und während ich schlafe, macht der Backup, Syncing, Tralala und Shit, ja? Ja, wenn ich nicht schlafe, dann sitz ich ja da und spiel Geodefense, dann macht das ja eh.
Irgendwie sind jetzt so Zahlen kursiert, dass 50% aller beim Apple Store aufschlagenden iPhones mit irgendwelchen Defekten noch nie gebackupt worden sind.
Nie eine iTunes gesehen haben, ja.
Naja, eine iTunes zum Aktivieren, aber danach nicht mehr. Und so, das ist ja, muss man ja sagen, man hat's ein bisschen vergessen, aber das ist ja eines der geilsten Features an diesem iPhone, dass du endlich, du kaufst dir ein neues Telefon, dein altes Telefon wird dir geklaut, es kommt weg, es geht kaputt, du schließt es an und du hast wieder da, wo du es verlassen hast. Und dass 50% der iPhone-Anwender das nicht haben.
Aber die, die...
Andersrum geht's nicht.
Vielleicht haben die halt auch einfach keinen Computer.
Nö, das sind auch Leute, das sind ein guter Kumpel von mir, den kenn ich. Der ist eine Formatiker, der kann programmieren, der macht iPhone-Development, der kommt nicht mal auf die Idee, dass er erinnert, wie er mal von seinem iPhone Backup machen könnte.
Aber vielleicht... Also ich lade ja mein iPhone schon über meinen Rechner öfter mal und dabei wird er automatisch gebackupt. Wie laden die denn ihr Rechner oder ihr iPhone denn?
Am Ladegerät.
Und warum nicht am Rechner, wenn sie einen haben?
Na, wenn sie keinen haben.
Die haben ja einen. Ein Informatiker ist was, nicht?
Ja, gut, der Informatiker, was weiß ich. Informatiker sind sowieso komisch.
Aber ich hatte letztens nur total einen Fuck-Up mal wieder. Habe ich hier einen neuen Rechner? Stecke ich mein Phone ran? Und dann sagt er, ja, hier im Moment, also hier sind Sachen auf dem Phone, die sind aber noch nicht auf dem Rechner. Sag ich, ja, mach rüber, Alter. Und was macht der? Der löscht auf dem Phone alle Apps mit den Daten und spielt sie dann wieder rauf in einer total obskuren Reihenfolge ohne die Daten.
Warst du vorher dann Apple ID bei deinem Laptop ID? Die Sau.
Und ich saß so da und dachte mir...
What the Facebook?
What the Zuckerberg? Da wäre ich echt aus allen Wolken gefallen.
Da wirst du gleich aus der iCloud gefallen.
Es ist halt alles völlig durcheinander und es war so dermaßen überfällig, dass sie das mal komplett anders machen.
Hoffentlich kriegen sie es damit.
Aber mal ehrlich, diese App Store ist eh schon ein bisschen komisch. Ich weiß nicht, was ich mit meinem iPhone gemacht habe, aber auf einmal meint er, da sind Updates für Programme da, so irgendwie neun Stück oder so. Und ich hatte erst so eine Stunde vorher da irgendwie rumgeklickt, und auf einmal meint er, da sind neun Updates da. Und guck ich so, dann sind das alles Updates von Programmen, die ich mal gelöscht habe. Es ist der Moment, wo sie umgestellt haben, dass man jetzt hier auch... Also sie haben noch hier was geändert. Kurz nach der WWDC haben sie doch hier das geändert, dass der jetzt, wie sieht das genau aus?
Bereits gekaufte Sachen schon nochmal runterladen kann.
Genau, da haben sie bestimmt irgendwie ihren State auf dem Server resettet oder was auch immer. Und da hat er mir einfach alles gelöschte wieder als Update angeboten.
Also auch...
Genau, die gekauften Artikel sind doch jetzt oben neu. Und genau, ich glaube, als das kam, hat er mir all den gelöschten Shit nochmal reingehauen.
Ja, sowieso ganz merkwürdige Probleme. Ich hatte auf dem iPad im Store, hatte mir die CSS-Dateien plötzlich nicht mitgeladen. Offensichtlich ist das ein reiner Webview. Und dann hatte ich da so unformatiertes HTML als iTunes. Und das hat er dann irgendwie gecashed und ich hab's auch nicht mehr wegbekommen. Das war...
Also, das Apple, auch hier muss man feststellen, ja. Nein, aber irgendwie...
Worauf können sie ja klaut?
Worauf ich ja sehr gespannt bin, wenn du ein iPhone aus der Wolke rekonstruierst, ob man da sein WLAN-Passwort eingeben muss. Ich kann mir ja vorstellen, dass die das... Also, wenn ich Apple wäre, so perfektionistisch wie immer drauf sind, würde ich ja sagen, du hast ein neues iPhone, du legst da deine SIM-Karte rein, dann holt er sich erstmal, nachdem du deine Apple-ID eingegeben hast, holt er sich als Allererstes die WLAN-Daten, holt die sich noch über 3G, übrigens Max steht gerade, während er darüber referiert. holt er sich über 3G, macht dann eine WLAN-Verbindung und spielt dann das Backup ein, damit du nicht mal die Notwendigkeit hast, dein WLAN-Passwort ein einzugeben. Ich hoffe, Apple hat das hingekriegt. Kann das mal bitte jemand prüfen? Ich hab keinen Bock, extra mein Telefon deswegen zu löschen. Hab's nicht gelöscht, hab's kaputt gemacht.
Nee, ich hab's schon löscht.
Interessanter Punkt. Ups, wir sind hier die Tür offen.
Ich dachte, du hättest die abflüssiglich aufgelassen, damit hier ein bisschen frische Luft reinkommt.
Nee, ich dachte, Tim ist vorhin draußen gewesen. Der Hausmeister kam gerade rein.
Hat sich eine Mate genommen.
Hast du auch die Katzen rausgeschmissen, die da schon vorher...
Den Müll durchstöberten.
Finally.
Gibt's eigentlich mal wieder coole Werbevideos von Apple? So mit Mac und PC ist ja vorbei. Vorher gab's ja auch immer mal irgendwie interessante, schicke Sachen. Aber jetzt gehen ja da einen voll auf...
Consumer-Kuschel-Videos, ne?
Großeltern wollen ja ihr Enkel sehen.
Auf jeden Fall. PC Free heißt halt auch, dass du jetzt auf einmal Dinge tun kannst, die du vorher nicht machen konntest. Du kannst ja jetzt auch Kalendare......annehmen?...herstellen und löschen und so. Also das iPad wird erwachsen mit dieser Änderung. Das ist schon nennenswert. Ja, naja gut, bisschen Mail überarbeitet, Piepapoo. Ja, was brauch ich eine Jahresansicht?
Na für die Schulferien, Mann.
Ja gut, ich sag jetzt nicht, dass das jetzt... Also ich hab nichts gegen die Jahresansicht, aber ich will einfach eine Mehrwochenansicht anstatt einer Monatsansicht.
Kommt schon irgendwann, eines Tages.
Da warte ich ja schon seit Ewigkeiten drauf.
Das ist ja hier irgendwie Resize from all Edges, hat auch wieder 10 Jahre gedauert.
Ja, mein Gott, ob ich das noch alles erleben werde.
Wi-Fi-Sync.
Wi-Fi-Sync, ich meine, wie lange haben wir darauf gewartet?
Lange.
Lange, und jetzt ist es da, es ist so ein Greifen da.
Noch ist es nicht draußen.
Meinst du, du schmeißt es immer raus?
So wie mit Zetterfest.
Na ja, ich meine.
Guck mal, aber nur, wenn man es an ein Power-Device ranmacht. Verdammt, dass ich nicht mein iPhone in meiner Jacke lasse und es an die Tür hänge. So ein Scheiß.
Weiß ich ja, habt ihr das mitbekommen, diesen kleinen Aufstand, den da...
Warte mal, das heißt jetzt, dass sie jetzt Wi-Fi-Sync in dem Moment... Dennis. Das ist ein teurer Kopfhörer.
Dennis schüttelt seinen Haupthaar und wirft den Kopfhörer auf den Boden dabei.
Die Metaebene wird hier zerstört. Also sie bauen Wi-Fi-Sync mit iTunes ein in dem Moment, wo man mit iTunes nicht mehr syncen muss. Aber es heißt ja wohl nicht, dass sie auch nur mit iCloud nur syncen, wenn ich es an Power-Adapter anschließe.
Doch, bestimmt, weil es kostet dann zu viel Strom.
Können wir nochmal gucken, was da steht, aber...
Was soll denn das?
Das wäre natürlich ein schöner Fnord.
Aber dieser englische Entwickler, der irgendwann mal vor zwei Jahren Wi-Fi Sync beim App Store eingereicht hat und jetzt sich darüber beschwert, die haben das damals rejected und haben meine Idee geklaut und jetzt nennen sie es auch Wi-Fi Sync und haben mir das Icon geklaut und so.
Ich dachte so...
Der soll mal scheißen gehen.
Was bist du denn für ein Horst? Wi-Fi Sync ist ja total naheliegend. Der verwechselt, sie haben mich beklaut mit. Ich hab einfach den absolut naheliegendsten Gedanken gehabt, wie jeder so einen Feature nennen würde und wie jeder so einen Icon machen würde und wie sich das jeder seit Jahren gewünscht hat. Du hast nicht die Idee gehabt, du hast die wahrscheinlich scheiße umgesetzt.
Ja, das hätte ich absurde Diskussionen.
Aber sag mal hier, wenn man doch jetzt, angenommen ich lade jetzt hier irgendwie die TomTom-App rund auf meinem iPhone, ja, hier bei dir in deinem Netz und komm dann nach Hause und mach dann hier mein Syncing oder wie machst du an Strommann und der Synkt, dann guckt jeder doch tatsächlich von meinem iPhone über WLAN die App nochmal komplett auf meinen Rechner rüber, ne?
Macht er das tatsächlich so oder lädt er die einfach aus dem Studio?
Aber warum muss er eigentlich von meinem App ein Backup auf meinem Rechner anlegen, wenn er das doch eh, wenn ich das mal verlieren sollte, das irgendwie holen könnte von Apfel, so wie sie es mit der Musik jetzt auch machen, weil eigentlich haben die doch alles da.
Ich glaube, wenn du das nicht willst.
Keine Ahnung, wie das dann bei iTunes 10.5 sein wird oder iTunes 11 oder iTunes was weiß ich. Also kann ja durchaus sein, dass sie auch sowas machen. Aber derzeit ist halt die Methode noch, dass er eben die Ups dann da hinholt, weil das iTunes ist halt dein Hub.
Ja, schlimm, schlimm.
Und diese ganze iTunes in the Cloud-Kram und so, das dauert ja offensichtlich eh noch eine Weile, bis das nach Europa kommt. Ja, bitte nicht über Gesten reden, aber was ich ja total groß an dich finde, ist ja dieses Airplay-Mirroring, aber das ist nur für iPad 2. Hab ich irgendwas verpasst? Warum?
Weil auch, das haben die doch nur erfunden, damit sie dann irgendwie dieses Gerät bei so einer Keynote nicht mehr anschließen müssen.
Das ist super.
Das ist großartig.
Das will man einfach haben, dass das iPad einfach immer alles per Airplay irgendwo draufsinkt. Könnte man hier auch wunderbar für den Beamer verwenden, hätte ich auch ganz gerne mal für meinen Mac.
Also für mobile Präsentationen irgendwo unterwegs, bisher mit diesem doofen Kabel, das hat ja genervt ohne Ende. Jetzt nimmst du da so ein kleines Apple-TV mit.
Genau, jetzt kannst du nämlich ein Apple-TV mitnehmen, einfach einen Beamer anstöpseln und...
Fertig.
Dann musst du dir aber noch einen W-Lan klicken.
Also richtig cool wird es wirklich, wenn die ersten Beamer mit Airplay kommen. Oder ist das so ein W? Beamer mit Airplay.
Fernseher mit Airplay, ja, so ein Zeug.
Na, mit Airplay wird bestimmt auch nicht mehr so lange auf sich warten lassen.
Was ich ja hoffe, also ich meine, was das ja ist, dieses Airplay-Mirroring, das ist ja auch die Sachen, die bisher über das VR-Kabel liefen nur, die laufen jetzt auch über Airplay. Das heißt Keynote kann da auch eine Präsentation drauf zeigen und so dieses ganze Zeug. Ich hoffe ja mal, dass sie das irgendwie auch in Lion einbauen, dieses Interface. Ich hätte das so gerne, erkennt ihr dieses Airdisplay, wo man so das iPad als externen Monitor nehmen kann? Das hätte ich gerne für meinen Fernseher. Dass ich meinen Fernseher da hinten als externen Monitor für meinen Mac nehmen kann. Dass wenn ich im Wohnzimmer sitze, ich da hinten irgendwie nebenbei einen Film gucken kann oder irgendwie so ein Scheiß und mir keine Sorgen, das hätte ich gerne. Hoffentlich baut das jemand ein oder Hektas. Erika Zardun, die ist auch da bestimmt schon dran. Die hat auch da bestimmt bald was.
So, wir sind durch.
Jetzt kommt noch die iCloud.
Die hatten wir doch die ganze Zeit schon.
Es gibt noch so ein paar Sachen, die sie auch gezeigt haben. Zum Beispiel diese Geschichte mit dem Split Keyboard auf dem iPad. Das fand ich auch ganz pfiffig. Dass du jetzt so eine Daumentastatur links und rechts haben kannst und die dann auch so in dem Mitte des Bildschirms drägen kannst. Drägen.
Aber ja auch schon, wenn du es so hältst, dass du dann nicht ordentlich cool tippen kannst.
Muss man ja wirklich mal sagen, da haben wir ja einige aus diesem Windows, aus dem Microsoft, das haben sie ja bei uns geklaut und das hat der UMPC wirklich schon vor ein paar Jahren gehabt.
Und für so einen Vibrator-Fan wie mich, das stand so ganz verborgen auf so einem Slide, Custom Vibration Patterns.
Kannst du so ein Video gesehen, kannst du so eintippen. Du kannst wirklich sagen, du tippst dem das vor und dann ist das abdrehen.
Weil jetzt ist es ja glaube ich so, wenn du bei Spielen oder so, so Force-Feedback-mäßig, das ist immer eine festgelegte Zeit, wie lange das vibriert und du kannst nur sagen, vibriere immer und dann machst du einfach nur das.
Ich glaube es ging immer nur eine halbe Sekunde lang und ging nicht weiter.
Für Spiele war das halt nicht so cool dann dementsprechend.
Das ist eine alternative System-Notification, wenn ich mich recht erinnere.
Werde ich mit vor allem zwischen Telefonanrufen und incoming SMS und sonstigen Push-Zeug unterscheiden? Weil ich hab mein Telefon fast immer im Vibrationsmodus, ich hab eigentlich selten das Ding klingeln lassen.
Anrufe sind die, die öfters mal kommen, wo dann sofort das nächste noch kommt.
So haben die bei Nokia die haben es am coolsten gemacht. Das SMS als Morse-Zeichen über den Vibrations-Dings. Obwohl die es ja als Ton hatten, aber...
Du hättest gern die SMS gemorst? Das wäre natürlich auch geil.
Naja, dreimal Dank.
Nokia, ich hab heute einen Vortrag gesehen von so einer Nokiatorte. Der Laden ist ja wirklich noch gefährdeter, als mehr es jemals beklag war.
Nein, geht natürlich voll gut. Apple hat dick Geld dagelassen.
So einen Quatsch hat die geredet, so einen Blödsinn. Wenn die bei Apple gearbeitet hätte, die wäre nach dem Vortrag sofort gefeuert worden.
Während?
Ja, des Vortrags. Wie bei den Comics, so ein Stock von hinten, von der Bühne.
Das Telefon hätte geklingelt, sie wäre rangegangen. Steve, ja was denn?
Die war irgendwie zuständig für die Crowdsourcing-Abteilung bei Nokia. Faselte irgendwie eine Stunde, irgendwas von Open Innovation und völliges Blablub präsentierte auf einem Windows XP Laptop mit Powerpoint und den entsprechenden Slides. Redete die ganze Zeit wirklich nur Quatsch. Keinerlei Inhalt, nichts. Und da hab ich wieder gemerkt, da gibt es echt noch Leute, die träumen, die träumen davon, dass Nokia noch irgendwas reißen würde, aber die reißen nichts mehr.
Nix.
Geil fand ich dann das Detail, als sie dann irgendwie sagt, ja, dann haben wir ja auch noch so eine Applikation, irgendwie für unser Crowdsourcing und so weiter. Das läuft auch auf dem iPhone. iPhone hat sie dann als erstes genannt. Läuft auf iPhone, Android und auch auf unserem Betriebssystem. Danke, dachte ich mir.
Aber ich find, also zu diesen Gesten nochmal, ich fand's schon doof, dass es nur auf dem iPad gibt. Also, das muss ich nochmal sagen, falls die wirklich zuhört, macht das mal auf dem iPhone irgendwie auch nochmal klar. Ich will nicht immer diese...
Achso, zwischen Apps denn und Tearschalten?
Ich will irgendwie Schnack, Schnack, Schnack. Ich will nicht immer Doppelklick, Swish, Swash.
Und so ist das, ja? Das gibt's nur auf dem iPad.
Das stand im Falle, dass du auf der Seite.
Nach vier Finger swipen, um Apps zu switchen. Find ich total geil. Ich würde viel mehr Apps switchen, wenn's das gäbe.
Naja, iCloud. Habt ihr das Gefühl, dass ihr schon verstanden habt, was es wirklich ist?
Ich hab das Gefühl, dass wir gar nicht wissen müssen, was es wirklich ist.
Das wurde bei mir auch gesagt.
Also ich fände ja schon mal, irgendwie no conflicts und so, haben sie ja irgendwie gleich mal vorneweg gesagt und irgendwie, dass das, was in der Cloud ist, Recht hat, oder irgendwie so war das auch mal. The truth is in the Cloud.
Mit anderen Worten, wir überschreiben deine Eingaben ohne zu fragen.
Ja, genau, also was genau das bedeutet, hätte ich schon gerne auch nochmal erläutert bekommen.
Ich hoffe, dass sie nicht von derselben Wahrheit reden, die sie bei MobileMe implementiert haben. Weil wenn das immer die Wahrheit gewesen ist, dann gute Nacht.
Ja, wir haben ja genug User, die das vor uns testen. Und dann, wenn man sieht, nach ein, zwei Monaten, die sind alle nur, find's voll toll und flutscht und ist geil, dann benutzt man's halt auch.
Also so was ich bisher von iCloud gesehen habe, finde ich ganz großartig. Ich finde dieses Backup in der Wolke, finde ich.
Ja, aber was ist iCloud? Wie würdet ihr das definieren?
Eine Sammlung von Web-Services.
Aber da sind überhaupt gar keine Web...
Naja, das ist HTTP.
Haben sie das gesagt?
Nee, haben sie nicht gesagt, vermute ich jetzt einfach mal. Äh, gesagt haben sie in der Richtung, glaube ich, gar nichts. War ja auch, ähm...
Also HTTP ist ja eigentlich auch ein ganz schön anstrengendes Protokoll, wenn man da ein bisschen mehr machen will als Webseiten anzeigen, ne?
Ich glaube, das braucht dich als Entwickler auch nicht großartig zu interessieren. Du kriegst einfach eine API-Folge gegeben, wo du sagst, hier schmeißt du eine Datei rein und kümmere dich darum, dass die jetzt mal weg ist und dass die auf dem iPad auch drauf ist oder auf was auch immer der User da hat und dann passiert das halt so.
Du redest nicht Web. Es mag über HTTP implementiert sein, aber du siehst davon nichts. Das ist Teil des OS.
Genau, das auf jeden Fall.
Und deswegen ist es auch kostenlos.
Ja, wobei es gibt ja wohl Hinweise darauf, dass man, wenn man zum Beispiel mehr Backup-Space haben will, dass man dafür anzahlen muss und so was. Aber so die Basis ist alles kostenlos.
Am interessantesten fand ich eigentlich das, worüber sie nicht geredet haben bei iCloud. Also sie haben einfach so ein paar Dinge, ein paar Worte sind einfach überhaupt nicht gefallen. Also erstmal Web-Interfaces. Zu keinem Zeitpunkt war in irgendeiner Form davon die Rede, dass es für irgendetwas in dieser iCloud ein Web-Frontend gibt.
Ich glaube, weil es das einfach nicht geben wird.
Das heißt, bei MobileMe, schalten sie diese ganzen Web-Sachen ab. Kein Kalender mehr im Web, kein Foto mehr im Web, kein Find-My-iPhone mehr im Web.
Find-My-iPhone auf jeden Fall.
Find-My-iPhone, ja. Weil du das ja auch offensichtlich ohne iPhone bedienen können musst.
Eben.
Aber bei den anderen Sachen, ich glaube Kalender und Mail und sowas, das ist einfach vorbei.
Ich glaube, das bleibt.
Na, mobile me in der Form, wie es heute ist, läuft jetzt noch ein Jahr. Gut, wie auch immer. Wir haben dazu kein Wort verloren. Ein zweites Wort, was nicht auftauchte zu keinem Zeitpunkt ist iDisc.
Ja, weil das Datalsystem vorbei ist.
Naja, heißt das, dass es auch kein iDisc mehr geben wird?
Das ist da zumindest nicht erwähnt. Ich glaube, Sie hätten es gesagt, wenn es das noch geben würde.
Werden eigentlich Bookmarks gesüngt?
Aber das wird schon bei mobile me.
Naja, gesagt haben Sie das nicht. Also er hat gesagt, unsere mobile me Anwendung haben wir neu geschrieben für iCloud. Das klingt schon, muss es nicht unbedingt heißen, aber das klingt schon oder könnte bedeuten, dass tatsächlich die Implementierung, wie Sie diese Dienste realisieren, ganz anders ist. Und ich frage mich so ein bisschen, was ist denn jetzt eigentlich das Native Environment von iCloud? Wenn ich jetzt eine Anwendung in iCloud mache, sprache ich explizit von iCloud Apps.
Na, die das nutzen, nicht die da laufen.
iCloud Apps sind die, die diese native Cocoa-P, die auch immer sie aussehen.
Nein, nein, in, in der Cloud.
In der Cloud?
Ja, er sprach davon, dass die Mobile-Me-Sachen iCloud Apps werden und jetzt in iCloud laufen. So wie du gerade von App Engine geredet hast. Hat es nicht weiter vertieft und hat es auch nicht weiter erklärt, aber es ist ja ganz klar, es muss ja einen Server geben.
Ja.
Ja, wenn du Keychain Syncing machst, dann muss da irgendwas sein, was die Keychains synkt. Wenn du Kalender speichert, dann gibt es da einen CalDAF-Server, der in irgendeiner Form in dieser iCloud residiert.
Also was sie erwähnt haben, ist Key......Adressbook Syncing, etc.
Also das muss da alles sein. Und das muss in irgendwas geschrieben sein.
Na, was sie erwähnt haben ist, ich glaube nicht, ich glaube nicht, dass du, dass man als Endanwender irgendwie oder als Entwickler, als iOS-Entwickler, da irgendwie Apps in der iCloud schreiben können wird. Ich glaube nicht, dass das der Fall ist. Sie haben gesagt, es gibt Key-Value-Storage. Und ich glaube, das war das Einzige, was sie zu dem Thema gesagt haben.
Key-Value-Storage war konkret Teil von dem Documents-Kram.
War das von dem Documents-Kram Teil oder war das generell von iCloud?
Das war bei Documents, das habe ich mir explizit notiert. Also er sprach erstmal davon. Core, Mobile, Micram werden iCloud Apps. Adres Book, Kalender, Mail. Und dass das jetzt nichts mehr kostet. Dann gibt es neue iCloud Apps. Neue iCloud Apps sind App Store.
Hatte das wirklich so gesagt?
iCloud Apps. iBooks, Backup. Backup ist sozusagen auch eine App. Und vielleicht ist das, verstehst du, ich versuche gerade so darüber nachzudenken, dass iCloud quasi so eine Art OS in der Wolke ist. Und mich würde es noch nicht mal groß wundern, wenn du am Ende in iCloud genauso programmierst wie in iOS. Bloß ohne GUI.
Also ich glaube nicht, dass es jemals, dass da ein User ein Webinterface für vorgesehen ist. Sondern du bedienst...
Also kein Webinterface, ein App.
Also ich, einfach jetzt mal, um sicher auszuschließen, was ich schon mal auf jeden Fall glaube. Dann dieses, also du meinst, dass man sozusagen, dass man Coco-Apps entwickelt und die laufen dann auf den Servern von Apple.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich das meine. Ich sag nur, dass ist das, was mir so durch den Kopf geht. Ob das vielleicht der Weg ist, wo sie hinwollen.
Ich fänd's toll, wenn das ginge. Weil ich glaube, dass das echt eine Menge Probleme lösen würde.
Ja, es wäre zum Beispiel auch für andere iOS-Plattformen, die kein GUI haben. Apple TV zum Beispiel.
Apple TV hat ein GUI, aber Time Capsule.
Kann man so sagen, ja. Aber auf jeden Fall auch was anderes.
Im Gegenteil, ich könnte mir sogar vorstellen, dass Apple TV nur das GUI ist für das Headless-App, was irgendwo bei Apple in der Cloud läuft. Dass du hast irgendwie ein kleines, ressourcenschonendes App, was auf dem Apple TV läuft. Mir fällt gerade auf, dann hätten sie ja so dieses SYN-Client-Sun-Dingsbums verwirklicht.
Ich glaube da nicht so richtig, dass da welche Apps laufen. Ich glaube, diese iCloud ist einfach Remote Storage und die Programme, die iCloud benutzen, kriegen halt dieses was war das Key-Value-API, das so halt irgendwie, wenn ich jetzt ein Programm schreibe und ich will zum Beispiel da irgendwas, was der User als Content bei mir reinkippt, was nicht so viel ist.
Selbstverständlich laufende Applikationen.
Ja, aber nicht welche, die der Developer schreibt. Habe ich nicht gesagt. Das ist doch total schnuppe.
Naja, solange bis sich das dann ändert. Ich meine, warum sollte sich nicht... Beim ersten iPhone gab es auch Apps auf dem iPhone und der Developer konnte keine schreiben. Und der nächste Schritt war, du konntest auch schreiben. Was ist, wenn iCloud jetzt erst mal die geschlossene Apple-Wolke ist, in der die Apple-Applikationen laufen und im nächsten Schritt kann halt auch der Developer in die Cloud?
Kann schon sein.
Damit du da dein eigenes Syncing machen kannst.
Und ich meine, so wie Google sagt...
Aber wenn die ja so wichtig die Value machen, dann aus oder nicht mehr so viel?
Aber ich dachte, das hat er auch eh schon gesagt, dass es halt Party up sozusagen, die iCloud zum Synken benutzen können.
Naja, das ist ja das eine, aber ich schätze...
Synken im Sinne von, dass du da Daten ablegst. Das ist aber was ganz anderes, als ob du da deinen eigenen Code laufen lässt.
Stell dir vor, du könntest besagt einen Jabbaclient schreiben, der deine Daten, der eine Schlüsselte Verbindung zum Beispiel aufbaut, mit deinem Key, du brauchst dich nicht an irgendeinen Third-Party-Provider zu wenden, der braucht nicht irgendeine Infrastruktur aufzubauen, sondern da läuft der Client auf dem Server und schickt mir immer eine Push-Notification, wenn was passiert. Oder ich hab einen RSS-Reader, der die ganze Zeit für mich im Hintergrund irgendwelche Feeds abklappert und mir die neuesten Sachen zuschickt.
Das glaube ich nicht. Na wieso? Ich meine, das ist, schau dir an, wer sind heutzutage die Player?
Die Teile dafür hätten sie.
Was sind die Firmen, die heutzutage die erfolgreichen Strategien fahren? Das ist Apple, Amazon, Google und Facebook. Das sind die Big Four. Das sind die Firmen, die derzeit definieren, wie die Zukunft aussieht. Und die betrummeln sich alle in der Wolke. Die eine oder die andere Art und Weise. Und sie bieten alle Plattformen an und sie bauen diese Plattformstrategie aus. Und auch Facebook kauft sich irgendwie Development-Buden. Also da passiert viel und auch Google lässt halt Software in der Cloud laufen. Und das nicht mal mit der App Engine. Also ich würde das jetzt, ich sage nicht, das passiert und das ist morgen irgendwie da. Und vielleicht ist das auch noch nie. Vielleicht ist das auch wirklich nicht Teil ihrer Strategie. Aber ausschließen würde ich das nicht. Weil das ganze Wording, so wie sie das rübergebracht haben, klingt für mich schon so, als ob sie nicht jetzt nur von so einer kleinen Erweiterung von einem Betriebssystem reden. So ein iCloud ist schon, allein schon wie sie das präsentiert haben. Lion, iOS, iCloud. Das ist nicht irgendwie jetzt auch mit iCloud, sondern das sind diese drei Sachen, wo vielleicht noch gar nicht absehbar ist, wohin die Reise geht. Und ich meine, da könnte man sich eine Menge einfallen lassen, wenn man erstmal da selber Software laufen lassen kann, wo man Sachen machen kann, wo man nicht dann auf Apple warten muss, sondern du schreibst das einfach und bezahlst Apple dafür, dass deine Software da läuft.
Beziehungsweise, das kriegen sie darüber wieder rein, dass sie da dein...
Da hast du die Hindernis Storage, da hast du die Performance und das spricht tatsächlich eine Menge für zum Apple ID und Authentication und diesen ganzen Kram kriegst du alles kostenlos und Kreditkarten und User und kaufen und so.
Ich stimme zu, dass es in der Theorie natürlich denkbar wäre und vielleicht auch teilweise wünschenswert, ich glaube halt einfach nicht daran, dass Apple das Delivert bekommt. Also ihr Track-Record mit Cloud und Web ist echt miserabel. Und ich warte, bevor ich da sozusagen mit einstimme in den Gesang, will ich erstmal sehen, was hier die iCloud, so wie sie jetzt...
Wollen wir das erstmal ein Jahr stabil laufen sehen. Das hat ja auch schon einen Grund, warum sie im ersten Jahr nicht gleich mit dem Store gekommen sind, sondern erstmal nur mit ihrem eigenen Shit.
Ich finde, da spricht eine Menge dafür. Zum einen haben sie, ich glaube sie haben die Technik, um das zu bauen. Sie haben dieses Sandboxing, was sie jetzt in Lion einbauen. Das ist natürlich für Lion schon allein ein schönes Thema, aber das wäre natürlich auch für so eine Cloud-Lösung genial, wenn du nicht für jeden Scheißdreck ein eigenes VM machen musst. Und sie haben halt einen Nachteil gegenüber zum Beispiel Android, in dem Sinne, dass wenn du eine vernetzte Applikation für Android schreibst, dann schreibst du theoretisch zumindest das Android-App in Java und du kannst den Server-Teil in Java schreiben. Dagegen als kleiner Coco-Programmierer, der nichts anderes kann, kannst du den Server-Teil nicht in Coco schreiben, außer du stellst dir irgendwo einen teuren Mac hin. Diese Cloud-Lösung gibt es da einfach nicht für. Und einfach dieses Objective-C, was sie eh schon rumfliegen haben, das zu kompilieren für irgendwie, und das läuft jetzt mal oben da in der Wolke, ist doch eigentlich total naheliegend.
Ja, wie gesagt, ich glaube ja auch nicht, ich sage ja nicht, dass es eine schlechte Idee ist oder ausgeschlossen. Ich vertraue halt Apples Internet-Track-Record noch nicht so richtig, also mal sehen. Vielleicht haben sich jetzt auch die richtigen Leute eingekauft und jetzt wird es das gelobte Land, aber wie gesagt, bisher...
Jetzt haben sie auch eine Idee. Jetzt ist es nicht mehr nur so ein Ansatz, so ein Aufsatz, den wir am Rand so irgendwo draufklatschen, sondern jetzt ist es plötzlich ein zentrales Element. Ich glaube, das war nämlich auch das Wesentliche bei dem, warum das so wichtig dargestellt worden ist. Das ist nicht irgendwie so ein Aufsatz für iOS oder so wie Mobile Mi war, oder Dot Mac, oder wie auch immer das jetzt heißt, sondern das ist jetzt wirklich... jetzt nehmen wir es auch ernst. Diesmal haben wir es richtig gemacht.
Der Chat will Beispiele ein, weil ihm nichts einfällt.
Naja, wie Max schon sagt, Server, was du sonst in Rails oder Python machst.
Angenommen, du willst halt sowas wie Amazon bauen. Du willst halt einen Store haben. In der iCloud hast du halt irgendwie Payment, Storage, Keyvalue, User, Authentification, alles da. Gehst da rein, hast gleich Millionen von Usern. Zack, noch eine iOS-App dazu. Selbes API, selbe Programmierumgebung. Alles ist in einem. Musst den ganzen Scheiß nicht selber machen. Musst keine Server betreiben. Musst keine Authentication machen. Musst keine Kundendatenbank führen.
Musst dich nicht umskalieren kümmern.
30% an Apple fertig ist die Sause.
Läuft dein Server mit Grand Central Dispatch auf der Cloud auf beliebig vielen Nodes, je nachdem, wie viele Münzen du einwirfst?
Kann alles.
Es müssen ja nicht unbedingt die großen Anwendungen sein. Nehmen wir die Einkaufsliste. Um so eine Einkaufsliste zu realisieren, die sich Leute miteinander teilen können, brauchst du irgendwo einen Server, der sich um die Daten kümmert. Und das könntest du über so eine Applikation lösen. Wobei du so eine Einkaufsliste kannst, wenn Key-Value-Storage über mehrere User-Sherber ist.
Dafür ist der iCloud da.
Von mehreren Usern haben sie auch wenig gesagt. Also was ihre Dienste betrifft, das könnte natürlich eine App tun. Ich hab jetzt noch gar nichts gelesen, was diese iCloud-Abi eigentlich kann.
Ich auch nicht.
Also wie gesagt, alles was ich bisher gehört habe ist...
So gesehen ist der iCloud nichts weiter als ein Filesystem für Programme, die auf dem iOS-Gerät laufen.
Ja, was mir noch gefehlt hat, also was wir jetzt noch kurz erwähnen müssen, ist hier iTunes in der Cloud. Wobei das fand ich ja eher, naja, also was ich nicht so ganz verstanden habe, also ok, du kannst halt jetzt deine ganzen gekauften Sachen jetzt schon...
für 25 Dollar im Jahr und nicht in Europa. Also aber nicht die eigenen Usi, sondern nur die gekauften Apple erst mal, genau.
Genau, aber das auch erst nur in den USA.
Und was ich mich da gefragt hab, also ich bin ja mit Dennis, wir sind ja so Losless-CD-Ripper, ne? Also wir machen ja hier nicht mehr so einen irgendwie verlustbehafteten Coleg, sondern wir rippen jetzt ja alles Losless von unseren gekauften CDs. Und wenn du jetzt sozusagen selbst gerippt hast, Losless auf deiner Platte, und du willst jetzt auf deinem iPhone, zahlst die 25 Dollar da, ne? Finden sie jetzt im Store raus, aha, du hast das, und kriegst jetzt 256 KBit AAC. Ob sie dann auch auf meiner Mac-Library sozusagen einen Downgrade dann durchführen und dann sozusagen, oder ob sie auf meinem Mac die Losless-Files lassen und nur auf dem Phone die 256 AAC-Files runterziehen und so.
Ich würde sagen, dass es jedenfalls so weit ist, oder?
Ich vermute mal, du wirst da auch immer noch Nein sagen können, aber...
Na ja, gerade nach meinem iPhone-Debake hier mit neuer Rechner und ich überstrecke dir mal alles, auch wieder so ein...
Also, wenn es mal 256 wäre, wäre ja toll, aber auch diese Apple-Option da, die automatisch irgendwie wieder umcoded auf 128, das find ich ja noch doof.
Also eigentlich haben sie das nicht geliefert. Was ist das? 25 Dollar pro Jahr für 5000 Songs?
Nee, für beliebig viele Songs.
Amazon hatte bis 5000, bei Apple war irgendwie frei.
Bei Apple? Sie haben auf jeden Fall von 20.000 auf geredet. Falsches notiert.
5000 Songs und darüber musstest du dann noch mal mehr bezahlen. Bei Apple war es egal, wie viel du hast.
Also du zahlst, so wie ich das verstanden hab, diese 25 und 29 Flat und kriegst dann pro Jahr einfach deine anderweitig besorgte Musik nochmal von Apple mit einem Gütesstempel drauf.
Genau, also für 5000 Songs kostet es 25 Dollar, für 20.000 Songs kostet es auch 25 Dollar. Ich nehme an, das ist nur der Grund, warum sie, um das klarzumachen, bei Amazon steigt der Preis. Je mehr Songs du hast, bei Apple bleibst du immer gleich.
Okay, also du zahlst 25.000, 25 Dollar im Jahr und dafür kannst du dann deine ganze Musik, egal wie viel es ist.
Und von wo du sie hast.
Aber es muss innerhalb dieses 5 Gigabyte Limit sein oder was?
Die Musik haben sie ja schon größtenteils. Du lest ja nur das Show, was sie nicht im Store haben.
Ach so, die Limit. Das Musik und Bilder zählen glaube ich nicht.
Aber die Musik haben sie ja eh schon rumliegen auf jeden Fall.
Die Musik aus dem iTunes.
Was zählt da nicht, was zählt da nicht, was zählt da nicht? Weil ich glaube nämlich Fotos zählen sehr wohl zu den 5 Gigabyte dazu. Apps natürlich nicht zum Beispiel.
Diese Fotostream-Geschichte zählt nicht dazu. Die Fotos, die du gerade geschossen hast, die für 30 Tage vorgehalten werden, die zählen nicht.
Da haben wir noch gar nicht drüber gesprochen.
Du hast sozusagen 30 Tage Zeit, weil sie sich ja relativ schnell auf irgendwas hinaufsünden, dann aus diesem Fotostream herauszunehmen. Also wenn du sie innerhalb von 30 Tagen noch nicht abgeholt hast mit irgendeinem Client, dann würden sie rausfallen. Aber diese Menge an Daten, die zählt zumindest nicht mit. Aber wenn du jetzt deine Fotos da drüber vorhalten willst, dann ist das sicherlich anders.
25.000 Songs sind Max bei Altion's Match.
25.000 Songs, guck an.
So, das ist nichts für uns.
Songs, was heißt das?
Ja, bestimmt.
Was ist das, wenn ich 25.000 Podcasts a 6 Stunden habe? Ist das dann dasselbe?
Dann treibst du Apple damit in die Pleite.
Let's do this. Das ist das nächste Wort, was ich sträflich vermisst habe, von Podcastsyncing. War hier einfach nicht die Rede. Ich meine, wenn iTunes in der Cloud ist, wo sind dann meine Podcastsyncs? Wo ist das Syncing von Feeds? Synchronisieren sich jetzt auch alle meine Devices in ihrem Podcastbezug? Lade ich dann die runtergeladenen Podcasts dann zu iTunes in die Cloud und synkt sich das dann daraus?
Nur, wenn du ein iTunes-Match bezahlst?
Nein.
Keine Ahnung, wie das läuft.
Das Wort Podcast kam nicht vor und es war mir vollkommen unklar, welche Rolle das da spielen kann. Ich meine, ich würde mir nun mindestens ein Syncing der Feeds wünschen. Wenn ich zwei Macs habe und ich subscribe einem Podcast, dass ich den auch auf dem anderen sehe. Die Frage ist natürlich, wo wird er jetzt runtergeladen? Wird er runtergeladen? Wird er überhaupt noch runtergeladen?
Wird er gesungen?
Wird er nur, lädt ihn iTunes für mich in die Cloud? Zählt das dann dazu oder nicht? Wann kann ich ihn runterladen? Wodurch kriege ich eine Push-Notification auf meinem iOS-Device? Was geht?
Was erlaube Strunz?
Was erlaube Steve?
Ich nehme einfach Instacast, dann habe ich diese Fragen alle nicht.
Aber mit Instacast habe ich auch noch nichts gesynkt. Das ist ja genau dasselbe Elend. Da weiß ich noch nicht mal mehr, was ich gehört habe.
Wobei das Bieten, also ein Syncing bieten sie an. Das kommt jetzt demnächst.
Instacast?
Was synken die dann?
Deine Podcast, deine Position, wo du als letztes gehört hast. Du legst dir über den Account an und dann ist es da. Ich nehme an, dass es ein iPad, also ist jetzt meine Vermutung, dass da noch ein iPad Klein kommt und dass da noch ein Mac Klein kommt.
Dann wissen die, was ich gehört habe. Instacast ist evil.
Du, Apple mit der iCloud erstmal über dich weiß alles.
Na gut, ich hab da nichts zu gehört und es ist mir überhaupt nicht im geringsten klar, ob sie da auch nur eine Sekunde drüber nachgedacht haben. Und was diese 5 GB Storage betrifft, ich meine, iDisk war bisher 20 GB.
Ja, das ist auch kostenlos.
Na ja gut, aber was kostet denn dann extra? Haben sie auch nicht gesagt.
Ich nehme an, da haben sie nicht mal Preise für.
Diese Eierwolke echt.
Wobei, ich glaube die 5 GB reichen schon eine ganze Weile, weil du brauchst ja ein ganzes Haufen Zeug nicht reinzupacken. Also zum Beispiel die Musik, die man auf seinem iPhone hat, braucht man da nicht drin. Die ganzen Apps, die den meisten Platz wegnehmen, brauchst du auch nicht zu sünden. Die liegen sowieso noch mal separat. Was du hast, sind ja tatsächlich, die große Masse sind deine Fotos, die du offen gerät hast.
Mit den Apps sünden meinen sie ja eher den Content, den die Apps erzeugen und nicht die Apps selbst.
Es geht ja darum, wenn du dein iPhone verlierst und du holst dir ein neues iPhone und du gibst deine Apple-ID ein, dann soll alles so sein wie vorher.
Die Apps waren ja nicht dabei bei den 5GIG.
Ja, genau, die brauchst du bei den 5GIG nicht. Sondern nur die App-Daten. Aber das ist ja im Allgemeinen nicht so wahnsinnig viel.
TomTom?
TomTom, das sind doch die App-Daten, der lädt doch nichts runter. Das ist doch nur das App selber, was die große Masse ist.
Achso, und wenn dann neue Karten kommen, kommen die mit einem Update, verstehe ich.
Genau, oder wenn dann, es gibt ja sowieso beim iPhone diese zwei Directories. Daten, die wirklich gespeichert werden müssen, auch im Backup, speichern sie in eine Directory. Und Cache-Daten, die man im Zweifelsfall wieder herstellen kann, die speichert man in einer anderen. Und ich würde sagen, TomTom, Kartenmaterial gehört definitiv in diese temporäre Daten-Cache-Files, was im Zweifelsfall eben auch nicht im Backup gestoart wird, sondern was dann eben, dann muss das eben nachgeladen werden, wenn TomTom neues Kartenmaterial hat und dann ein iPhone verloren. Aber es geht ja nur darum, iCloud ist ja dieses Backup, ist ja nur dafür da, bring mein Telefon wieder in den Zustand, wie es vorher war. Und dafür muss es ja nicht, brauchst ja nicht den gleichen Speicherplatz, den das iPhone belegt.
Oder hat.
War das jetzt zu Confuse?
Ich denke nur ein bisschen nach.
Diese Wolke ist noch ganz schön wolkig.
Was ist noch sehr wolkig? Also, ich meine, dass sie Backup drin haben, finde ich groß. Also, dass sie das einfach berücksichtigen. Ich meine, es ist irgendwie naheliegend. Sie hätten es machen müssen, wenn es nicht drin gewesen wäre, hätte man sofort wieder mit dem Finger auf sie zeigen. Das muss. Aber.
Das hat mittlerweile sogar Google.
Wie Android-Telefone.
Ich glaube 233 oder 233, ja kann das.
Ach so, das kriegen die dann. Wann die exzertieren den Telefon in zwei Jahren? Oder nie? Man muss ein neues Telefon kaufen.
Wenn du Nexus hast, dann kannst du es sofort. Das war doch heute das HTC Desire. Haben sie ja gestern angekündigt, wird es kein Gingerbread heißen, kein 233 für geben, HTC.
Nicht genug RAM.
Nicht genug RAM? Jetzt sind sie wieder zurückgerufen. Oder haben gesagt, dann haben sie festgestellt, hat doch mehr RAM. Oder ich weiß nicht, also.
Sie haben einfach nur gesagt, Contrary to our prior statement, we will release.
Hat es doch genug RAM.
Ich glaube, so viel Alarm, dass sie nochmal umdenken mussten.
Ich glaube, die haben echt in die Fresse gekriegt dafür.
Die Marktverunsicherung ist wirklich maximal da.
Ich glaube vor allen Dingen, das ist ein Telefon, das du noch kaufen kannst. Und wenn du das kaufst unter der Bedingung, weil dir der Hersteller gesagt hat, wir bringen da zwei, drei drauf. Und dann sagt der Hersteller plötzlich, oh, machen wir doch nicht. Ja, also dieses Backup, das muss sein.
Also Jungs, ich bin durch.
Machs schlapp, du warst letztes Mal nicht dabei.
Du musst jetzt bis zum bitteren Ende.
Ja, das ist schon bitter die ganze Zeit.
Ist es?
Aber...
Ja, mach das schon.
Wegen halt dieser ganzen Wolkigkeiten, ja. Das macht mir bei mir so auch so ein Gefühl, wo ich denke, eben hier so mit Cloud-Hosts und so weiter. Ich weiß es nicht, ob sie das hinkriegen. Also warten wir mal ab, was die da mit dieser Cloud wirklich delivern und was da drin ist und was nicht. Und dann sehen wir mal weiter hier, ob sie gewappnet sind für wolkige Ausflüge.
Ich glaube, sie wissen... Ich meine, die haben da ein Datens... dieses Riesen? Filter-Center aus dem Boden gestampft und so. Die wissen also da jetzt nicht mehr allzu viele Schüsse in der Richtung Freiheim und dass es langsamer sitzen muss.
Steve hat versprochen, dass diesmal everything just works.
Was macht ihn da so sicher?
Er hat gesagt, wenn es nicht funktioniert, rollen da Köpfe.
Weil sie es ernst genommen haben, glaube ich. Weil sie eine Strategie hinter haben, weil sie ähnlich viel Hirnschmalz reingesteckt haben, die sie normalerweise nur in ihre Telefone und MacBooks stecken.
Das wäre ihnen zu wünschen.
Das ist meine Vermutung.
Ja, noch korrekter Hinweis aus dem Chat. Ein weiteres Wort, von dem ich wenig gehört habe, ist Verschlüsselung. Also wenn ich es richtig sehe, sind die Backups schon verschlüsselt. Aber gesagt... Haben sie es?
Ich weiß es nicht. Zum Thema Verschlüsselung haben sie nur gesagt, iMessage ist verschlüsselt von einem Gerät. Also das haben sie halt gesagt. Ich nehme an, dass da auf jeden Fall überall eine SSL-Verschlüsselung drauf sein wird.
Ich rede jetzt von Backup.
Ja klar. Um sich nicht die Google Blöße zu geben, die sich da mit dem Kalender und dem ganzen Zeug gemacht haben. Ob das nachher dann bei Apple nochmal verschlüsselt ist, ist natürlich mal eine spannende Frage. Im Zweifelsfall mit welchem Passwort? Muss bei Apple alles neu verschlüsselt werden, wenn ich mein Passwort ändere? Ich glaube nicht.
Glaube ich auch nicht, weil die nutzen ja auch Data-D Duplication, sonst könnten sie sich das ja alles gar nicht erlauben und das würde dann nicht mehr greifen.
Moment mal, also für Apps, meine Apps brauchen sie ja wirklich nicht zu verschlüsseln. Die habe ich bei ihnen gekauft, die sind eins zu eins dieselben. Wenn ich da ein Telefon verliere, dann brauche ich nicht, will ich nicht. Aber meine Daten, die müssen verschlüsselt sein. Und dafür können sie sowieso keine D Duplication machen. Na mein Foto ist mein Foto, was ich gemacht habe mit meiner Kamera, das hat keiner los in mir.
Du scherst ja nicht dein Backup mit anderen Leuten.
Ja, aber wenn du Zeug an deinem Backup hast, so Bilder, Programme, Zeug, was andere Leute auch haben, dann machen wir D Duplication.
Ja, aber das ist ja nicht so viel. Ich meine, wenn du so ein iPhone backups, das ist ja nicht viel.
Aber ich habe genau die gleichen Bookmarks, die Hucke.
Wobei, das kann auch schon viel sein. Ich meine, wenn du Instacast da ordentlich runterladen lässt, auch diese ganzen runtergeladenen MP3s.
Aber Instacast ist, wenn du, ich habe es ja gerade gemacht, wenn du einen Restore machst und dann ist Instacast wieder drauf, dann sind alle deine Subscriptions da.
Aber die files nicht?
Aber die files nicht. Achso, was heißt das? Das habe ich doch gerade gesagt, die liegen in dieser Cache Directory. Du kannst bei einem Anlegen von Dateien auf dem iPhone...
Okay, okay, verstehe. Ja, das heißt, dass die Datenmenge darüber schaubar ist. Weil die Apps kommen nie mit rein. Das ist eigentlich nur die per App Storage im Wesentlichen. Und was sie so an Settings sonst noch so sichern müssen, um das OS quasi frisch wiederherzustellen.
Also ich hab die stark...
Also das wär voll das iCloud Pro-Feature, wenn sie sagen, das wird auf dem iPhone verschlüsselt, dann hochgeschickt und die bei Apple können eigentlich überhaupt gar nichts damit anfangen.
Und du kannst noch bei Find My iPhone Remote Wipe auch in der Cloud damit tricken.
Wo liegen die Backups nochmal?
Jetzt mal ganz unter uns. Apple bietet an, dass ich mir den Schlüssel für meine Festplattenverschlüsselung doch zu ihnen hochladen kann. Glaubt ihr, dass die ernsthaft darüber nachdenken? Was? Was wirst du?
Die Backups, war das Application?
Library, Application, Support, Mobile, irgendwas.
Mobile Backup, oder sowas. Mobile Sync. Mobile Sync? Mobile Sync Backup, genau.
Ich find's auch echt spannend, dass ganz viele Leute gar nicht diesen Column-View im Finder benutzen, sondern dieses Ausklappen, das find ich so anstrengend da zu navigieren.
Column-View, dieser Next-Step-Dings, das ist ja voll anstrengend.
Das ist vielleicht total großartig, so schnell und übersichtlich.
Schnell, ach, Schnack, Schnack.
Der Desk-View ist super, da kann ich hier mehrere Sachen gleichzeitig ausgeklappt haben, das geht alles nicht im Column-View. Ich hab hier doch ganz erhebliche Backup-Größen, aber ich kann natürlich gerade gar nicht sehen, welcher Ordner hier gerade was ist. Was hab ich denn zuletzt gebacked up? Mein Telefon, Today. 685 Megabyte.
Das ist nicht so viel. Also ich kann mir vorstellen, mit diesen 5 Gigabyte, dass man da wirklich seine gesamten iOS-Geräte unterbringt.
Das ist aber jetzt mehr, als ich dachte. Aber ich hab, glaub ich, auch ganz ordentlich... Was könnte denn da so schwer sein?
Kannst du noch mal reingucken? Gibt ja da dieses...
Kann man irgendwo sehen, welche ist ab wieviel belegt?
Nein, nicht einfach so.
Es gibt so ein...
Keine Ahnung, wie es heißt. Backup LS oder sowas. Also da ist ja so eine XML-Datei drinne, in der verschlüsselt ist, wie jede Datei heißt. Also wo die sich befindet. Und es gibt so ein LS-Programm, mit dem kannst du dir die ganzen Daten darin mal anzeigen lassen.
Wenn es nicht verschlüsselt ist, sozusagen.
Wenn es nicht verschlüsselt ist, klar.
Ein CD-Rolling, also die werden ja da in ihrem Data Center so viel Storage haben, dass das für doppelt so viele User reicht, wie sie jetzt gerade haben bestimmt, mit 5 GB pro Person.
Und ich hab irgendwo gehört, sie haben sich ja nochmal die gleiche Fläche reserviert, um nochmal genau das gleiche Data Center nochmal aufzubauen. Also die sind auf Wachstum ausgelegt.
Na gut, aber wenn du Millionen User-Daten und so anvertraust mit Backups und so weiter, dann willst du auch nicht einen Data Center nur haben, was dann mal wo eine Boeing rein segelt und...
Ist natürlich das direkt daneben zu stellen natürlich auch doof.
Ach, das soll direkt daneben sein? Waren sie nicht auch in anderen Bundesstaaten sowieso schon auch noch?
Achso, keine Ahnung. Zur Not spielen das alles auf irgendwelche Amazon-VMS.
Ich hätte es ja in Alaska gebaut, gleich so mit Nature Cooling.
Das UFO!
Das Mutterschiff!
Haben wir eigentlich schon über Gesten geredet?
Ach komm, du willst doch bloß, dass du in dem nächsten Vorspann auftaust.
Wir sollten mehr über Gesten. Epilog meinetwegen. Ein paar Worte noch. Ich hab mir das angeschaut.
Du hast dir das Video auch angeschaut. Ich fand das ja echt cool.
Habt ihr euch das auch angeschaut?
Einen Tag nach der Keynote war Steve Jobs in Cupertino bei ihrem Kauzl und hat vorgestellt, was sie da bauen wollen. Im Wesentlichen pflanzen sie da einen Park, wo ein UFO landet. Sie machen da ein ganz spaciges, vier Etagen, kreisrundes Gebäude hin, wo sie 12.000 Employees unterbringen wollen. Ansonsten renaturieren sie den ganzen FU und bauen sich auch ihr eigenes Kraftwerk dahin und wollen ihren eigenen Strombedarf von diesem Kraftwerk decken und benutzen das Public Network, das Stromnetz der Stadt als Backup.
Die Begründung dafür fand ich ja heiß, dass wenn mal das Stromnetz ausfällt, weil wir da nicht alle 12.000 Leute nach Hause schicken können, brauchen wir ein Ausfallsystem. Da sieht man mal, wie durch das amerikanische Stromnetz mittlerweile ist, dass das offensichtlich so ein Standardfall ist, den man einfach einplant. Ich glaube, hier wäre das noch wesentlich ein Katastrophenfall. Wenn es so ist, dann ist es halt so. Dann geht halt alle nach Hause, wenn es alle fünf Jahre mal vorkommt. Aber da scheint das ja zumindest mit eingeplant zu sein.
Das Stromnetz in Amerika ist schon relativ rotten, wie so vieles andere.
Ist das auch ein Silicon Valley?
Ich finde es eigentlich jetzt schon. Darum bauen sie ja U-Foos, damit sie wegfliegen können.
Na, ich glaube, wenn einer noch das nötige Kleingeld hat, dann Apple.
Was ich ja echt krass fand, ist ja immer so gefragt worden, ja, und was geben sie der Stadt dafür zurück?
Strom.
Ne, ne, ja, wir sind ja hier auch einer der größten Steuerzahler. Oder wir sind der Größte. Wir zahlen ja hier auch Steuern. Ja, aber können sie uns nicht hier so kostenloses Wi-Fi machen? Naja, wir finden schon, wir zahlen hier Steuern. Was ist denn die Aufgabe der Stadt, das zu machen?
Ne, er meinte, da werden wir dann keine Steuern mehr zahlen.
Also, auf der einen Seite, was ich ja ganz okay finde, dass man irgendwie, dass hier nicht irgendwie so Firmen anfangen, Infrastruktur aufzubauen, die eigentlich die Stadt aufbauen müsste. Auf der anderen Seite aber schon dieser deutliche Hinweis, wenn wir das jetzt nicht dürfen, dann sind wir woanders. Und das wäre natürlich schade für uns alle.
Für uns alle?
Also ich, weil ich die Stadt Carpatino so mag, und ihr wegen der Steuern.
Naja, ich glaub, er muss da gar nicht so alarm an, das versteh ich schon.
Das ist auf jeden Fall ein amtliches Headquarter und das ist sozusagen so das letzte...
Ich fand das auch geil.
Das letzte Stück Apple auf diesem Planeten, was noch nicht ordentlich designt ist, ist halt ihr Headquarter und das haben sie damit auch dann ausgemerzt, das Problem.
Ehrlich gesagt, als ich die Fotos davon gesehen hab, hab ich gedacht, wow, da würd ich gern mal arbeiten. Das heißt, bei diesem alten, hab ich das nie gedacht. Da hab ich nie gedacht, so, da möcht ich mal arbeiten.
Aber das sind doch die schicken Icons hier im Hof.
Die haben doch da so die ganz uralten 80er Jahre Icons da am hochstehenden groß.
Hier Claros the Dog, oder wie heißt dieser Hund?
Dokkau.
Claros the Dokkau.
Genau, steht da auch noch da rum, oder?
Ich glaub schon.
Ich glaub, aus Street View kann man den noch sehen. Steht da noch. Der Icon Park.
Kann schon sein.
Ja, aber das ist voll und das will man nicht mehr. Und das UFO ist besser. Und nur angeblich jede Scheibe Glas in dem Gebäude ist so...
Rund....
ist rund, weil das Ganze ja komplett rund ist. Und dadurch wahrscheinlich kostet es schon......
ein Tempel.
Deswegen muss das nächste iPhone mindestens 1000 Euro kosten.
In dem Park wahrscheinlich.
Und dann kommt ein Erdbeben.
Und alles ist weg.
Ich hoffe ja, der Olle Steve macht's noch eine Weile.
Ja, bestimmt.
Halt durch die...
Na ja, aber es sollte jetzt mal langsam dann doch wieder ein paar Pfunde zunehmen, finde ich.
Ja, so ein bisschen Fleisch kann nicht schaden. Was ist der? Ich hab... Frutana ist der? Hab ich gehört? Ich weiß nicht, ob es stimmt. Das ist noch unterveganer. Ich glaube, das ist nur noch Rohkostessen. Und... Also irgendwie klang es, als ob man schon allein von dieser Ernährung so aussieht, wie er aussieht, ohne dass man da irgendeine Krankheit dazu hat.
Bist du sicher?
Ich...
Frutaria?
So, sind wir jetzt durch mit unseren Themen?
Er war wohl mal.
Ach, er war mal, okay.
Seine Ärzte werden ihm schon sagen, was er zu machen hat. Ich glaube, er kann jetzt nicht mehr wirklich ne sagen.
Ja, ich weiß nicht. Hat der Chat noch irgendwelche Anmerkungen?
Ist das Steve Jobs jemand, das dir auf seine Ärzte hört?
Ich inzwischen denke ich...
Mittlerweile ja.
Nächstes Mal reden wir auch wieder über Hardware.
Und über Windows 8.
Hardware ist geiler eigentlich, ne? Hardware ist der Hammer.
Ich kann nicht sagen, ich mach so viel mit Hardware. Software ist das Ding.
Software ist so viel besser als Hardware. Hardware ist nur mitten zum Zug.
Die machen Hardware und Software und nur zusammen macht Spaß.
Ja, also diese neue SSD, ne?
Hier gibt's Gerüchte.
Wir hatten das ZFS-Keyword und jetzt hab ich nochmal kurz das SSD-Keyword gedroppt. Ja, ich hab's vorhin erwähnt.
Und was könntest du damit abschießen mit dem Unterirdischen? It's still targeted at Eric Schmidt.
Rooftop Segway Racing Track wasn't insisted.
Wir lachen hier gerade, weil Joy of Tech und die Karikatur...
Sehr schön sind da auch die Lions, die da rumrennen im...
Oh Mann, oh Mann, oh Mann, oh Mann. Okay Leute, ich glaube wir machen jetzt hier mal ein Ende, denn es rollt schon mit den Augenhuckel auch.
Ich roll mit dem Stuhl.
Das war unser Wrap-Up.
Oh Mann, ja, also echt.
Das war unser kurzer Überblick. Demnächst dann die ausführliche Version.
Nächstes Mal Teil 2.
Wenn es dann rausgekommen ist, dann müssen wir uns ja noch alles nochmal genau angucken.
Wir klicken live jedes Feature einzeln an.
Wir besprechen jetzt jeden Pixel in der Line.
Eine Sendung pro Feature.
Wir müssen mal wieder auch mehr über Macs reden. Also neben anderen Sachen auch.
Ja, ich hoffe, dass ich hier bald über Macs reden kann, weil ich scharre ja schon mit den Hufen, um einen MacBook Air-Upgrade zu führen.
Wann kommt das jetzt? Also ich meine deine Prognose...
Wer weiß es schon.
Ich hab ja so ein bisschen auf Dienstag gehofft, dann kam nur dieses scheiß Unlocked iPhone 4, was keine so interessiert.
Was haben sie gesagt zum Thema Lion? Juli ist in zwei Wochen.
Also Juli würde mir noch reichen.
Also ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass sie das eher schon mit Lion rausbringen.
Ja, das würde total passen, oder?
Nee, die bringen es natürlich kurz vorher raus, dass du ein Upgrade kaufen musst.
Ach, sowas machen die nicht.
Ich kauf's.
Siehst du, als wenn ich dann einen R kaufe und ich habe einen Lion, habe ich dann auch gleich die Lizenz, um es auf meinen anderen Rechner zu machen? Wahrscheinlich nicht, ne?
Und auf deine Apple-ID-Geräte.
Naja, aber du musstest ja aus dem App-Store nochmal runterladen.
Ja, wahrscheinlich. Also für die Upgrades muss ich es dann schon noch mindestens einmal kaufen. Oh mein Gott.
Siehst du, dass du schon auf Säcke-Max drauf reingibst?
Die werden dann höllen Geld verdienen mit diesem Upgrade. Ja, nicht wie immer. Ja, aber ich kann mir auch vorstellen, dass die Images da gut übers Netz gegangen sind. Ist da was ich glaube, wie sie das ThroughStore machen? Ob sie das dann bei Lion irgendwie unterbunden haben? Haben sie nicht, ne? Da ist irgendwie so in diesen bisherigen Distributionen immer so ein Disk-Image mit drin, dass man sich noch brennen kann. Ja, das muss auch sein.
Ich glaube ja, dass sie... Die haben doch bei deinem MacBook Air da ist doch auch so ein kleiner USB-Stick dabei. Ich behaupte jetzt einfach mal, in Lion wird es ein Feature geben, mit dem man diesen USB-Stick einfach auf die neueste Version bringen kann, dass er dann im Zweifelsfall, wenn irgendwas schief geht, die neueste Version von Lion direkt installiert. Also das bleibt ein Installationsmedium.
Das ist ein ROM.
Sicher? Ist das nicht einfach nur, dass da irgendwie Soweit ich weiß, ist das ein ROM.
Vielleicht haben sie da einen hidden bit und dann ist es RAM, aber...
Das kommt. Vielleicht noch nicht mit DIME, aber das kommt.
Ich will auf jeden Fall ein neues R haben. Ich brauch mehr Hardware. Genau.
Ich will 1,8 Gigabyte RAM.
Das ist ein ganz normaler USB-Stick. Also. Spielen wir noch ein Lied zum Ende.
Oder muss Huckel wieder auf der Mateflasche flöten?
Stimmt, wir hätten eigentlich unterschiedliche Füllstände in den Mateflaschen heute mal zum Ende haben sollen.
Na gut, dann sagen wir jetzt mal ordentlich Tschüss.
Was ist das denn Geiles? Das ist der Schluss, was jetzt gleich kommt.
Nee, kann ich nicht.
Guck ich mir jetzt auch an.
Bis bald.